[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
we win we win oh my God welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives we got him let's go see him
and that's it he does the job
Sam entering its Fifth Season 16 teams
will reboot the PCL Legacy with a new
format and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion oh my God this is on the
other side what did we just see
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
the pro chess league is back
International Master Danny Rancher
alongside Grand Master Robert Hess we're
back Robert it's been it's been way too
long I can't wait to dive into today
with you
it's been so long that I can't find the
shirt the very shirt that you're wearing
I had one we wore them together way back
in the day so I'm a little jealous that
you're sporting yours for those who
don't know this is a a shirt we got at
the live pro chess League finals in San
Francisco 2019. uh we are so glad that
it's back and of course hope to have
many more of those live finals in the
future but Robert I I mean normally I
try to have something funny to say to
throw you off guard and get the
resentment going early you know but I
feel like I don't even need to do that
today I feel like you're already ready
on edge hosting with me
I certainly am because we have great
matchups in store today and you're you
and I'm me so it's going to be a fun day
regardless it's gonna be a blast let's
let's dive into first before we talk
about the matchups we got four teams
throwing down today it's going to be
epic let's remind everybody as the
season has really just kicked off in the
last week or so here uh but the most
important dates are for them to pay
attention to the regular season taking
place over February and March that Arena
Royale date is going to be a lot of fun
we'll talk about that four minutes it
gets closer and then of course as we get
into the playoffs and the finals Robert
uh what what sticks out to you I know
you've got all these dates marked you
are you are really the guy hosting
almost every show that's happening so uh
how pumped are you for the season
it's going to be really exciting I mean
we already saw some epic matchups in
week one we're still in week one so I
have the playoff circled eight teams
make their way through and with the
format that we have in place I mean it's
you don't know who is going to make it
until we see teams win three matches in
the regular season
yeah it's it's a format that really
keeps everybody on the edge of their
seat regardless of how they're doing and
it's something for those who are Mega
fans of the PCL you've been following
this thing for for all five years you
know that as the season goes on it you
know some teams fortunes are different
than others but we're really pumped
about how everyone is going to be
engaged and still have a lot to fight
for as the season goes on but regardless
of the Season format let's talk about
the actual match format before we get
into the matchups it's all play all
first to eight and a half points uh
those are the those are the two major
takeaways the 10-2 time control I
haven't jumped in this week and and seen
how the action is on the board Robert
but uh your thoughts on on anything else
to highlight about the format here
it's awesome because if teams are tied
eight to eight you're you can see all 16
games played then you go into the tie
bricks which is just Mayhem and the
teams they repeat their board around for
excuse me uh order of pairings they swap
colors and they go at it and we saw some
epic matches just yesterday in that tie
break
yeah the uh the fact that if it's tied
we get more chesses just I feel like we
have to design every format to do that
what Whoever thought it was okay to end
chess in a tie like who had that idea
it wasn't me I you know it wasn't it
wasn't you I may put the Hess and chest
but I do not put the draw in chest you
did not put the draw in chest and you
can't spell draw with I and there's no I
in team anyway I'm pretty sure it checks
out let's check out the results from
Wednesday uh we got uh we got big names
going down in every matchup we saw that
the Wizards took down the Garden State
passers uh heart goes out to our boy
Donya who I wish we could talk to him
about that maybe at some point we could
and then the Gnomes uh an epic and very
hype fashion took down the the maniac
shrimps which I still can't get over
every time I read Maniac shrimps
can't get over the name I can't get over
the logo that logo is just awesome same
with the all the logos really but that
one sticks out to me and Maniac shrimps
they deserved a beer they qualify their
way through
yeah well the the uh reaction of young
Ludwig Hammer as his team got the job
done and kind of in kind of Epic fashion
right this is sort of what protest
League Dreams Are Made of or how hearts
are broken we're gonna let Hammer's
enthusiasm take it away
take the knights take the night yes
Laura's gonna win it it's nine and a
half it's all decided with kawain it's
all decided with Gawain
but the weight is Gonna Lose It Go Wayne
eluses don't wait to lose this up to no
he wins
it because
the game we win we win we win oh my God
we were down to rock we went down
[Laughter]
this is gonna be I have a feeling that
the the the way the league has been
structured this year Robert we've got
the main show here and of course we want
everyone to stick with us but every team
has a captain in addition to a manager
and sort of our version of empowering
the the broader chess community and
streamers to kind of provide their own
coverage for fans of the team and we're
gonna get more and more moments like
that I mean Hammer I think lost his
voice I think he spit all over his
camera he literally lost his bleep in
that call right there I don't think I've
ever seen Hammer react like that in all
the hours we've commentated together
yeah usually Mr comp Cola collected but
he lost his Marvels I mean he was just
all out for his team and that's the kind
of support you need to win an event like
the pro chessing every single team is
quite stacked I was gonna say where's
the where's the stoic calm the face the
face of of so many Norwegian uh chess
shows in Norway of course uh Hammer
Hammer I think I think he has a home
there on Twitch commentating for his
gnome so uh all right let's talk about
the matchups today Robert we start
things off with mgd1 uh the second team
from India uh very much a Powerhouse
we're gonna talk about that versus The
Blitz uh this is this is a team of of
mainly mainly Frenchmen and French women
um along with some other free agents I'm
pretty pumped for that one and then of
course we have the Berlin bears taking
on the Gotham knights with the the
largest the biggest chess Creator on
YouTube Levy Rosman the Gotham chess uh
with the biggest streamer on Twitch for
chassis car Nakamura um which matchup
are you most excited for I mean they're
both coming up obviously we start with
mgd1 versus The Blitz
I have to say the mgd1 team just the
team from India they are loaded both
teams from India are just awesome but
the blitz I think they're kind of a wild
card to me because it's a family team
this is a family show and they've got
two different husband wife uh teammates
set of teammates and they also have a
father-son Duo what more could you ask
for
I love that you said it's a family show
as if you were reminding me of how
appropriate I need to be today was that
I don't know what that was about this is
a good old-fashioned Family Fun uh the
jokes will only be awkward and subtle
um all right you're right it is a family
team though let's talk about how these
rosters are stacked up because it's one
of the reasons I think we have the
Family Affair you talked about Robert
every team must include at least two
women and at least one Junior the teams
can add up to eight players most teams I
think already have their full rosters uh
but you can you can add up to eight
players by by the middle of the Season
uh and the players must stick with the
team they play a single game for that's
to prevent kind of mid-season swapping
not sure that that would happen but uh
the uh the roster for the as you said
MGD one
um and and the blitz are both are both
stacked with a lot of people who who
know each other quite well so your
thoughts though on how the structures of
these rosters come about
yeah you know you just want to pick the
best players possible that's what this
format does for every single team
because when a 2700 plus player has
counted as 2700 you want the highest
rated players in the world on your squad
and yeah Arjun era geisey he leads the
way for mgd1 uh that's one of the
biggest names in chess he said that 1.5
million dollar deal with Quant box and
mgd1 they're an agency they've helped
him secure that kind of financial uh
outcome so great for them and great for
the squad that was such a huge thing for
chess that I wonder uh how how I wonder
how much it flew under the radar for
people to really appreciate that our
generic I see the reigning Junior speech
has championed by the way uh and and
someone who's just making a name for
himself every time he plays chess uh he
has signed at least in my mind the most
lucrative public deal we've ever seen on
record I mean it's incredible to have
the sponsorship that he does obviously
as you said MGD won the agency that
helped him secure that
um but we also have uh the beast audibon
on this team right you know how much I
love watching him throw down in this
format harika dronavali of course
someone who's been playing in the
protesting I feel like since the
beginning she always performs in the
rapid time controls uh this this is
going to be epic the uh the only uh
non-indian flag there is Amin Tava to
buy of course we see there
um a mean a star and someone who we know
does very well on jess.com in just about
any fast time control he can get his
hands on so this is going to be a team
but they're going up against the Blitz
and we mentioned it's a family affair we
told Danny subtly to keep it appropriate
what sticks out to you of the many
family pairings on the blitz roster
it's gonna be Alexander grishook the
face you see on screen there with his
wife Katarina Lucknow look at her rating
by the way 2563 in this league that
counts 23.50 against the cap so they
have 200 plus rating points to spare so
that uh husband wife Duo is as dangerous
as it gets perhaps the best in chess
history and so with Maxine versus by the
way that's your boy Danny that's MBL and
he isn't even the highest rated player
on this team
no it's crazy when you think of a team
of top French chess players you just
assume mvl is number one most the time
but getting grishek that two-headed
monster of MBL and Alexander grishek is
going to be a force to reckon with for
for any team of course uh Matthew
Cornett um and Damonte uh do let Cornett
also um a uh a family family deal there
and then we mentioned Etienne bakrow and
his son Alexandra bakrow
um this is uh this is gonna be fun I I
feel like we almost need to have like uh
excuse me losing my voice already it's
early we need to have some sort of Fam
Family uh show show here to to really
give this team even more of an edge but
all right
Robert we've talked about the rosters I
guess we should you mentioned quickly
about how it works uh with the rating
cap for top women players so let's
actually bring that up too and talk
about the rules of of how the uh the
lineup rules come into play week in and
week out
yes for sure that each lineup if they're
four players on a team you have to at
least one woman playing for your roster
you have a 25 50 average rating that
said if you have players over 2700 they
count as 2700 against the cap and the
same deal for women over 23.50 you want
to have the strongest players in the
world on your team Magnus Carlson a
great find because while he's 28.50 plus
he counts at 2700. Kennedy lock no we
saw her at 25.63 but she clocks in at
23.50 against the cap you want the best
players the blitz they've secured
themselves a monster lineup as have most
the teams in the league they're taking
it seriously
yeah and it shows that this is sort of
the game within the game right obviously
once the game starts we know what we do
this is a chess show it is a family
friendly chess show and we'll be talking
about the X's and O's but for the
managers and obviously the you know the
composition of these rosters is is
really a key part of Victory and you may
not think about it once the chess starts
but if you tend to notice some teams
getting more points on different boards
look look for the gamesmanship of how
they really recognize the potential to
take advantage of the different rating
caps so all right let's talk about the
games uh that will go down and the
matchups that will be in store right
away uh the board assignments directly
before you you see Arjun era guys see
Alexander grishek all the way down uh to
board four Robert before we talk about
who plays who in the first round what
particular matchup just comparing board
ones to board ones board two to board
two Etc sticks out to you here
I think it's Savita Street Ward 4 for
team MGD one for the Indian yogis
vaishali scored one and a half points
out of three games because that team won
early that is critical the success of
your board four you may live or die by
their performance I think Savita shrees
was only 16 years old she's over 2 400.
she is up and coming and she's already
there she may score some points but this
two-headed monster at the top for the
Blitz the 2700 pluses that's not really
good when you're a board for it you
don't want to face those beasts on the
top too
it's funny because you picked board four
and I think it's a great choice and I
think it's a great storyline to remember
the one thing that makes the protestly
great is it may come down to your board
Force performance not your your most
recognizable name Magnus Carlson for
example on board one but I really got to
go with the board to break down there I
think iRig I see and grishek in some
ways is a bit of a coin toss I might
even give her a guy see the nod right in
faster time controls he's such such a
great player up and coming but I feel
like Maxine Bossier the grav over over
niranyan is uh is that's the one that
that kind of leans the Blitz the blitz
way
yeah I feel that I mean SL Mariana he
plays a lot on chess.com he's a
fantastic player in his own right but
we're talking about Maxime lagrav a
world Blitz Champion I mean he's a
Mainstay in the speed Chess Championship
so I get you I think that it's going to
be tough sledding or team mgd1 and even
in the first round right we get to see
those a lot-sided pairings because board
one plays board four uh Danny I'm really
excited to get this one uh going because
I think that every single matchup every
single round there will be some great
games I love that you said the the board
four board one matchup because again in
the end of a match you're obviously
focused on whatever dramatic game is
going down there but a lot of these
matches are won early on those upsets
can happen for your team right if Savita
can somehow you know skate Alexander
grishek in the first game like what does
that do for MGD one's chances for the
rest of the day right so pay attention
fans we got more than 5 000 of you on
Twitch I'll pull up YouTube here as well
thanks so much for being with us I'm uh
I'm pumped and
and I know the games are going to be
starting any moment now so here we go
um all right good
now as I say I'm really excited because
in board four first board one you see
that the board four players uh they have
the white pieces so it's not an
automatic win for those 2700 plus
players I mentioned vaishali she beat
Super he was playing for the Brazil
Capybaras he's beaten Magnus Carlsen in
that famous fishing pole game so we do
see these upsets happen so with the
white pieces you know you need to score
some points I mean that would be huge
for your team's chances if you're the
billboard four for either team mgd1 or
Blitz it's a great point because you
know with the highest levels of Chess
plain white with the first move a huge
advantage and even if some of these
names are not you know the most
recognizable right away they are very
strong chess players and when you have
that first move advantage in terms of
preparation and being able to guide the
game down the line that you want that's
how upsets happen and an upset is just a
draw right the lower rated player all
they need to do they don't need to
strike a deadly blow even just getting a
half Point kind of nicking away at the
potential of the top board so I love
that the lower rated players start out
with white in the First games all right
you talked about savita's chances what
kind of chances do we give Damonte De
Monte against Arjun
she's very experienced in the Pro chess
League I know the type show this year 10
minutes plus two second increment but
she has that experience she's played all
these top players before I just think
Arjun is too strong like I want to give
her praise she deserves praise but Arjun
era geisey when it comes to the quickest
High patrols he was an absolute beast in
the world rapid Chess Championship
Magnus Carlson may have won the
tournament but Arjun aragaisy I think my
performance rating was number two he
didn't finish with the silver medal but
he played an absolutely superb
tournament so when our generic guys he
plays you just have to look at him that
stoic you know composure and say he is
likely going to be the better player and
even with the black pieces I think he
has this one we've gotten we've gotten
to know that room pretty well I've also
gotten my OCD to calm down as I look at
that very disorganized shelf behind
arjune every time we see him on camera
now I'm like is 71 gonna like dive in
there and at least color code the thing
like what is going on right I mean no
hey Danny you have four kids he is not
one of them leave him alone and he
actually showed us a bunch of his
stuffed animals and trophies on his
shelves during the Champions chess tour
so maybe there is some organization to
what seems like yeah exactly to the
madness Okay well um we'll be getting to
know that room uh very well over over
the next coming years of course
um so uh so I guess I should I'm gonna
have to let it go yeah and and the games
have started
I I believe we are off Robert E4 on
board one this is the battle between
board two obviously for the MGD one
playing black and board three for the
Blitz
yeah and look at the rating disparity
here and Narayanan he's 26.73 he's a
fantastic player he is playing a modern
Danny this shows us that he wants to win
from the very first few moves yeah
Lauren London is uh is playing a hyper
aggressive approach with the modern
being G6 and Bishop G7 now A6 you're
really trying to throw in there the
potential to expand on the queen side
but okay white white already has an edge
in these positions as long as white
knows how to use the space Advantage
they get I like these tiger modders with
the bishop G5 here but that's because
dubious openings have always been my
thing
Bishop G5 is a perfectly good move you
know I'm going to be hard on you later
in the show don't do it to yourself this
early self-deprecation takes the fun out
of it for me come on SO Bishop G5 one of
the things about it just to talk is is
you you add a little bit of dysfunction
to Black's development of the e-pawn and
if black ever pushes an H Pawn around
the king side that's a weakness that can
later uh be taken advantage of so Jokes
Aside putting the bishop there can kind
of be in uh an odd line you also have
this idea of Bishop E3 after H6 Queen D2
and kind of a typical sort of Yugoslav
attack so but we see that boy you're a
little thrown off here by by narayanan's
modern or at least uh at least
pretending to be as he's now now already
down almost a minute and a half on the
clock it's a shocking clock management
here because you have to just play you
know that it's early on in this game he
plays Bishop C4 inviting B5 with Tempo
but then just gonna drop the bishop back
to B3 that's going to be safe and secure
there and it does eye this F7 Pawn but I
think that black typically wants to
adopt a setup with Pawn to E6 blunting
this bishop diagonal so Danny I really
just worry about the clock management I
know eight minutes 37 seconds sounds
like a lifetime it's all those bullet
Maniacs that are playing on chess.com
but against a strong player like nariana
you need all the time you can have
yeah and rapid rapid as we know is the
uh you know maybe it's the future of
chest of balance where you really see
preparation still make a huge difference
but players not have six hours on the
clock to solve a problem they might be
faced with so rapid means that Nora
yanin is gonna have preparation knowing
what he know what to do in this line you
can't get yourself that far down on the
clock if your boy or and expect to uh to
be happy about it at least not in all
four games today we'll see how this one
plays out
um okay D6 played
yeah is this like the slowest moving
protesting game ever yeah seriously
these guys I don't know if they got the
uh the memo that this is a I'm all
jacked up you know I've had two cups of
coffee here in my uh get ready for
Gotham Knight's mug here today Levy
Rosman shout out to you in the uh uh
wingardium Levy Rosman but um okay yeah
these guys are really really uh slowing
down the pace here maybe I need to slow
down
well we see that you know white is
developing this looks like a great setup
for Boyer here all of the minor pieces
out except for the dark Square Bishop he
can play the E3 or G5 later he's going
to Castle his King that said in a modern
approach we see a bishop staring down at
the center here comes the Knight
eventually B5 he encountering the bishop
is possible as well and the pieces will
stare at White's Pawn so white has the
advantage in terms of control the center
with the pawns but black guys try to
counter that with the pieces but they
didn't mean this is so early and they're
spending so much time I feel like both
are unfamiliar with this opening yeah
it's interesting it's one one side
surprised one with the modern maybe then
Boyer surprised him with the bishop C4
approach rather than some of these you
know the Austrian structures with F4
sometimes are a little more common black
uh getting under pressure a little early
there with E5 Here Comes Queen E2 which
also has the C5 idea so all right we'll
come back to this as these guys wake up
maybe we need to slip them some coffee
uh let's check in with our bird's eye
view and just remind everybody that
every game in this matchup between mgd1
and the blitz is underway we don't see
any moves there between uh Savita and
garishuk but uh but okay we'll check on
that a little bit what what uh position
has your fancy I see a Scandinavian hi
guys it's me John over there in irigaisy
versus uh De Monte cornet
that's in the top left that was a
Scandinavian and John Bartholomew
somewhere uh he is about to make a video
on that game because uh Scandinavian is
not seen at the highest level very often
it will pull up that board as we wait
for the final game to start between
grishuk and Savita Shri but yeah Arjuna
geisi like Narayanan is bored too
they're making their attentions clear
they want to win this game they want to
pick up points and he played a
Scandinavian something you only see from
Ludwig Agron and the highest levels
right you know he may be the top
streamer in the world uh good for him
but you don't see him from the top chess
players sorry you're so great don't
worry we love you but Knight C3 the
queen has to go you've already moved
your queen twice getting kicked around
but in return for that Danny look at how
quickly Arjun is playing he's just yeah
going after pawns he should not take
this Pawn there's just no way you take
this Pawn on B2 with the Rook sliding in
front of the queen and getting this Pawn
on B7 but Diamante she is not afraid
that's the best news you can have your
Blitz fan well it's funny to say that by
the way a blitz fan like everyone loves
Blitz chess but the team is also called
Bliss it's almost like The Branding was
thought out oh sorry go ahead no no
that's what I was saying Kevin boardy is
brilliant yeah
the uh Kevin boardy if you don't know
him Blitz stream uh one of the top
streamers in France I didn't say Chester
memory I said streamers in France he's
actually I believe streaming right now
his own team's point of view being the
captain for the blitz
um I want to go back to what you said
about Demonte showing that she's not
afraid I agree and one of the ways we
can kind of uh judge that is the clock
right Robert you see that she's actually
or at least at the when I started this
monologue she was up about 45 seconds
um she's also doing just fine on the
board and so I think one of the best
early signs you can see for a potential
upset is that the lower rated player
doesn't come overthinking it right
doesn't come scared if you will and uh
because no matter what these games were
going to come down to time pressure
they're going to come down to testing
your nerves in the end and if you have
more time on the clock against a
stronger player much better chances so
and I by the way you know I love the
Scandinavian for white jokes aside and I
love my boy John
Bartholomew but I think White's position
is is pretty simple to play here
um the Queen's gonna come to D2 you can
Castle actually to either side of the
board that pawn on F3 can sometimes
accelerate G4 very quickly depending on
where you want to put that King and if
that pawn gets going you might quickly
be launching into a king side sort of
Pawn storm so uh it's interesting
because the bishop that came to G4
earlier Robert inducing the pawn to F3
you would argue that made that Knight go
to a less less active Square on E2 but
these positions are very easy to play
for white and and I'm already liking uh
de Monte's chances against our Junior
geisey here really not kidding and Arjun
he may want demand to the castle King
side so Hill Castle Queen side and then
it's a matter whose King will be safer
the white Kingdom that's very safe and
tucked away there and this black queen
is just misplaced that you have to watch
out for this D5 shot not now because the
bishop is loose on E3 that's part of the
reason why black induced the move F3 is
if this following F2 the game would be
over you just push your point on D5 you
win material but with this bishop loose
you cannot play D5 just yet Queen D2
your suggestion Danny looks very natural
to me because black really does not want
to take this Pawn on B2 with Rook B1
coming I take on B7 but she plays Queen
D2 and the evil bar doesn't like it so
Danny is there a way for black to scoop
up this Pawn I I feel like it doesn't
look good but the evil bar suggesting
that black is doing just fine
I don't know the theory uh at this point
Queen D2 obviously brings uh brings D5
okay as an option and a threat because
it guarded the bishop but no Arjun
already knows what to do plays Knight A5
and that looks like it's the problem the
bishop if it goes to B3 black will
snatch up the bishop here and if you go
to D3 I think black will take B2 because
the Knight guards B7 is that it I'll
show that the queen takes B2 Rook B1
Queen A3 and guess what you're not
taking on B7 because the Knight defends
it and the evil bar is only slightly
better and that for a pawn that's pretty
good news for whites because Black's
King is still in the center and you're
not fully coordinated that said I don't
think she wants to give up a pawn at
this stage I think she should slide her
Bishop back to B3 allow the Knight to
capture it at least you get a capture
towards the center your Rook is
developed on a starting Square that's
some good news but I think Arjun he's
getting the imbalance that he wants to
any it's all you can ask for versus a
strong International Master like Demonte
Elite cornet so I think that Arjun he's
doing the right thing but she's also
playing quite well here herself
agreed and also if we look at the clock
it's sort of Shifting back the direction
where uh the favorite is showing why he
is one of the strongest and uh most most
aggressively rising stars from India I
think he's happy with the with the
double-edged position he got so all
right let's back out and take a look at
all four games quickly again the uh the
bird's eye view as we like to call it
reminds everybody that four games are
still in action uh one eval bar has my
attention which is Narayanan uh quickly
quickly turned that modern into into an
edge for black over there against voyeur
I know we already talked about that game
Robert but I mean oh my gosh 95 on the
board we got to go back to it this is
that game by far has our spiciest action
so let's let's go check that out how did
a pawn get on B2 and why is the Knight
hanging on E5 Robert you're the Grand
Master go all right let's go back in
time B5 was played B4 was played and
Boyer says I am not a boy I'm a man and
he goes E5 hitting this Knight on F6
take my knight on C3 good for you and
after e takes Bishop takes white could
have just taken this Pawn on C3 and we
see the evil bar saying the white is
actually slightly better with more
development but up to H6 the bishop goes
Pawn takes Pawn The Rook slides over but
look at Black's a pawn here it comes A4
A3 is the idea I don't know why you
can't just take this Pawn but instead
Boyer castles and that's your A4 Bishop
C4 A3 you have a cemented pass Pawn one
square away from promotion and white
says let me go I am going after your
king and black says uh no Pawn to E6
your attack isn't on the verge of
fizzling out and White currently is down
two pawns Danny in this position and
there's a protected pass Pawn on B2 I
think this has gone a little bit too far
if you're a Boyer yeah it's how often
you see a protected passport on B2 with
this many pieces on the board I mean
this is we are in rare territory here
everybody and and yeah it shows that if
White had played a move like maybe A4
Robert if we want to back up a couple
moves instead of castles to prevent
black from cementing that protected Pawn
uh maybe this was the way to go at least
closer to equal I don't know what else
the computer like besides besides
stopping A4 but you could just take the
pawn okay yeah in fact
simple chess to win the pawn back
um
okay fascinating I will say this though
as we get back to the live position
despite the email bar greatly favoring
black and for good reason that is a Pawn
on B2 this is not an easy position for
black to play should time pressure
commence right because your king is
stuck in the center that Bishop on H6 is
preventing castles at least for the time
being and so there's there's positions
we talk about that are blunderable right
yes the computer says black is winning
but humans make mistakes in positions
when their King is stuck in the center
and they don't have a lot of time on the
clock so so let's let's keep our eye on
this one this is this is going to be fun
I think
yeah actually just to show quick
variation of how things can get spicy
like if white takes this bishop and the
Black Knight takes back D5 let's go I'm
trying to Checkmate this King and if you
play E5 maybe their permanent weakness
in the light scores Here Comes F4 the
position will be cracked open this is
not just a shell that you can hide
behind no white has pawns they're gonna
bring up the board open some files and
you see the evil bar actually suggesting
that it's hovering around the middle
that's not just a draw that's just
Dynamic equality black up two pawns with
a passer on B2 but white with the attack
so I'm with you Danny we can't just uh
call off White's chances here black
needs to be very very careful yeah no I
love that line with 1967 and D5 I mean
it is it is a position that is easier
for white to play and we talk about that
a lot right bold strategy cotton the
first dodgeball reference of the day can
we get that guy a diamond membership
um
is let's get him a one month Diamond
membership I'm feeling generous today a
bold strategy throwback to you dodgeball
you can dodge a wrench today Robert but
you can't Dodge a ball and Danny we
don't have to wait to see if it pays off
it did just pay off that person wanted
Diamond membership so
bold strategy cut okay uh speaking you
talk about Dynamic imbalances I think we
got to go check out uh a game that is
full of dynamic imbalances uh you know
I'm dying to go check out my boy MBL the
Frenchman with three names he's playing
Black in a position where uh White has
the bishop pair but black has what seems
to be the more coordinated pieces with
the queen coming to D6 and likely a
quick doubling on the D file so I'm
liking mbl's position here as black even
though I do love the dark Square Bishop
for white oh that's Menace in the
position it just slices across the
entire board the single best piece is
this bishop but look what mvl is doing
he is putting his own Bishop on D5
protected by a pawn it's kind of Connect
Four where your Bishop is actually a
bishop not just a pawn here and this
bishop Emoji 2 is useless so sure Queen
C3 friends Checkmate in one black can
simply defend that square and say what
next and maybe this Knight that's on B6
is dominated by a pawn three squares
away this Knight can go back to no not
there to D7 and then even up to E5 and
don't count out Pawn to F4 for black
let's go for an attack because this Pawn
is on H3 daddy you're kind of
highlighting this in the other game in
the uh narayana game in the modern that
you wish your palm were back on H2
because F4 is not scary if you have
another Pawn defending the square F4 is
a lot scarier when this G3 Pawn is loose
so kind of wish you could take it back
no and I love that uh that plan is sort
of supported by the move that you
highlighted Bishop to D5 from Maxine
wasn't just because he loves Connect
Four by the way ways one of his favorite
board games second only to chess but
actually supporting E4 allowing the pawn
to advance to start to pry open White's
King side we often say the best pawn
moves around a king's uh King's Castle
is to move them backward because you
never you never are happy usually when
you advance them in the middle game and
your king side becomes weaker so I like
maximum's chances like okay maybe we're
being a little bit mvo biased here
obviously Grandmaster guha knows what
he's doing that Bishop on B2 is a menace
we should probably just highlight that
Queen to C3 could be played at any
moment to threaten Checkmate on G7 uh it
doesn't do more than that at this time
but when you ever have those types of
power moves on the board you have to
remember because the phrase is it may
not work now but it might work on a
future move and if you do anything else
wrong you leave a piece undefended some
other threat when those types of
powerful threats are possible that's how
bad things happen so let's watch out for
that but I've heard anything is possible
so you're telling me just you know
anything is possible you know
but but
your point take it I know I'm supposed
to be the serious one and I'm the one
just uh distracting us uh but I do think
that one another important line to show
is that if white plays D3 trying to
break down this Pawn chain you have to
watch out for moves like E3 because this
Pawn is loose on G3 I think you really
need this Pawn back on H2 because if you
think you're taking here in Comes The
Black Queen and that's why you want your
Pawn H2 to protect the square this would
be devastating it's funny I don't know
how we got here but speaking of the idea
I was talking about in the in the modern
the tiger modern for white I am sure at
some point Maxine put the bishop on G4
and do stage three and backed it up like
without knowing exactly what the opening
was we don't have to but that's that's
an idea there you go that's an idea
that's kind of advanced and I think
sometimes for our viewers they look at
that and question the loss of time the
loss of Tempe time is critical in chess
but when you're thinking about the
bigger picture one of the factors we
always try to instill in our students is
the only pieces that can't undo their
decisions are the pawns so high level
chess is often about inducing weaknesses
creating open squares moves that your
opponent ultimately will wish they could
take back and so I just think that's a
super instructive point if Maxine does
eventually break through within A4 by
the way they'll look at Rook C3 by
Google he's opening up that third rank
bro he wants that Rook on G3 if F4 comes
I really like that move
yeah and I saw like a chat by the way
featured chat saying G6 Connect Four G6
would maybe be the worst move on the
board that doesn't lose material because
you're opening up this bishop for a
checkmating attack so I know I've been
joking about Connect Four do not just
connect
that's a different board game
I love no it's funny we rarely laugh at
at move suggestions just for the
reference but that wasn't a huge yet but
it was like funny because the way Robert
said like G6 would quite literally be
the worst move on the board it would
speaking of pawn moves You'll wish you
could take back that would be one so be
careful
um does Connect Four count if one's a
bishop that's a that's a fair question
we will get the Connect Four rulebook
out at some point today
um and uh and get back to you on that so
all right on that note there's only one
game we haven't really gotten to if we
want to get back to our bird's eye view
and that is uh the game between Savita
board four for MGD one and uh Alexander
grishek actually we haven't gone to two
games but we but maybe let's go check on
that board four versus Board one battle
and see how uh Sasha is faring with the
black pieces there
I think this is as good as it gets for a
board four look at this position Danny
uh there's not an advantage that I could
see for black oh the queen or her is
nicely centralized right now how could
you complain here I think that grishook
is hoping that in an end game or at
least in a whittled down middle game
with queen and Rook on the board because
a pair of Rooks is likely to get traded
at some point that he could be because
for B4 and chisel at White's Queen side
and in the end game having the Pawns in
the center will be advantageous but
actually the move Queenie too that looks
like it was in imprecise one because the
Evo bar just started syncing well and
the the other Advantage here I love the
idea of B4 of course it tries to open
the bishop on the on the dark Square
diagonal but the long-term advantage of
the bishop versus the knight in a
structure like this as long as there's
one other piece to help like like a rook
on the board is is usually More Than
People realize because with pawns on
both sides of the board the Bishops
buying those pawns if you if you combine
a black Rook on a second rank the Knight
often feels frustrated less of less of a
night more of a donkey in terms of
keeping up with a bishop that can pry
and put pressure on the diagonal so it's
not as fancy oh my gosh we already have
a victory okay I I wanted to finish my
point about Mission the night before the
mate happened but darn it was too fast
let's go to that board and see how
Checkmate has occurred
I mean I feel so bad I wanted to make
the instructor point but I should have
let the commentator and me come out
instead of the teacher because I was
watching this game over here on my
monitor I'm like holy crap Bishop takes
H2 is coming if you back up to Bishop
takes H2 this is when I saw it the White
Queen was on C6 and and Narayanan finds
Bishop takes H2 to start to pry open the
white king and things just get bad from
here this is a beautiful sequence
because most people think it's about
winning the bishop that gets you
checkmated on D7 but Knight comes to E5
the queen cannot protect the G4 Square
it goes to its only safe Square over
there and then bam give me that Bishop
the king just gets a check made it on H4
we're not laughing uh because of the
players it's just you know you have to
laugh otherwise you cry because King
made on H4 beautiful give it to me give
me that that uh that gushy stuff right
there that's that's an attack right
there that we're gonna remember for the
rest of the day that was a fun moment
and uh Narayanan showing uh that hey
maybe I was wrong saying that MBL is the
best board too between these two teams
now Ariana came to play and he strikes
first for MGD one but look at the top
left and the bottom left the bar is all
the way down in Black's favor it looks
like Maxine Basha lagrub he's missing
his g-pawn but so is white and the top
left uh Demonte as she is down to just a
few seconds against Arjun eragisi who is
mopping it up it looks like his King is
very safe and she's about to get checked
which game should we tune in for the
final move they're both instructed we
got opsicode Bishop attacks for irigaisy
look at that Bishop on that long
diagonal and the white Bishop on C2
feeling useless uh or or we go see mvl
get it done because the g-pawn prophecy
came to fruition let's go back to mbl's
game I mean or you choose this is so
much fresher I put the mvo game up it
looks like he is just taking everything
that's offered to him if this bishop
were on A1 and the queen could line up
there might be a Checkmate a black one
on the position black one on time and
Maxine vasilograph has won Danny's heart
a long time ago and he's winning more
chess game
good to see him back where he belongs
you know sit on the couch
what wait is Envy wearing a blitz Jersey
is that a jersey they've made I think he
has a blitz Jersey on
they've they've got it figured out there
I think the blitz are uh look at that
Blitz Jersey
Maxim hey buddy
I love you I love you okay let's go back
to Eric guys you're a geisies game
because uh unfortunately Demonte uh do
lead cornet is um
is um
is is resigning because it's going to be
Checkmate on H2 so a lot of these games
finishing and Rapid Fire succession at
this moment
yeah and this uh was clear from the
early stages that arjunaire Garcia was
playing for a win he gets that W A big
one for mg D1 who goes up two to one and
now the big question with one game
remaining Danny is Will Alexander
grishook the board one be able to take
down Savita Shri the board four for
India because that game is still going
and it's not clear that he is going to
get a win
yeah I just saw that uh comment from
feature chat I was literally about uh to
say that phrase uh black pieces
dominating early on in in this
particular matchup black has won all
three games just fun little fact so good
call now chat you stole my thunder I was
just about to say that
um all right if grishek wins we will
have a 4-0 sweep for the second move so
much for uh for playing the white pieces
huh yeah no this uh is supposed to be
first move Advantage but the higher
rated players for both teams have had
black but look at Savita go here she
brings her Knight to E4 this Knight can
capture the bishop at some moment I just
want to back up a second here and a lot
of people would say give me this bishop
your King has to take but black doesn't
just have to take over here you can
actually take on B2 first hitting the
Rook taking the Knight next and we
already saw what happened with Narayanan
got a Pawn on me too you don't want to
give grishook that same past Pawn so
instead B takes C3 is played that Bishop
is still under threat the queen slides
into E5 but Danny Savita with her Knight
on e4 yes her Pawn structure is worse
with the split pawns over here but she's
hanging in there
yeah we often talk about the only real
way for a knight to compete with a
bishop in an open board in a position
with with pawns on both sides is to be
centralized right you have to have a
knight that is more of an octopus and
and and and can kind of reach reach all
different scores quickly so uh savitha
knows that she's going to use the queen
in night the dynamic duo as best she can
I still give brishic the long-term edge
here not just because of the positional
problem on the C3 square but look at the
clock Savita is under a minute grishek
knows how to use the time Advantage uh
we normally see him in a position down
down this much on time
yeah and the big problem is a knight
gets dominated by Bishop it's some
already dominated by a pawn three
squares away but if Bishop takes away
even more squares F6 D6 C5 and G5 that
Knight can't go anywhere which means
after F5 the Knight would have to go
back to G3 the Knight goes there
voluntarily but that's even better or
grishook because he doesn't have to push
his Pawn forward and expose his King I
think he'll just swap one pair of Rooks
Danny and after The Rook takes back
bring this Rook down yeah yeah he's
gonna say he can probably play Rook B2
right away even the brook is defended on
d8 by the bishop uh if you want to kind
of build the tension Rook B2 immediately
capturing on d8 only reroutes that
Bishop to the B6 square with the Rook on
B2 and the bishop on B6 uh you know the
only long distance relationship that's
been working as long as the rook and
Bishop is um ours hours that's right
long distance relationship
that was you did it I mean I just feel
like very rarely do you make me blush
you just did it
you know why go ahead no you go ahead no
I was gonna say by the way he went for
this idea and here comes the long
distance relationship everyone wants to
see Bishop's coming to B6 go ahead I was
gonna say that you're always the one
making those awkward jokes so now you've
uh unfortunately influenced me and here
I am but oh my how the tables have
turned the tables have turned um King H1
uh it's it's it it's an awkward move I
mean the only thing more Awkward than
the King on H1 is a queen on H1 I'm
speaking from experience
don't bring up that reference because I
was there with you that hurt I'm still a
pain vet you bet that was something that
almost killed our long-distance
relationship my chest that day uh yeah
you better cry I mean this king's also
crying in the corner because if the
bishop comes to C7 and black was H5 H4
just to kick this Knight away there
might be Checkmate this Rook on A1 tied
down to both the eight wow what kind of
super GM move is that like you're on the
attack you just trade Queens to
liquidate into a winning uh rook and
minor piece ending because F5 kicks this
night out of there you wouldn't have two
yeah
super GM and superhero super GM by day
Superhero by night and uh
right now he's making this making this
look easy good old-fashioned family
front fun you know just to clean it's
technical
rated PG
this Knight on G3 is horrible I can't
Leap Forward anywhere the only where
square has available is F1 Sook is just
going Pawn grabbing now I like what
she's doing Savita going after these two
pawns here but I just imagine that this
bishop slides to this diagonal keeps the
king locked at home and there's gonna be
a back ring check
yeah and even Rook takes C3 immediately
probably possible to hit the Knight if
you want because Rook takes E6 met by
King F7 I think so there's there's a lot
of options here for for krishek he's
going to take his time and ensure that
black is uh black is gonna get four
victories to start off this match the
only thing more devastating for the
white pieces is how Donya noradiski
heard about your uh heard about our
relationship and that's awkward that's
like the modern day you're watching a
show and you find out that someone else
is more important than you it feels like
the modern day sir no de Bergerac did
you see the new the new version of that
I haven't actually the good okay next
next time you go on a flight just yeah
just for the musical feels just look at
you watch it
okay
um
all right well Grisha takes his time
before playing E5 wow what
what a move though
doesn't even play the the obvious
forcing moves makes a simple advance of
the e-pawn
and uh I saw Chad calling me out for
digging and grishek's time skills if
you've ever watched Alexander grishek
play in one of his many candidates
tournaments by the way the guy has
played in the candidates
uh more times than than anybody at this
point he he has a habit of getting
himself under time pressure but it's
also one of the things that makes him
great while in time pressure and in time
controls like this rapid and Blitz
Alexander grishek of course a world
Blitz champion at one point in his
career
um that's why he is a sought after free
excuse me I'm losing my voice today he's
a sought after free agent in the protest
League those who've been following for
for uh since since this all began know
that uh Sasha is a guy that everybody
wants on their team
uh for sure because he's played in five
candidates tournaments and he is a
three-time world Blitz champion of
course you want that guy on your roster
and he's pinning this Knight but he has
now done under a minute Danny and if
he's not careful and allows The Rook
behind the pass Pawn that could be
Troublesome but he can't push his Pawn
to E3 and Bishop to F2 that's I think
going to be the winning strategy I think
that'll be fun if E3 King H2 F4 renews
the threat of Bishop to G3 it just gets
nasty he's calculating it as we speak
um by the way shout out to Savita she's
she's been living off the increment here
for quite a while uh but it's not over
yet wow he's just not over yet she's
living in the Icarus she literally loses
on time so Danny Joshua Joshua
Chamberlain strikes again yeah now that
is an old school Pro chess League
reference but Alexander grishek he may
be old school he may be a veteran but he
has helped his team tie the first round
two to two so Denny those four games in
the books no big surprises with the
heavy rating favorites winning their
games
yeah all four of the top seeds win which
is why black goes 4-0 because all four
of the top seeds were playing Black it's
honestly hard to pick
um pick out who was the most impressive
right I think they all they all got the
job done uh narayanan's game though how
often are you gonna Checkmate someone on
H4 I think that goes uh that goes for
the game of the round in my book
yeah a little help from his opponent by
allowing him to establish that pass Pawn
but finding those crazy tactics oh
finishing with a flourish was narayana
I'm with you I think that was Game of
the round both sides both teams had
their higher Raider players winning
board one and board two with black but
it's only gonna get tougher as the
matchups get more and more even
and the matchups will continue they will
get more and more even as Robert says
and we're going to take a very quick
break don't go anywhere the pro chess
League again is underway we're so
excited to be here when we come back
it's the round two matchups between mgd1
and the Blitz
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome into our new video collection
series here with the one and only the
14th World Chess Championship
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody the pro chess
League underway yet again today we've
already had the first round between the
team's mgd1 and the Blitz in the books
uh no big surprises yet all the
favorites won
um and your favorite Robert Hess is here
so everyone's getting what they want
today my favorite your favorite
um no dandya everyone's happy
well I think now people are gonna be mad
at you we know how many fans Donya has
but this format is excellent right even
if you're commentary leaves a little bit
to be desired on occasion the format the
league is awesome
the format is hot the the league is
awesome let's remind everybody we talked
a lot about uh roster construction the
rules of the lineups the game within the
game there uh let's remind fans
re-familiarizing themselves wow I nailed
that word re-familiarizing I said it
without stumbling uh themselves with the
format of the league but it's kind of
simple it's a it's a massive Swiss it's
an elimination Swiss over the next three
weeks after week one teams will face
those with the same record this process
continues ultimately what you need to
know is this three wins by a team secure
them a spot in the playoffs three losses
secure elimination that they will not be
competing in the playoffs That season
Robert
that's pretty simple win three matches
you go through the playoffs lose three
matches you're gone so I think that it's
straightforward for these teams and a
lot of these teams are very neck and
neck I mean there isn't much separation
because of the rating cap so even the
teams that have Magnus Carlson we saw
that they almost lost the cobras who had
a Wonder Liang a great player of raid 26
30 26 40 on board one there will be a
lot of parody in this league
yeah and one of the best parts about
that process is one of the things we've
had historic I just want to talk about
this because I'm very excited about it
we've been doing this for years Robert
what are the problems you have
historically in any team league is at
some point you have a team that's like
8-0 on the season playing a team that's
Owen Eight and the Dynamics of that
matchup can be in Balance right the
content might not be as good because one
team just might be more dominant than
the other the way this works is
throughout the season fans every single
matchup is going to be based on how
they're doing which means by definition
if you're winning a lot you're going to
be playing a team that's also winning a
lot and so the stakes only get bigger
and even if you're losing you're
fighting against teams who are in a
similar spot literally fighting for
their lives and so you always have that
that pairing that draws your attention
because there's something at stake and
and no real major imbalances there so
anyway very excited about that I'm also
very excited about round two which
matchup do you have circled that we're
about to jump into Robert
wow I mean look at this the kind of the
powerhouses have the white pieces I'm
gonna Circle the match of between
Alexander grishek and mitraba guha I
think that guha against mvl it got out
of hand he was in time trouble but I
think when he's at his best we saw him
in the chess.com Global Championship he
is capable of taking some points off
these higher rated Grandmasters he is a
GM himself he's super strong I think
that's the best chance for any of the
four low-rated players to score an upset
I think you're right that has to be the
the game that uh that the MGD one have
have circles coming in here you got to
get an upset at some point to have a
chance to win the match uh unless you
assume your top words will always get it
done but I think that's an opportunity
of course having the black pieces uh for
guha is going to be hard against grishek
but we'll see what he can do here having
the black pieces against our junior
geisey is going to be hard we know that
uh for mahel Boyer yeah especially if
Boyer plays the way he just did against
nariana that was wild stuff and Arjun
aragaisi I called him an agent of chaos
during the Champions chess tour he
thrives in commotion so we see it's at
the start of Queen's game decline in
early age six just stopping this Bishop
from getting to G5 where it often pins
this Knight so I think that for Boyer
it's good to get off the common opening
threads you're making a sideline
variation happen and that way you're
forcing Arjun just to play at the board
maybe Boyer escapes the opening with
more preparation in his book rather than
his opponents well I love that he's
paying attention to his camera framing
too can we get fobby to pay attention to
that thought when you look at what Boyer
just did he paid attention to his camera
frame because he appreciates the fans
want to see his full face then not just
his lovely curly hair Bobby
wow well I think Boris you need to play
like Bobby to take down Eric but that is
a good shout out players too often go
with the five head camp they're like
leaning over they don't remember that
they're on camera uh but you know it
happens because they're so focused on
the chest and well Danny this opening it
kind of became a Catalan from a queen
skin but declined this bishop is out on
D6 rather than his typical spot on E7
and yeah I feel like this approach for
black what is this Knight C6 but before
we could even talk about the approach
that it's already the awkward H6 Bishop
on D6 a bit more of a Target in this
structure than it is on E7 but the
Knight on C6 blocking the C Pawn
okay it invites this move are your guys
he says all right I'll call your bluff
I'm gonna gain a Tempo I'm gonna play B4
I'm gonna put the black squared Bishop
on F4 I'm gonna dominate the dark
squares and I'm gonna Crush you on the
queen side with my Pawn storm
yeah I don't understand it I don't like
it I'm gonna be honest that this Pawn is
often so it's going to C5 to compete for
the center now white has full central
control the only Pawn break that black
has is E5 B6 is another Pawn break but
white just goes forward with B4 and
Arjun Castle quickly I liked your idea
of starting with B4 I'm just going to
show that on the analysis board because
if you play B4 to start with and black
plays B6 you also have to contend with
this move B5 because if your knight goes
back to B8 well that Knight gets locked
in after a move like C6 you're not gonna
be very happy about the piece being
there so you often have to go to the rim
and maybe you're okay because you're
fighting uh to break down this Pawn
chain but your Bishop stinks uh these
pawns look really strong here it's kind
of a Fighting Chance uh for black but if
you don't make the most of it in the
near future you're just gonna be
strategically lost well I agree with you
that B4 seemed like the more challenging
approach for argument note that Boyer
doesn't have to be asked twice to
prevent it back to the live game he
played A5 now again I still like white
structure and here comes Bishop for
making sure that E5 is not a
breakthrough the black will get anytime
soon but but A5 is a good move and you
see that's why the computer is like well
okay it could have been worse because
now to Robert's point now B6 can come
for black and B6 can undermine that lead
C Pawn in the pawn chain and white
doesn't have the move B4 to reinforce it
so as awkward as it is in terms of how
we got here okay and now oh he just
missed Knight B5 he's just losing the
pawn oh my God
yeah he can't believe in himself he said
the same thing I think he said in French
because that is uh you got a pardon his
French he just dropped the pawn on C7
and the thing about this is your knight
is often F6 to go back to E8 you get
defensive for a second to protect your
knight just went up to E4 so he just
drops a pawn in this position it's all
Arjun Eric icy and mg D1 it's so funny
because by the way if he had played B6
your idea now that B4 was prevented I
think the position is much more
dynamically balanced he plays Knight E4
what an interesting blunder to to learn
about this structure that suddenly that
C7 Pawn is undefendable and okay now
okay we're about to get another made on
H4 I love you Boyer I don't necessarily
know you that well yet we're getting
we're going to get to know each other
real well this season but you're about
to go O2 buddy and this is already in
desperation Tim
yeah because uh black king is now loose
in addition to being down upon but even
if you win back your material which you
probably aren't you are going to be In
Harm's Way on the king side so that's
bad news for the blitz I mean they're
trusting him to put up a fight but we do
have other games going on here so why
don't we hop on over to our four board
scene because two other games I see have
begun whoa what is going on in the top
right I was just about to say uh
Narayanan versus uh Demonte duleep
cornet that's the game we got to go to
it wasn't a king's Gambit but it might
as well have been what in the world is
going on in that game white has a huge
Center black has taken upon an F4 and
and and claimed that she wants to keep
it with the move G5 to follow
and uh Robert we gotta back up to the
Batcave analysis board we go what in the
world was this opening in English what
with B6 and then white just threw all
the pawns forward and eight like what is
this C4 E4 A3 and then after A5 to stop
B4 F4 I mean what in the world are we
looking at
I
if this is the future of Jess though I
will say sign me up because I love the
positions we're getting on the board I
haven't looked at a single one no Berlin
12 move draws here yet although Wesley
and Hikaru haven't been paired yet you
know so we'll we'll hold out hope for
the most exciting draw at some point in
the season
um but here we go we've got G5
the Dynamics of this battle here yes
Danny is
n't life I literally had to come in the
commentary to tell you that
that voice
Morgan Freeman who invited you
I invited myself nobody ever invites me
I I I want to attend and just storm in
I think he heard that we were having a
good time that we didn't miss him so he
invited himself
talking about your long-distance
relationship and I got I got mad it's
true it's true no I mean you're in
Robert's relationship is at least East
Coast based you know so it's not a
direct challenge to your to your current
affair but um anyway well Dania um I I'm
glad you're here uh we've got a lot of
exciting chess on the board no it's not
the first time I've seen a peace
sacrifice but I feel like every game has
been delivering so far and I'm just I'm
just loving it man wait down there
before you speak it's the first time
he's seen a correct peace sacrifice that
could be true
the chat loves Dania they're already
letting us know
and uh Daniel seriously though
what are you doing
I think this is like a mutsio Gambit you
know in the king's gamut where white
just leaves the Knight on F3 and there's
a Pawn on G4 and white just chills and
castles except here at White's Castle
Queen side which is even better I mean
queen G3 and Knight B5 I feel like we
might have like a 10 move game
no this this is exactly the type of
Gambit that you're referring to with the
King's game and for those who don't know
the line there are very very famous back
in the Romantic days of Chess where
every peace sacrifice was good I was
supposed to be born in that era not this
era where dubious peace sacrifices are
often refuted but this is this is a game
right up my alley I mean I feel like
white can play almost any move here
Donya and the attack gets better like
even C5 to play the bishop to C4 Knight
D5 is a threat anything that starts to
expand on the center is going to be very
difficult uh for cornet
yeah man I mean when when your king is
no Safe Haven even hypothetically you
know you're in trouble like even if
black gets to the king side
white will have plenty of attacking
opportunities running the h-pawn bishop
D3 E5 I mean naryanan is such a
dangerous player I've always struggled
against him in every time control
um I'm just taking back to Madrid for a
second I'm just enjoying this I miss our
comfy chairs that we had I know from the
studio there at the candidates I know
this feels really good though at home I
mean this is
this feels this feels really good you
know
um
I
I don't know what else to say I just
want to listen to YouTube guys talk I'm
a very I'm a very generous partner in
this in this three-way so okay okay well
I'm gonna take us away from here for the
moment just because I like the way what
are you talking about I'm a generous
partner you know that okay yeah you're a
great co-commentator thank you Danny but
I wanted to take our attention
he has a lot of experience with
grushrook they commentated the world
championship together so when you see
your buddy play Sasha Grisha you know
he's taking on this league what do you
make of his position and just sort of
having him in the league and on the
roster
it's not ideas
and you play it well uh it looks like
it's actually a good position here
um and he's down on time which is that
means the world continues to spin and
the sun has gone out in the morning yep
but F6 is a good move there by black
um I'm so excited to see Sasha play it's
just it's just fun
by the way mgd1 not supporting the
jersey that MBL was to represent the
blitz but look at that custom t-shirt
you got the pro chess League over the
right breast pocket you got the mgd1
logo over the left that's looking pretty
sexy Dania your team the passers you
guys getting any swag any any custom
jerseys anytime soon the cobras it's
like on the screen I'm sorry the cobras
uh cobras I how dare you
that was just to make sure that Peter
that Peter still has something to yell
at me about so I just gave him more ammo
there you go has something to yell at
everyone about
um
in our first match yeah back disaster
back to Sasha
this is hilarious because all three of
us are used to hosting and now we're
just like passing it to each other that
we gotta say back to the action uh but I
do I do have a quick question for you
Daniel when you were commentating with
rashook did you like imperson him to his
face like did you accidentally slip into
Sasha uh accent
um I did not so I've never done that
with anybody except that there have been
a couple times when I've interviewed
like grishek Wesley
um even Vichy when the chat was just
going crazy or Gary obviously and the
chat was going crazy like why are you
not doing an impression
um but there were a couple of times when
he was sharing stories and I was sitting
there thinking like this is the most
grishic moment of all time like there
was this one time that he was talking
about like learning how to drive and he
said that right after he had learned and
got in the car for the first time he
decided to just go out on the road he
said and I was driving on the main road
and I didn't know where I was going so I
just decided I didn't go and obviously
he's saying this in Russian but yeah I
go straight in the line and then I go
for three hours and uh I didn't know
where I was going but I figured I would
eventually reach uh somewhere in the
road and I went foreign
she was like keeping his composure
completely anyways uh he's awesome
um but yes I've had that temptation but
I've decided to abstain when
compensating with them
I feel like that's the next level the
next level for you is is uh
doing commentary in the voice of the
person you're impersonating with them
Azure kill commentator so next time we
have a chance to challenge you uh not
like we've ever done silly things like
tried to slip words into broadcasts or
other types of innuendos we don't do
things like that it's a very
professional approach when the three of
us are together for sure
oh without a question by the way uh
Carnet actually has reacted to that
peace sacrifice pretty well gotta say we
don't have to go to that game I'm see
I'm like two minutes in the broadcast
and I'm already telling you what to do
hey we love when you're here let's let's
do the thing we're done in part some
great wisdom about the structure I don't
know how long we have you for so we've
got this interesting position uh some
awkward pieces both sides having the
night that are awkward oh I guess we are
going to flip over we are going to keep
you with us and we're going to go over
to the uh to the Coronet game to see how
the psac is going so there we go
producers are really the ones in charge
here and I'm happy to get your opinion
on the psac they wanted to wait for you
to say what to do so that they could do
something else yeah I mean Sasha
slightly better there
um and me and wisdom don't really go
well together but I was just mesmerized
by this position because it looks like
White's winning the piece back right
because the queen seems to have to move
and then white takes on D4 but perhaps
black has Knight B3 check here
and then after King C2 you know it's
time to Rouse McGill it's all from the
grave and ask him to find Black's move
is there something crazy here
maybe the Tactical minds of Our
Generation can speak up
um what can I just go to an end game
like can we can we just trade queens and
maybe go somewhere like that
speaking of tactical Minds simplifying
into an end game
yeah yeah
and then it's relaxed College structure
is healthier we got only have two Pawn
Islands now I was just about to say that
it's an equal equal pawn count but
probably you prefer black the Knight has
a home maybe on on F5 I guess and you've
got the H file plus the bishop on F1 has
a hard time developing as long as the
bishop on B7 is uh is spying the G2 Pawn
so
um wow look at that look at that
it's playing oh it's on the board
here we go
quick question for you by the way uh
it's from the chat it's not for me you
know I don't have any questions for you
I barely talk to you but devious coconut
wanted to know who is the most
underrated player here in your opinion I
don't know if that means in this match
or in the entire protest League or
amongst the commentary team
I already know the answer to that who's
the most underrated yeah someone I'll
let the chat figure that out
um man in terms of the match the the
legal have to take a rain check on that
because there's so many like 2600 so our
you know just ridiculous like Nicola
Bortnick for example I think is playing
for the Gotham Knights you know he's 24
30 or whatever and you know he just like
tears most GMS to shreds and Bliss
matches
um and there's and there's quite a few
players like that in terms of this match
uh looking around the horn
I mean okay actually my hell Boyer um
played him a few times in title Tuesdays
and I think he scored a ton of upsets I
think he's being me he's been Hikaru uh
he's definitely no one to mess with
even though he did say monsieu and
blunder upon in the opening uh so maybe
he'll make me no actually he's got a
pretty good position against Sarah geise
I was gonna say I don't know what
happened over there I somehow made that
game of game yeah
are probably two people to watch
okay
um
in this particular matchup I I was going
to call you out for the mahel Boyer uh
you know not just because male hasn't
hasn't had his best chest today but okay
it's only it's only been uh a game and a
half and right as we say that he seems
to be holding his own against irigaisi
um so so okay good calls
um
Daniel what are you doing today what's
your plans besides watch me and Robert
for the rest of the show
I'm gonna watch you and Robert and then
I'm gonna rewind the show and watch you
and Robert again
I play some basketball yeah
are you watching Danny to figure out if
you want to slot him as a free agent on
the cobras is that why you're watching
Danny here
yes
yeah I was gonna say given that I by the
way no team has ever come knocking on my
door to play for their
not that you say that Robert
uh we're done he has to go so he doesn't
you know let's get rid of Dania here I I
just realized I've never been asked to
play for a single protesting team like
it literally just dawned on me
foreign
right okay I mean they it's probably
because they assumed I was busy with
commentary that's all that's awesome
yeah that's that's why I got to ask in
2021 and other years to be on teams
right because they just assume that
we're busy okay well this has been great
Guys Don you have a great day
thanks Danny you guys are being here
I'm having a great time watching you so
just wanted to say all in all
seriousness
um you're awesome and I'm definitely
gonna watch this match for the rest of
this match
thanks man and good luck to the cobras
the rest of the uh the way and I'll try
not to forget which team you play for
next time love you Peter
hi
all right that was great
he's gone all right well we've got we've
got exactly what you predicted with this
queen trade Robert and uh De Monte do
lead cornet showing that she is uh she's
gonna Stave off the peace sacrifice and
maybe be better in this end game and by
the way uh well never mind she is down
on the clock I was gonna say she's not
too far down on the clock but she is
yeah no it's a time travel for one
minute remaining for black in this
position but she actually has very good
chances it's King on B3 even though
there are no queens in the board it's a
bit out in the open the bishop on B7 is
just an excellent piece uh The Rook on
E8 staring down this Pawn E5 you're
already trying to win this Pawn so I
feel like she's has a great chance to
score an offset in this game and after
rookie three maybe there's D6 that pawn
is just pinned
and she plays it instantly
still maintaining that uh one minute on
the clock you know the thing is this she
doesn't have to win this game to feel
good about what happened she is the
lower rated player she also is playing
the black pieces and by the way she was
probably losing at some point in the
middle game right so this is a game
where a draw feels like a win not just
for cornet everyone but for the Blitz
and if we back up to the bird's eye view
uh I think the Blitz
the blitz might need that game I'm just
looking at the fact that Eric icy did
come back and looks like he's about to
convert against mahel Boyer
um
in an interesting one there the top left
that game with the past pawns for white
and White's also up like three pawns but
look at the bottom right Danny I feel
like I'm watching uh one of those games
those romantic games that you've been
talking about take me back to Zurich
1953 a peace sacrifice to get a knight
into D5 into Sicilian is Maxima Sherlock
playing the same with the white pieces
the answer is absolutely he loves these
kind of adventurous games yeah we should
we should go to that game we haven't
checked on MBL versus Savita tree at
least on this room by the way we see the
Finish is uh is there
irrigation does take down mile Boyer so
the first result is in the books but
let's go over to Maxine Bossier the grav
uh versus Savita Shri and uh maybe back
up a few moves Robert just to show
everybody how that D5 Square became
available because that's a powerful Pony
but it cost it costs something in order
to get there yeah white threw the ponds
forward up to G5 the Knight take the
bishop with check the pawn takes back
after Knight D7 here it comes after
Knight C5 Knight F5 giving up one night
because once the pawn captures and you
better capture otherwise you're going to
be in some trouble here at least in the
dark squares Knight came into D5 and
this is what top players do Danny they
give up pieces at the right time not
speculative sacrifices this objectively
correct because if you take on C5 as had
to be played after Pawn takes Bishop
takes F5 there is a sickening series of
events and I think it starts I'm gonna
show it with Queen F3 this bishop is
under attack this queen is loose so if
you just make a hair Wireless move the
Knight comes to F6 with check and you
lose the queen because you have to react
to this Knight over here so Danny I
think you might even have to bring your
Bishop back to see it or something like
that and The Rook comes to E1 yes
what a fascinating position here
threatening any Discovery uh will win
the queen if the queen just moves to a
random Square you might still have
discoveries because the Rook on A8 is
hanging uh of course as you highlighted
white is just bringing another Rook into
into the uh the game with a rook D1 so
this is
this is awesome I mean these are the
kind of piece sacks I'm sitting here I
heard how much you emphasize the word at
the right time when you were talking to
me to really highlight that it's not
just okay to close your eyes and Sack
pieces anymore this day and age I get it
memo received
um
let's see if Maxine play look at Maxine
though he just scratches his head
and I can't tell if this is a super
Grand Master saying I see the end of
this game the conclusion is near are
like wait a second can she get away with
this right
well Bishop takes F5 probably was the
only move for Savita anyway and and as
we see she's played it I like that she
didn't take too much time because
sometimes a a player who's worse and by
the way we see a draw actually in the
game between grishek and guha the first
upset of the day is in the books
everyone just like Robert called the one
game that probably had the best chances
would be uh
is is drawing with the black pieces
against Alexander grishek and that means
De Monte Delite cornet her results even
more important in the top right she has
nine seconds remaining but she has an
equal end game that is one where she has
to hold and uh Danny I mean with limited
time against a strong opponent that's
dangerous territory but she has great
drawing chances to position his level
yeah wow okay well uh we have our first
upset in the books Grandmaster guha gets
the Half Point against Alexander Grisham
with the black pieces but here we go
will cornette be able to hold this one
against norionen
um this is a tougher position to hold I
think than than it looks yeah because
white can try to spring for this outside
pass Pawn that's what I'm sure what you
were about to indicate that may distract
the black king and the white king can
then go on into the queen side because
we will see in exchange at some point
and the white people will try to march
in to get those Pawns well and and
usually to kind of take a take a page
out of Robert hess's book to evaluate
the long-term winning chances you look
at factors like Bishop being the right
color corner of a poem we always say or
in this case the Bishops being the same
color means that
all white really needs is to use the
king side to distract black enough to
win one Pawn on that other side of the
board because the same color Bishop
ending if white has a past B Pawn or a
past C Pawn that's an engine that white
can win it's not always winning but you
can win those engines it's not like an
opposite code Bishop Affair so so this
is tough for black especially when you
don't have a lot of time on the clock
right because now is it just hm or is it
G5 and can come into E5 like you could
try to pick up some ground here but the
issue is once the king comes to E5
there's nowhere else to go oh whoa whoa
why'd you push the pawn no 55 King
opponent ending is lost now yeah oh you
can't trade and now the pawn is cemented
on the light Square this was the worst
thing she could do
yeah that's the only real way to give
white those winning chances because now
you have two two things to guard the B5
pawn and the F7 Pawn principle two look
at that move you free the D5 Square Here
Comes King D5 King C5 and this is gonna
be over
yeah the kid can go right there um
the bishop goes back and the King goes
over the King goes to D7 the king comes
up to F6 and goes after this F7 Pawn as
well then now it's winning over it's a
really instructive lesson for the
viewers oh sorry go ahead what no I was
just saying oh no yeah it's it's it's
it's good to know that the pawn on the
opposite color square of the of the
bishop not only is not a Target but it
also helps your Bishop so while that
point was on B6 it guarded the C5 square
and the light squared Bishop guarded C6
and E6 so by pushing that pawn forward
not only does she give white a second
weakness besides the F7 Pawn but she
also created the path for the white team
to come in that wasn't there otherwise
so that's actually a really instructive
takeaway for fans looking how not to
play this end game right because the
king can't get in like it got as far as
it could it can't get to B5 either all
these squares are under Black's control
so that was a huge misstep in time Trail
B5 a losing decision and that means the
blitz are in some trouble so let's Zoom
back out 2 our other boards because
Danny speaking of trouble Maxima Sheila
grab he may be in trouble in the
evaluation but on the board actually on
the clock he is doing quite well and now
actually she made a mistake in her time
travel yeah I was going to say I'm not
exactly sure how Savita got out of that
position that we saw it did remember
you'll find Queen F3 or not we'll back
up and look maybe quickly when it's over
but right here right now she has less
than 10 seconds Maxime still has more
than two minutes and you've got this
this dark Square problem oh my gosh Here
Comes rookie eight it's happening on the
board and it's Rover
can't stop 27. remove that
oh Queen H wood check okay yes but now
now pre-move it although Queen A1 check
yeah
yeah Envia is a monster you distract The
Rook away and get Queen G7 check and
made but Denny I mean he did play Queen
F3 and after Rook B8 he took this bishop
and it's apparently completely winning
for white at this point and you probably
could just play Simple chess because
you're strategically one in addition to
yeah actively dominant but he went for
it right away and the eval bar tanked
because suddenly you don't have a
Checkmate and what she missed do you
want King h8 which makes sense because
you want to bring your Rook to G to
defend but she had to play Queen C6 it
looks like and the reason is that Rook
D6 does not work The Rook is hanging the
quarter gives but just enough time to
keep the queen tied down to the F6 Pawn
yeah and by keeping the queen tied down
the whole evaluation changes right now
black can challenge on the D file can
activate you're not so worried about
Queen H6 ending the game on the spot so
obviously in time pressure you could say
that Maxim's Knight F6 check decision
was slightly practical but in hindsight
yeah it did it did give Savita a small
chance even though she missed it so all
right well some some players uh did get
their chances we saw uh an upset here
for the first time today the higher
rated player does not get the dub with
uh Grand Master mitravagua get in the
draw against Alexander grishek Robert
we brought Dania on but I prophesied
that that outcome I did think that is
very strong player he's a GM and he
Helga shook with black dick Elite cornet
she had her opportunity she let it slip
that is the margin it's slim but it's a
lead for team mgd1
yeah well you know it's funny because
this this matchup could have still been
tied right with that draw potentially
for cornet but of course we instead had
the instructive the instructive loss in
that end game but all right
plenty more instructive stuff ahead
today as we see this match is still very
close mgd1 with the uh the slight lead
there uh given given the draw that they
were able to scathe uh from grishek so
all right well uh before we head to a
break we uh
we want to give a quick call out to a
big event that's coming on February 20
no no sorry I'm I'm mixing up the lines
here my apologies everyone we want to
remind everybody that if they're a title
player they can compete in the open
qualifiers to try to be a part of the
2023 Champions chess tour uh maybe you
didn't even know that was the case every
Monday is kind of like another title
Tuesday title players are competing for
an opportunity to get into the main
events uh make sure you check it out
every Monday they are underway your next
chance if you are a tired player to join
is this Monday February 20th for all the
details use the command qualifiers in
chat so uh all right
Robert a lot more to come from chat by
the way we have more than 11 000 viewers
on Twitch more than a few thousand over
on YouTube this day has just begun the
most exciting matches uh may still be
ahead so thanks for being with us don't
go anywhere the pro chess League
continues with mgd1 and the blitz moving
to round three when we return
foreign
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
a competitive chess the weight of a win
long or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely days are over
the pro chess league is back once again
in chess teammates matter
we win we win oh my God welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives we got him let's go see him
and that's it he does the job too oh Sam
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion oh my God this is on the
other side what did we just see
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
welcome back everybody we're moving to
round three today and the first matchup
of this set of protest League games you
have mgd1 right now with a slight lead
over the blitz Grand Master Robert Hess
with us missing his T-shirt we're not
going to hold it against him
um but uh Robert great chess so far and
you're doing okay with commentary I
appreciate that that's a huge compliment
coming from you also I wouldn't be
missing a T-shirt If the swag bag I was
promised actually arrived so I'm not
blaming you but somebody on your team
has not given me my shirts you're not
wrong you're not wrong we got it we got
to get our stuff together uh the the
team that needs to get their stuff
together right now is the blitz uh they
dropped a game in that last round with
Alexander grishek uh giving up the Half
Point despite having the white pieces
but you called it Robert you said that
guha had had chances and he delivered
who do you think has uh who do you think
has played so far uh the best chess for
MGD one who's leading
it feels like Narayanan has played some
excellent chess I know he should have
just drawn that game against uh
uh cornet excuse me but he had an
advantage out of the opening so I feel
like he's playing enterprising chess and
that's good news but Maxine Russia
lagrove and our generic geissi have
those perfect 2-0 scores as well yeah we
just saw Maxine he had a dominant
position he had to lead in The Clock he
is uh the Superstar or the Blitz and
he's kind of the team hero he is making
it work he's getting it done
well now we start to move into those
later rounds rounds three and rounds
four uh we're getting closer to matchups
that are even on paper at least anyway
right uh you're gonna get you're going
to get battles as we get closer to board
one versus Board One board two versus
Board two and on the way down so here
with iRig icy taking on Maxine Bashe the
grav we know that that could basically
be a board one versus Board one match up
in many other in many other respects so
that's a huge game for us to focus on
and then Narayanan taking on Alexander
grishek we'll see if uh Sasha rebounds
after dropping the draw I mean I don't
really not to say the other two matchups
don't matter but I'm already focused on
those heavyweights there on the top two
boards and I get it because Maxime and
Sasha Grisham with the white pieces hey
it can be anybody including Magnus
Carlsen when I'm actually focused on the
bottom two boards and that even
surprised myself because team mgd1 has
white on both of those bottom two boards
I actually think that plays a bigger
role when the players are a bit lower
rated I think at the top level there's
so many draws between highly rated
players I think it's Advantage mgd1 and
least when I look at the pairings okay
it's interesting and again I think we
make the mistake as commentators we're
used to comment commenting on uh the top
players in the world but in this in this
battle that is team chess uh the board
three and board four have just as much
of an effect on whether the team wins
and for the record mgd1 they are likely
not to go 4-0 but they are within
Striking Distance of winning the match
just for the record remind you it is
eight and a half points for a match
Victory uh so they're getting closer to
the finish line here we go MBL with the
white pieces versus arjunior geissy this
should be a fun one I just think it's
funny to me that Maxime is bored too
like that just is ridiculous he's a
board one in our hearts and he is by
rating should be a boy when he's higher
rated than our generic icy but we have a
Spanish or Italian we get the Spanish
here from Maxine we know he loves
himself and good Roy Lopez and our
generic geissi he likes the open
structures he doesn't mind a clash but
Don yeah look what I look what happened
Danny daniana and now I'm talking to him
but I was going to ask you if you are
our generic geiste and team mgd1 you
just play like Saudi in this board
because you are ahead and you're playing
Maxime so kind of what's the mindset
would you have if you're a team captain
I I think you are especially because
you're also playing the black pieces
right your real opportunity to strike
and lead your team as board one is going
to be in the next round when you have
the first move you know that Maxime is
one of the best prepared players in the
Spanish uh in the world it's not a
Berlin here Maxime loves the Berlin and
also knows those lines very deeply but I
I'll say this I don't think that
necessarily means you won't take your
winning chances or be willing to mix it
up if you're given that opportunity but
no reason to risk it just play solid
Theory and kind of make make Maxine
prove it right because for his team who
by the way is trailing down a point
Maxine should be feeling a little more
of the pressure here he has white and he
wants to help his team get back on track
for sure and black is about to play and
has played C5 taking control over the
center both pawns staring at the D4
break which may eventually happen but
our generic icy is also one of the best
prepared players on the planet uh during
the Champions chess tour we were
mentioning it time and time again when
he impressed Vichy Anand was like are
you still in your prep and he goes I
have 10 moves more to look into it was a
really mesmerizing display of
preparation that he used against nihal
sarin in the tatasil India event but in
this one it's a closed position I feel
like for our generic geissi I mean he
should be happy about how this opening
is gone he's in zero risk at least at
the moment yep
yeah it's uh all theory if you will
write the eval bar properly reflects
both sides chances this is why the
Spanish has been played for so many
years by the best players in the world
because it gives chances to both sides
Arjun quite quite comfortable here up a
little bit on the clock a nice Queen
side expansion uh but all right this
game has yet to to show the the teeth
that it potentially has for white this
Knight coming to F1 white has some slow
plans in these positions you can
relocate the Knight to the king side try
to slowly manufacture a king side attack
you can also try to get to the D5 Square
uh depending on depending on where you
want that Knight to go so uh Maxime has
yet to show his cards yet I guess if you
will in terms of how aggressive he's
going to be uh with the first move in
this game
he has indeed I mean we don't know
what's going to happen next he is down
about a minute on the clock and while he
is I do want to zoom out for a second
because the second game has begun
Alexander grishek has white and look at
that position in the top right it's a
four knights with a knight hopping into
D4 Danny so a very different style of
position than the one we're just looking
at
my girls are just learning chess and I
would never let them play a move like
Knight to D4 moving a piece twice before
all the rest of your pieces are
developed what are you doing uh narayana
no but a Jokes Aside this is this is
some tricky stuff some tricky theory for
black and it does come with with uh with
risks but after the Knight comes to D4
you threaten to win the bishop pair so
white Retreats the bishop now black has
to deal with the E5 Pawn hanging and
there are more than a few ways to do
that oh and one of them is to just
Gambit it C6 and D5 here we go this
stuff is spicy because you can grab a
Pawn on E5 here for white and then black
plays this move D5 and after Pawn takes
D5 we see a position where black will be
at uh most down one Pawn here but you
have quick development you win Bishop D6
Castle bring your Rook to the center and
this King might get caught and if this
Knight moves ever back to F3 this bishop
comes out to G4 with a pin so just to
show something like that is if we make
some careless moves here comes the
bishop to G4 that's not fun I'm going to
take on F3 ruin your king Side Pawn
structure your king will never find
shelter so that's why black plays this
Gambit it's saying I will quickly go
after you and for shook now he's on the
clock
94 is such a cool kind of I guess you
know Modern Display of where the
concrete aspects of a position are more
important than the old principles that
used to guide us right don't move a
piece twice but in these situations as
we may be about to see here comes D5
we're not going to get the blunder I
think of Knight F3 but the point is that
904 Robert yes it moved twice but it
stops white from playing D4 right it's
on on a very strong Central Square kind
of a thorn in white side and and the key
to Black's initiative that is about to
come very quickly here with moves like
Bishop D6 and getting Castle so I like
it it's fun and uh black black is
playing maybe not necessarily for a win
but definitely playing to put pressure
here on grishek and grishek's thinking
which could be a bad sign for him as
he's not in preparation and this gets
hectic but he may play instead of Bishop
B3 just dropping back and allowing black
the time to kick the Knight he could
play Bishop B5 check we're talking about
how you want to keep the bishop here
this gives away the bishop pair but it
also gets that Knight out of this D4
Square so if I deliver a check and we
swap nights over here something like
this now white does have D4 to reinforce
the Knight and open up the bishop and of
course when if this Knight doesn't get
kicked there's no Bishop G4 pins and
structural damage
yeah I love that and again you gave up
the bishop here but remember you won a
pawn to get here so removing that knight
from D4 is probably White's top priority
in this position I'm sure grishek is
thinking about it but even though I got
roasted oh no he goes back to E2 I got
roasted for calling out grishook's
traditional time pressure that he
welcomes earlier uh mark my words that
as now we get to the more even matchups
on paper and gershek is facing some some
maybe even higher level preparation he
doesn't want to get himself under time
pressure but he just might against uh
narayanin and maybe Irrigation in the
next round so we'll have to watch out
for that all right speaking of things we
got to watch out for Robert it's time to
back up once again the bird's eye view
is ready all four games are officially
underway uh but we have to choose a
flavor
wow that that irrigation I know we were
just there excuse me but Eric I see
already with an advantage as Black
versus Maxine Bossier the grav uh but
which other game do we want to pay off
first I just want to make a few comments
about the other two games and we will go
back to Maxime and Arjun in the bottom
left we have mitravagua with the white
pieces against Demonte dollite cornet
and it says Advantage black but it's one
of these positions that it gets messy
quickly because it's not just a clear
Advantage where it moves are simple it's
look at white on the long diagonal
Black's Pawn structure will be hanging
pawns so it's going to be one for the
Long Haul and in the bottom right we're
just getting started so I do think we
should go to Arjun and Maxime it's a
really critical matchup here uh for
these two teams and Denny lacks Pawn
structure a bit compromise after the
bishop exchange double Pawns in the
center but we tend to like these double
pawns because it keeps that Knight out
Knight E3 dominated by the pawn three
squares away yep
one and now black can can play a move
like Knight D4 also the B4 Pawn is under
Fire we should just point that out right
now white has to deal with that threat
black also dominates the a file which
allows Rook A3 which is poking at the D3
Pawn right so white actually despite
black having the optically bad looking
Double D pawns white actually has the
pawns that are the most targetable here
right the D3 pawn and the B4 Pawn are
both a bit of issues will you play a
move like Queen B1 okay or queen C2 that
dynamically defends B4 because it pins
the Knight on C6 uh but I'm I'm liking
I'm liking arjun's chances and uh again
given the time the time we see it shows
that he comes well prepared the uh the
kid knows what he's doing
um despite his inability to keep his
shelf organized
well he has his life organized he had
2700 plus player he signed a 1.5 million
dollar contract with Quant box or has
spread over five years but he can now
bring his Queen over to B7 he could
organize his pieces I'll bring his Queen
to A8 defending the Knight on C6 keeping
the back rank so the king feels safer
and taking over the a file completely I
feel like Arjun is playing a wonderful
game of chess thus far and Maxine better
be careful he's quick on in terms of
time but he better be quick on the board
because he may find himself losing a
pawn at some point yeah black is putting
on the pressure
in the immediate sense Arjun has to deal
with a threat white will play Rook to C1
if you give Maxine One More move and
that night running into problems but we
we're sure Arjun is going to find a
square for the queen and then the
question will be okay and he does indeed
with D7 now the question will be how
does white defend B4 uh and as uh as we
put it out Knight to D4 is an option
because normally you may not like that
trade but if that trade happens in that
E3 Knight doesn't have a happy Square it
can't go forward because that pawn on E6
keeps it at base so anyway interesting
stuff I I admit I would probably lose
this position for either side
um it's that imbalance you know uh but
uh but I can't wait to see how these two
gentlemen play it much better than I
would well I do think your idea from
earlier Bishop d8 Bishop B6 is also in
the cards let's just try to improve this
piece that's staring into pawns it's not
needed on the F6 Square so that's the
one problematic piece I think it can be
improved I like arjun's position but
this remains a game so I feel like we'll
leave these two super jams to it and
maybe we'll zoom out for a second
because all four boards are in full
swing
yeah uh Diamante dulite cornet versus uh
mitraba guha is one we haven't checked
on
it's getting weird with a queen on H4 a
knight on e4 what's going on
you tell me yeah it is pretty weird
because there's a queen trade offered
and white instead of trading Queens
brought this Rook to D1 saying please
take me this is a good instructive
lesson that you trade on your own terms
and if black takes this queen on H4 that
welcomes this Knight out to H4 with
Tempo against this bishop and if you say
let's just trade pieces you're not
trading you're in fact losing a piece on
the spot a knight takes this bishop the
other one's under attack the Knight on
D2 is loose as well white just wins so
let's say you don't trade Queens uh on
H4 well what's the idea you're just
going after these Central pawns hanging
pawns yeah probably the most difficult
Pawn structure to deal with Danny uh
maybe that's overstaying the case but
I've always felt that way even at my
Grandmaster level
yeah I was just about to ask you why
does the computer prefer black gear
because everything you said even in my
International Master Level lower than
you I'm like everything about this tells
me White's about to be better the pieces
are going to be traded which means those
pawns which are really a middle game
advantage in order to use a hanging
component Advantage everyone you want
pieces you want to have a reason to use
that space if black can play moves Queen
D7 or queen C7 to put a couple Rooks
behind the pawns you might have some big
pressure but I feel like with the piece
is getting traded white has an advantage
here so I don't quite understand well
it's what you just said pieces getting
traded I think black and the last one
should put the pawn F6 I know Ben
Feingold says never play F6 but a move
ago if we can bring up the analysis
board yeah let's do that I get the idea
you're just trying to create space for
your king but F6 shuts down the queen
trade shuts down the bishop all at once
and if you ever take this Knight on e4
well it in comes the rook and the queen
is in danger so I feel like keeping the
piece on the board was advantageous or
black you just have the activity and the
bishop pair but now that H6 was played I
think you could swap wins and after The
Rook takes maybe take this Knight on e4
because if the bishop takes on e4 here
those hanging pawns they're not going to
be lost but I can bring my knight back
first get out of here you go back I
bring my Bishop here and like it's every
which way you're being threatened and I
just feel like it's uncomfortable for
black even though the eval Bar says
you're fine it's about equal I think
it's just an easier position to play for
white who's actually targeting the black
Pawns
yeah uh very very well said and the
instructed points remain for chat that
when you have a hanging Pawn structure
keeping the pieces on the board has to
be the top priority otherwise you don't
really have a way to justify those pawns
being loose F6 as awkward as that was
the moment you suggested I'm like okay
that's the Grand Master move and you
know
um I'm not a grand master I took Ben
Feingold a long time to become a grand
master maybe that's why we struggle with
that puns
well I don't know about that Danny
you're a great chef just looking for
ways to get Ben involved in the show
looking to roast him hi Ben I know but
I'm not gonna let you roast yourself I
told you the self-deprecation that can't
happen I'm gonna have to be the one
roasting you in therapy okay therapy
you're right okay therapy anyway
um all right but no seriously F6 is a
really strong move it also had that
purpose as you said making that Bishop
on B2 kind of stare at granted that's
that's a it's a really instructive idea
I love it and now uh now black may be
regretting it very soon black may not
lose the end game but the piece is being
traded surely favors white those pawns
only get weaker with every Miner that
leaves the board so
um all right every minor piece gone
makes those pawns harder to play with
all right let's back up what do we got
we got more chess more games to look at
only one board that we haven't checked
in on do we go uh go pay off Savita
versus Boyer see what's going on I'm
just gonna note then top left Maxine by
Sheila Grove has lost the B4 Pawn so
Arjun eragite in the driver's seat on
the bottom right we just saw that Boyard
stole the pawn on B2 so let's go into
that one because Boyer he is now up a
pawn at least temporarily he's also up
three plus minutes he is playing
lightning quick chest and of the best
that white can do is try to take this
Pawn on C6 that's not going to get it
done the bishop on B6 is a monster the
Knight on B3 is not a very good piece
it's not the Steed it's a donkey and I
like Boyer's chances in this one
agreed and uh the healthy Pawn is
already already hard to argue with um
what do you what do you player if you
take on C6 twice black can regain the
pawn by putting a rook on C8 and you win
the you win the C2 Pawn right back I
assume that's the move yeah
um but if you're not going to take your
Pawn back now you may never have another
chance because on the next oh by the way
a trade on C6 didn't occur and then C4
by Sunita interesting okay
oh that's a really smart move I wasn't
even looking in that direction but she's
trying to shut down this bishop and
disconnect the Bishop from the a pawn
and that's actually a really nice try by
her I think Queen takes c66 was easily
winning for black after Rook Sierra
getting active so C4 is a wonderful move
by her she's still worse but she can
play Rook to B1 now C5 is coming C6 is
loose A7 may be a Target
good move
I love it and if C5 comes even if you
don't win the C6 Pawn right away much
better chances you can kick the queen
from B2 and relocate that Knight at some
point so this is a way to to play a
position down a pawn is to is to make
sure that your opponent's pawns can't
really use their advantage they can't
get going oh and by the way so black
plays C5 but the compromise of that is
now you've made your Bishop kind of a
dull boy over there on B6 and uh I
really like what you said I think Savita
found the best way to keep the fight
alive here with C4 and if she could
bring her Knight to D5 she might just be
better even though she's seriously so
this bishop is really just you know
acting as a pawn and the inherent
limitation of a bishop it only controls
the color complexes on so I actually
like the move Knight A5 because if we
get liquidation I know I'm talking about
bringing the Knight to a good square but
just a step back and move and bring up
the analysis board that if Knight A5 and
you take it well this should help
White's chances the second Rook comes to
A1 we're gonna hit A7 we're gonna hit C5
we're going to see liquidation and that
should help the chances to hold the game
but instead she just decided to bring a
rook over the queen went back to F6 and
well what about this end game Danny we
could take on F6 black saying my double
I say Pawn's not a big deal I have an
outside passer and it's an extra Pawn I
think you highlighted it well if only
the Knight could move diagonally and
through its own Pawn right if that
Knight lands on D5 completely different
evaluation of this position but a long
way to get there and what can black do
in the meantime and if I if I was to
give one other evaluation about this uh
this matchup from 30 000 feet I would
say the only other problem I've noticed
with Savita throughout the day is she's
been consistently down on time right and
that's hard uh obviously she's been
playing super strong players but looking
at that clock before we leave it black
doubles White's time on on the clock and
that may end up being her end up being
her own doing I'm with you I mean the
double pawns aren't that big of a deal
look at Boyer going in the open file
stopping 94 and at some moment once this
bishop moves the a pawn will be released
but that's far away because the Rook is
on the B file it's creating some
pressure so she has chances but the
clock is not doing her any favors I'm
with you and we can hop around to
another game just because uh and this
one will go for a bit with the end game
what catches your eye we gotta go back
to the iRig Icy game uh he's continuing
to uh to flex a small advantage against
MBL but it's a small advantage that I
think could become a bigger one in a
hurry he's upon upon on B5 and now he's
using it I think wisely which is more of
a let me just forget about that guy and
put pressure on White's pieces prevent
Maxine from improving his King side look
at this he's tactically holding on to
the pawn 94.
I'll show that give me that pawn oh have
fun with it because Knight D4 says
please take my free night it's free go
for it but after Queen takes F2 check
the king is just hunted down the king
would have to go over to a square like
H2 you take this Pawn the king comes
back and I don't know where the
Checkmate is but I'm guessing it's
somewhere here maybe it's got It's gotta
be there I yeah E5 maybe or but then
there's Queen C4 check I actually don't
know what
maybe just back between here simple
chest okay can't protect we have six
simple chests
uh I was grimacing when I when when you
first started showing this line because
you're shaking my head for my boy Maxine
this is super tough and he is down a
little bit on the clock so okay he has
already played Queen B3 Rook A5
but his chances to hold this are based
on whether irigaisi can coordinate the
pieces and just use the extra pawn and I
don't know how many tricks Maxine can
come up with
uh before before that happens
well this is just a clean extra Pawn
especially if you play B4 now it's
protected by all your minor pieces the
rook and slept to A3 to go after this
Knight on E3 that's been the problematic
piece we mentioned it a while back this
Knight on E3 dominated by this Pawn on
E6 it never got anywhere and all it's
doing is blocking the bishop that's an
important task but I think that you can
dislodge it with B4 and Rook A3
yeah I feel you dog I feel is that that
feel your dog I feel your dog I feel
your dog is that a thing people still
say I feel like you just you know aged
yourself a lot I just aged myself
um
well I do I do uh I'm picking up what
you're putting down
uh
what what sandwich do you want me to
finish okay hold on D6 is traded for F2
I don't know that that's a uh
that that's a simplification Maxine
wants Arjun
go ahead I feel like there's just I mean
there have to be so many tactics here
but Arjun is doing the right thing he
can take enough to with check and then
move his Queen he has that as an option
but he probably has a game ending tactic
we see it on the oh
he takes away the H2 Square it's made
Rook takes C5 is meant by Rook A1 check
and it's Rover
so good yeah he just took away the
Escape Square
D It's Crazy and Maxine is shaking his
head seriously his tactics are just
bananas it's
he wins he wins games I mean you could
have played a number of moves there as
black but he pauses his sense of danger
right that's one thing that he has he he
spots those tactics because I feel like
he has a sense when there's a blunder
that was made and and always seems to
capitalize
yeah maybe he's like Austin Powers his
middle name is danger and he can just go
Rook takes F2 Queen G3 this is just mate
right
oh Quita G3 please play Queen to G3 no
not right away because the A2 Rook hangs
right
that looks good right it looks fun Brook
takes F2 Rook takes C5 Queen to G3 there
is 91 oh I didn't see that honestly
okay so maybe that's the problem
oh he's out on your minute
yeah queen bee what was the resourceful
move by Maxime it's funny because we
have the we have the luxury of the eval
bar but Arjun doesn't have that and so
it's a little tricky yeah we were
looking at Rook F2 and if Rook takes C5
Queen G3 I thought it was just leading
to Checkmate but there is Knight E1 and
maybe Black's still winning because you
can bring this Knight up into D4 and
just go into the game oh I blundered
somehow just check E5 check okay this is
just getting wild I'm I can't see it
like Argent I'm just gonna trust him
Arjun only has 30 seconds though to a
minute and a half from mvl by the way uh
the the other games in this round are
also still going but we're probably
going to stick right here
um because this this is a game with so
much on the line with two of two of the
biggest names playing in this matchup he
gives away his Rook because the C1 Rook
is loose but Rook C8 check King A7 you
can get this Rook but he's going for a
mate there's just got to be a Checkmate
over here because he is giving up a rook
where is Stone Cold killer
focused
where's the the Checkmate Danny after
Knight takes F3 there's Queen takes F2
um uh wait those Queen H2 mate if you
take it oh I miss Maiden one and then
two look at him he's hiding his face
but I don't know what he just said to
himself but gave himself a good slap in
the cheek and uh unfortunately Arjun
gets it done in style if you're if
you're a blitz fan
um I just want to show the conclusion
here that uh Queen takes F2 there's
Queen H2 Checkmate maybe that's the line
that mvo missed like I did and if you
take this Knight on F3 directly you get
checkmated by force Queen takes Pawn the
king is in the corner keep pushing it
back and then there's two checkmates
either Queen H3 or queen G1 is mate the
bishop covers the square and of course
you want is the same mate so our generic
I see Maxine is uh he hasn't got him
Arjun gets up in a hurry Maxime is
already hitting that game review button
let me see my game report where did this
go wrong uh and uh we'll we'll leave him
to analyzing as we back up Alexander
grishek and Narayanan look like they're
getting closer to a draw but Narayanan
the only one with chances so the chances
for the blitz not looking great right
now
with iRig icy having already taken down
NBL and Narayanan is the only one who
can win this game even though it is
likely a draw yeah now he's into his
play in the bullish Chess Championship
he's a great bullet player in addition
to his classical and rapid and Blitz
skills so this one actually is quite
easy for white you just sit you do
nothing you movie Rook back and forth
there's not an easy way for black to
make progress except for G5 G4 except
when you give up your Jeep
he was laughing he's like well that's
not gonna do a lot for my winning
chances we'll take a drop off okay well
that makes our lives easier and the
blitz can be a bit happier that game is
a draw two games remain Danny in the
bottom right looks like uh yeah let's do
it completely winning
Savita versus Boyer a huge Victory this
would be for the blitz remember they
were down a point uh coming into this
round three so they need everything they
can get and right as we join Boyer does
get the job done winning a piece on E2
after the move Bishop E1 very very nice
uh savitas time pressure unfortunately
remains her Achilles heel it does and
just to quickly show that black just
infiltrated with the pieces Brooks the
center Bishop kicking the night away the
bishop slides up helping the pawn go
forward and then the Rooks come into the
game and it was a devastating win for a
black pin and then when that's game over
so win for Boyer went for the Blitz and
that leaves one game remaining here
Danny yeah and it's between mitravagua
and Demonte dollite this is a huge one
because if the blitz somehow take this
game with the black pieces they will be
tied
yeah a this would be a reversal of the
last round
if cornet can get the job done
unfortunately probably only white has
winning chances in this in this Rook
ending but you know time pressure does
crazy things to people so we'll see
yes and playing for results also does
crazy things if you're playing for a win
that can backfire but here white is too
stable on structure is nice and
protected one Palm nylon here where D5
is Iceland here goes mid trouble goes
Brooks going after A7 and White's King
even though black king is out on E6 you
can check it backwards and maybe the
white king could play A Part here
thank you
I'm with you I was just trying to
imagine is there any real winning
chances here now okay if that King gets
to E5
Watch Out The Rook can come to A6 oh oh
and uh
but that makes H6 weak yeah so The Rook
can come to the sixth rank you can't
play Rook D6 because the A7 Pawn Falls
so by the way why wasn't Rook A6
just no F6 I guess for black it was it
wasn't losing yet F6 was possible but
but she walked into you see her uh go
back in her chair she blunted it oh is
it is it Checkmate the King goes up to
E4 it's almost Checkmate here if you can
get F4 to work
yeah so G5 this is a really again
instructive example for for viewers that
pushing those Pawns in the end game we
saw unfortunately uh Four Dead mods she
she played a B Pawn advance and and it
lost her a game earlier and now she
moved the g-pawn which again usually the
right way to hold these Rook endings is
to just sit tight or really really think
about whether you need to change your
defensive setup in this case she did so
too early and it made a bunch of
weaknesses on the king side that's
Checkmate in one move yep
and I think we just show that just one
more time as uh metropica he's maybe the
hero for mgd1 because he drew for Shook
and now won his game here but back when
she played the move G5 Danny it created
a weakness a permanent weakness a
backwards pawn and a lot for Rook A6
yeah
again it's it's understandable because I
was just asking the question myself do I
need to stop King E5 so no judgment it
makes sense right you're worried about
this King F4 King E5 when you're under
time pressure sometimes things look
scarier than they actually are and she
kind of panics that actually opens up
the door for much bigger problems now
you have two weaknesses as they say
principle of two weaknesses both the H
and the a pawn are ultimately waikou has
able to get it done and uh yeah you're
right dude's the hero right now he is
helping mgd1 extend their lead uh as we
as we continue to go forward they win
Another Round Here by a score of two and
a half to one and a half total uh
biggest takeaway here though despite
buha's win to me is irigaisy getting the
job done with black over Maxine Basha
The Grove yeah that's a monster
performance for Arjun Eric I said we
know what he's capable of and he just
put it on full display taking down the
French with three names he kind of
slaughtered him in that one and it
looked like Arjun was in the driver's
seat the whole time so it's a lead for
MGD one it's first to eight points if
seven team Blitz only has five didn't he
I don't know what the blitz have to do
but they're getting blitzed
right now the mgd1 team is only a point
and a half away let's bring up the
standings in this matchup uh that that
means they could even lose this round
two and a half one and a half and they
still get the job done so that's kind of
a scary position to be in if you're the
blitz you have to win by a minimum score
of three to one to tie this thing at
eight games a piece so you know if
you're if you're storyboarding this
thing hashtag scripted some fans think
all sports are scripted I think that's
an insane conspiracy theory but we'll
talk about that later uh it would if if
you're drawing up the 3-1 Victory it has
to start I think at the top with grishek
taking down the Unstoppable to this
point Arjun irigaisi yeah good luck to
anybody needing a win against Arjun but
if anyone could do it yeah Alexander
gristook the three-time world Blitz
Champion can uh he'll have his work cut
out for him but he needs to lead the
blitz back as they're down by two points
yep and you'll have to do it against the
only person still perfect on the day 3-0
Arjun irrigation so all right what will
happen will we have a storybook comeback
or will mgd1 get the job done don't go
anywhere we got 12 000 of you on Twitch
more than 3 000 on YouTube the day is
only just beginning to Much More Much
More chess ahead so we will come back
with round four of our first matchup of
the day the pro Chesley continues in
just a few
I remember people saying no you got a
sandbag keep your rating low don't clean
the world open and win six thousand
dollars you know just just don't don't
keep your rating up and I'd be like what
are you talking about I'm trying to
become a GM that's ridiculous so that
mentality was something I had to
escape this was not the black bear
School mentality but the park ecosystem
that to me was Prospect Park in Brooklyn
definitely Foster this idea because
a little bit of muscle mentality that
you keep your rating low and you try to
lose
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back here the pro chess League
continues Alexander grishek
right there continues to try to get the
job done and he'll have to get the job
done Robert if the blitz have any chance
in pulling off a comeback
well Simon and Garfunkel calling because
they're saying hello darkness my old
friend look at grashook there the lights
are dimming not just on him but on the
blitz's chances because they are down
seven to five but Alexander grishook he
gets those black pieces against none
other than Arjun Eric icy a lot will be
resting on the three-time World list
Champion shoulder well and that's why
you go get yourself a free agent like
Alexander grishek right now we know he
has a tough task and again our junior
geisi is the only perfect score on the
day he just beat Maxine Bashi the rock
with the black pieces so we're not
saying it's a task that he we should
expect that he can get done but that's
why you go sign free agents right if you
are the blitz you bring in a guy like
grishek four moments like these uh in in
hopes that he can give your team a
fighting chance so so let me ask you for
the storyboard let's say grishek pulls
off the maybe improbable winning with
black over Arjun era geisi what are the
other two games that you have circled
where the blitz maybe have a chance to
do the 3-1 score that they meet you know
me I've been talking about the bottom
two boards board three and four I know
mitravagua has performed well for MGD
one but for the blitz mihal Boyer just
had my board I just had a great result
against Savita Shri he won that game
with black he needs to use the biggest
Advantage with the white pieces against
guha and
she has zero points but she's earned
herself some very good positions she
probably should have about one out of
three on the day a couple draws have
slipped out of her fingertips but those
two matchups with the white pieces she
they have to make the most of it on the
bottom board
I agree and you know the more I look at
the more I think there's there's a
chance here because I know Maxine just
lost a tough game uh news flash he was
playing Arjun irigaisy a guy who's just
seems to beat everyone right now so if
if he somehow gets the job done right if
MBL gets the job done the bottom two
boards have white as you said right both
cornet and Boyer have an opportunity
with the first move to maybe Flex some
aggressive chess and so I don't think uh
that uh that the blitz are done just yet
and and of course we started off the top
saying grishek is brought on more
moments like this so let's see what
happens the first moves are about to be
underway Alexander grishek probably
finishing checking his prep don't worry
we got two cameras on everybody but you
are allowed to check prep before the
game so either that or he's giving his
kid a snack because often he's kind of
double dutying
um I've been there you know working and
and dating at the same time so what
exactly is gershwick doing who knows I
think you need a new name double dutying
sounds like something different so you
know double duty is also something I've
done as a dad that we don't like to talk
about anymore my youngest kid is no
longer in diapers and thank you okay she
still is very cute if you're watching hi
Talia why we see that this is a French
defense you know how I feel about that
but it's an homage to the team it's team
Blitz led by Kevin boardy blitzstream
they are yeah I'm France so uh you know
I actually kind of like it I have to say
I dislike the opening but I have to
appreciate it for the moment you don't
see the French at the highest level very
often so Arjun doesn't get that much
over the board experience against this
line right and it's funny you don't see
it at the highest levels for a reason
because with the right prep with your A
game the French is good for white at the
highest levels but sometimes we see that
Gambit pay off right where the fact that
you don't play it as often because it's
not good for your opponent means that
when faced with those practical
decisions Robert you can misstep right
so why do you see players at the top
level occasionally bust out a French or
like a sicilian Dragon kind of falls in
the same category because you're kind of
saying hey look I know if you about all
your prep that this is a gamble but if
you don't I'm giving myself double edge
chances and I need to get a victory and
this variation can often Peter out into
a draw we've seen many games in this
line with repetition The Rook will
eventually land on the B7 square like
right now and the queen often goes to d8
First throwing into check if the move G3
happens the queen can slide back still
Bishop F2 again the queen comes back and
the bishop can go to B6 so we have seen
draws in this line and I wonder if
you're mgd1 if you're our generic IC are
you okay making a quick draw that might
make your teammates feel a little bit
better the pressure is off them because
even though a draw is not the desired
result with the white piece is it's a
seven and a half you only need a half
point to ensure a tie breaker and one
full point to win the match
I would say yes I think that also From
grishek's perspective he's kind of like
well look I don't have my absolute best
chest today Eric I sees a monster I went
for a gamble here I'm black I'm willing
for a draw guy so I don't know I don't
really know how that how that plays it
would be anti-climactic for us because
we just said hey you bring on a guy like
grishek to get the job done uh all right
but here guys he answers the question he
says all right I'm gonna let this game
play out
um I'm not necessarily taking the
repetition at this time good news for
Alexander grishop because right now you
see he has the bishop pair that's good
for blacks let me make that green you
have a healthier Pawn structure white
has split pawns on the queen side the
good thing going on for Arjun is his
active Rook on B7 you can delve Rooks in
the B5 you can also play F5 at the right
moment white king is safe and sound on
G1 blacks King in the center or even
Castle kingside can fall victim to an
attack especially if this bishop jumps
out to the D4 Square so I think that
their chances for both here and by the
way Denny I know I see the second game
has started as well but I believe that
the blitz should be happy to have a
combative game between Grisha and Eric
ice
agreed agreed the uh the the gamble paid
off kind of playing to the fact that
maybe you're a geisey wouldn't take the
repetition and now grishek is going to
get some chefs to fight for let's back
up to the bird's eye view and see what
the other players are fighting for I
think we have a London almost as painful
as a Scandinavian and that Narayanan
versus Maxima Sheila board uh but all
right E5 is on the board early this is
going to be a fight for sure yeah next
year's a Torre attack instead of a
London but very similar with uh the pawn
structure being the triangle they bring
your Knights to these squares the
official comes out but if I played now
that's not threatening it's not winning
any material anything of the sword but
it does gain black important space and
maybe black will play E4 that's
something that you always say Danny is
that you tend to attack in the direction
of your pawns I think that's confusing
in the London and in the Torre because
White's on chain are going in both
directions so are we playing towards the
king side are we playing towards the
queen side which way do we operate
well often that's kind of the idea of
those super solid structures you think
of the same thing when you look at a Bad
Thing English right the fact that you
have a essential structure that bodes
well white can play for B4 whatever
black sometimes white can expand on the
king side not in this particular case
but I think Maxime is happy because if
black gets E4 and D5 and can somehow
reorganize the pieces to start expanding
at least you have a double-edged
position that you can that you can fight
for an attack um
although that's also a huge commitment
right because when you play E4 and D5
you fully commit uh to the darkspurs
also being a problem that Bishop can
come back to G3 white will eventually
play C4 and kind of go for a different
type of structure once uh once the
Pawn's on D5 so all right H6 is flexible
maybe you're gonna play G5 Maxime is is
trying to toy toy with this moment a
little bit and I think black's
intentions are very clear using your
words of wisdom you play towards the
direction that your pawns are facing
black is trying to move this Knight and
play F5 as well let's get an attack
going look at how solid Black's position
is The Queen 98 looks awkward because it
makes the rock stuck on f8 but it's
doing an important role and The Rook
will be active if the pawn gets to F5 so
G5 may be next in a must win game Danny
this is exactly what you need for
maximum I love this position for black
and it is a bit of a clinic in regards
to when you advise students how to play
against a Tory or a London style
structure like this challenging the dark
Square grip that white has with this
lead Pawn on D4 is key whether it's E5
or C5 both moves are often key to the
aggressive and effective black
repertoires against the structure but
when you combine it with this H6 the
Knight can go to H7 you're going to play
F5 you're you're expanding on the king
side before you've even committed E4
because you might trap the bishop
exactly G5 and F4 right exactly again
exactly there you go sorry Jaster came
in the moment I said exactly yaster came
in and now he's gone
yep yasu knows he talks about squares he
talks about each placement and here A4
that's that expansion that you were
talking about potentially for white I
just feel like that's not the important
part of the board at least not for the
time being so I like this position for
Maxine versus he can play G5 it's not
overextending your king is perfectly
safe back here uh he can go with that or
as you're indicating move this Knight
maybe to D7 or H7 he goes with G5 he's
playing for the results he's playing for
the win and watch out because F5 F4 may
hit you and it will trap your Bishop on
G3
are there okay I was gonna say are there
tactics on E5 with the Knight being
loose possibly not yeah you have to take
care first I think because of that I
think Jenny's okay you're pointing out
that in the event of D takes E5 a white
does have Bishop E5 because once we see
this trade this is a loose piece
dropping off scenario the 9h5 is a goner
so after d takes E5 it almost certainly
uh oh wait what wait he took wait he
took he took it he went E4 couldn't you
just take this Pawn
or was there G4 is that the point some
kind of
attack on this night but the answer is
clearly not because Bishop takes G7 oh
my gosh that's right here no but this
looks bad for black because if Bishop
takes uh for white excuse me because
Knight takes G7 but you take here and
after it takes Queen takes
oh you got to see these things if you're
not Ariana
seriously that that's an opportunity you
might not get back against MBL so Maxime
could have just gotten away with one I'm
glad I asked the dumb question about
whether E5 was hanging because turns out
it could have been a critical tactic
vaccine doesn't have to be asked twice
to move that Knight on H5 to safety
plants it on F4 and I'm back to liking
black chances in this game
um all right let's back up there are two
other games we haven't looked at yet all
four of these games matter just as much
on the scoreboard in the end we've got a
dynamic Affair happening in that French
between irrigation we'll come back to
that in a minute uh but we've also got
okay two other games down down below the
blitz need dubs potentially in both of
them voyeur in a French also uh against
guha and then Cornett
um in a uh would look to be a weird kind
of Rouser Sicilian probably with the six
Bishop D7 line I know that line well
um and uh I kind of like White's chances
in that game I like white chance that
both of the bottom two boards and yeah
these are critical matchups every single
game is of equal importance a win is a
win for your team let's go to the Boyer
game against guha just because that pawn
structure looks terrible for black but
it's also it's something that is known
right we've seen the double isolated H
pawns many times this isn't an end game
right and Boyer I mean we're just going
away from the screen like he does not
want to be on camera right now
he's slowly shifting
yeah he is and he's but he's also
shifting his pieces towards the king
side at some point Queen D2 you go to F4
and in the future this Knight if you're
not careful that Knight goes into D6
with check the game might just be over
so for now I think that black has
everything under control but A6 is maybe
the move you have to play but Danny if
you play A6 just we can bring up
analysis board you're covering the
Knight D5 jump but I'm looking at this
position and I'm thinking well can I
play a C4 push at some point can I bring
my Rooks to the center and I guess Who
Was Not Afraid just hassles kingside and
the Knight goes back to C2 rather than
up to B5
immediately boy you're not taking a lot
of time to consider it may be already a
little nervous that he's down a minute
and a half on the clock I don't know I
kind of liked I kind of liked your goal
of getting a pony to D6 maybe maybe a
tactically just didn't work anymore
because of things like Knight takes E5
maybe
um but all right it brings the Knight to
C2 he's also headed to E3 to G4 and if
he can reroute himself to the king side
uh guha might regret how cat how
Cavalier he was about putting the King
on G8
usually black plays F6 to try to break
down this Pawn chain but it's not good
here because you'll be saddled with this
backwards Pawn E6 and your king side
will be even more open but Knight E3 to
G4 is automatic I don't see an easy way
to stop it and don't play Queen takes B2
it looks like a free Pawn good for you
Rook F to B1 traps the queen on the spot
Queen can't get out of here the Knight
is covering the A3 Square so your queen
is lost on B2 I love this for the blitz
I think that uh yeah Boyer is playing a
great game and it's an easy game for him
to play who cares about the queen side
it's gonna be all about this King side
over here
yeah and by the way I think he's also
sporting a blitz jersey with that camera
adjustment I kind of looked at it I
think he's got the same Jersey on that
Maxime does so shout out to the blitz
for bringing the team spirit and maybe
it uh maybe it helps them rally here
with a comeback right there's a reason
we we have a score you got to get to
eight and a half so while it may seem
like a tough task it's not over yet and
not over I love Boyer's chances yeah me
too he should throw his b-pawn up it was
a Target now we can use it to his
Advantage kick this night out the E5
Square will be carved for the White
Knight and that's a bad news for Black's
pieces I feel like white just has a
spatial Advantage a better Pawn
structure if black brings a second Rook
to f8 uh what are you doing I have my
pieces blocking your path it's not
accomplishing all that much so I think
it's time to throw the pawns up the
queen side
agreed B4 B5 if that Knight has to leave
C6 you might just put your knight on E5
uh and uh that's usually a problem in
these front structures so
I'm look I'm looking at it and I'm
liking it now a little bit of a Time
Advantage for guha so Boyer should not
overthink the situation at this time
that could that could backfire later but
uh let's back up and take a look at the
only game we haven't yet in the other
Blitz battle again they need a 3-1 score
minimum to make a comeback uh
as we as we let's let's go back to the
bird's eye view and check out the other
the other game because I think we want
to check on uh did Monte uh delete
cornett's game
um her battle versus Savita let's take a
look over there let's do it by the way
Boyer did push the pawn up to B4 a move
later he's trying to expand on the queen
side let's go to the bottom right
because this is up Danny wrench's
wheelhouse we have a kind of a Rouser
system uh black with these double pawns
and then pushing this Pawn to B5 as well
trying to go after the white king but
Danny to my eyes the white king is
perfectly safe with all these pieces
yeah and you're already spying at ideas
like 95 here like this is I don't know
whether you can play it but this is this
is uh this is how the magic happens and
these browsers facilities 95 takes takes
the queen moves sorry the bishop moves
and you move the knight from G from okay
that's a little crazy but like 94 but
even even just to show like 90 yeah 94 I
was gonna say Knight F3 and the point is
that you're bringing the Knight to F5 in
some of these positions and and it's
actually just really really hard to play
Black despite the extra piece
um anyway we'll see
yeah I think it just goes it's one of
these positions where Knight D5 is
extremely tempting but it's not
necessary because after Knight D5 let's
say black instead of uh you know you
can't just go back and play like this
and say prove it now it's you need to
win the game so you feel good that you
have winning chances but white is
already better there's no rush in this
position because these are cemented in
place not going anywhere so I feel like
instead of Knight D5 F5 is thematic yep
you just say those pawns really not
going anywhere please push the spawn up
because once the queen slides back the
D5 square is wise for taking this is not
even a bishop anymore it's just a piece
in the dark squares
frankenpod white is strategically one
yeah white has Knight F1 Knight E3 you
bring the other night into D5 you end up
with uh one of them one of them still
standing at the end and just absolutely
dominating that pawn of a bishop on E7
so I love it I love it getting the
subtle lessons for me Danny play
positionally oh and look at that but uh
demante agrees with me it's time to go
all in here
um and unfortunately for both myself and
cornette if I'm honest maybe we should
learn a thing or two about uh taking
playing chess a little slower like
Robert Hess um because this sacrifice
may not have been necessary for what you
know I'm I kind of don't mind it because
look at the clock situation you've
called this out game after game savita's
biggest Kryptonite it has been hurt
playing quite well throughout the day
but she gets in time trouble yeah and
when you're in time trouble and this
Rook is barreling down the e-file this
queen can steal a second Pawn you may
get two pawns and an attack or a
sacrifice Knight I'm feeling it I I see
the evaluation bar I'm biased by it a
little bit but I think that it's scary
and when you kind of put that fear in
your opponent's heart it's hard to play
when you're in a rapid time
yeah playing a king in the center with
your opponent all in on the attack is no
one loves playing those positions and
nobody loves playing them when you don't
have a lot of time so all right
obviously it was the first move I called
attention to when we got here so I'm
glad she played it but I do agree with
you that F5 a slightly more positional
grind of an approach was perfectly
playable as well so let's just show one
more critical line again so if e takes
D5 e takes D5 here
Bishop moves let's look at your queen
takes up six I was um you know the
bishop is pinned The Rook has to move to
f8
okay
and maybe just bring the Rook up by the
way can we do can we just show please 94
just make me happy now that just now
that the Rook is on f8 just you know for
the kids what do you want me to show
wait Knight takes up six and rookie
eight is made it's double check there's
a rook on a fade oh my gosh okay uh
never mind delete it back up so no one
saw what I did
[Laughter]
I'll I'll help Danny's point I'll help
Danny's point if this Rook were here
maybe and then if it still doesn't work
because the King goes to f8 we'll go
King here and this is what Danny was
hoping for
oh my gosh I've been up since 5 30. I'm
tired okay
um anyway
do your puzzle rush so you don't miss
tactics like that
um all right okay she's worth the bishop
it worked she scared her right she
played 95. she took with the bishop
keeps the king uh safer in the center
thanks to this wall of Pawn that's a
Phalanx unfortunately the light score
domination is just devastating yeah five
sticking out Queen F5 Knight E4 you
mentioned this Knight getting to F5 this
is strategically already one for white I
completely agree and you you called it
Knight D5 it worked I love I love what
you said and what he was saying is the
bluff worked right Knight D5 Black's
best chances are to call the bluff in
variations we were kind of just looking
at with each takes D5 she doesn't and
white is this is a very hard position
for white not to win so let's take a 30
000 foot view here Robert look at this
if Demonte wins this game
back to the back to the bird's eye view
the blitz are already in much better
shape here
the the chances of a comeback are very
very real uh if Demonte can win this
game
yeah no then she is going to win this
game there's just no risk in her
position she's up a couple minutes so it
was a sacrifice that panned out I think
in classical it's just it still might
have been a good one just because
practically speaking difficult for black
to defend so black has no activity a
white can hop around this is oh look at
this your idea is about to happen it's
just yeah devastated
Knight Pops in on F5 uh black is busted
so all right now back to the bird's eye
view uh where are we at in the other
games Maxine bashayla grav looking
pretty good as Black versus
neuron Young
so mvl in the driver's seat and that one
maybe we should hold that what's going
on in the shook game by the way Arjun
has a Pawn on E7 all these games are
pretty wild but I'll pull up the game uh
we'll go to the game between Maxine
versus Sheila Grove and uh SL nariana
let's do it so Narayanan is uh trying to
hold on he's uh he's worse in that
position as we can see in the upper
right there we go
um and uh
I know this is a position where the E5
are only a little bit favors black but
it feels much better for Maxime he's
also up a minute and a half on the clock
I mean look at the time look at the
position uh the Queen's trade is on the
table this Pawn F5 it sticks out these
pawns on B4 and A4 the rook and the
queen are lined up against them you
couldn't
ask for a better winning chance for me I
think he's just winning not even a
chance I think he's certainly going to
win this game he's up a pawn in the
starting position as well
I mean so storyboard I'm not gonna jinx
it but De Monte potentially getting a
dub on board four if Maxime gets a win
here on board two all the blitz need is
one more full point on one of the two
other remaining games so by the way now
after B5 uh A4 Pawn is is hanging in
these variations it's understandable
because you're trying to highlight that
the bishop on G3 can win the C7 Pawn but
uh your your own B5 Pawn might also be
falling pretty quickly here is taking
everything before it's played instantly
and F3 tries to take advantage of the
fact that Rook 98 is loose but you can
drive that pawn forward to E3 I'm going
to show you quickly if you take this
Pawn you'd lose the game on the spot
because that is a PIN to the king you
just lose all your material so Maxima
Shield Agra loses with white to Argent
ERA geisie this is a huge win that he's
about to get for the blitz I just don't
think there are any chances for nariana
here down on the clock down a couple
pawns on the board whoa but if we go to
the bird's eye view look what's
happening on the top board Danny this is
a look at that transition
dude we're suddenly in an end game where
only black can win I mean I know it
probably should be a draw or at least
the Evo Bar says hey don't freak out
this is this is roughly equal but really
only black can win a a two Rook versus
queen position here uh those pawns can
be picked off one by one Rook to C8 the
other Rook to C6 you win the C Pawn then
you can sort of do the same thing with
the a pawn so sometimes these positions
look like oh how can the queen be that
much worse two pieces can do things that
one piece can't even if that one piece
is a queen
the Rooks are going to slide up I think
that was an inaccuracy by grishek he
does not have much time H6 a little bit
sloppy he wants to get off the back rank
but he's allowing white activity that
was not deserved C5 now and you can't
line both of your Rooks up in a row that
was a mistake by Grisha I thought it was
still black to move in that position for
granted dude
he made that move 0.3 seconds look at
his clock he barely made that move in
time
now he raises his eyebrows this is why
Grisha gets the time pressure meme
everybody because of moments like this
he played with 0.5 on the clock
by the way he may just only end up with
a draw here I think H6 was a huge
mistake as you said not letting not
letting those pawns Advance was key for
black but the thing is it's easy for
gristook now because the pawns can't
move so his Rooks just stay put his King
can go up and this road can go back and
forth back and forth I was gonna say but
how does he win the pawns I was thinking
he had winning chances if he picked off
the pawns oh he oh he was winning I
agree with you I'm just saying that he
at least he's not going to lose the game
and he can look at Maxim's game this
game is the drill let's quickly go back
here H6 we understand you make Luft not
war create space for the king but if
instead he played Rook C6 there's no
background problem the queen comes up
yeah Rook slides over give me this Pawn
then we're gonna do the same thing on
the a file we're just gonna go Pawn
picking it may not be a Halloween but
bobbing for pawns is still a good thing
to do for black and you just win the
game no and this is exactly again
another instructive point for for fans
tuning in this isn't any game that you
can actually remember for your own game
sometimes you're like how do I evaluate
queen versus two Brooks this should show
you that these split pawns are just
sitting ducks there for the black Brooks
two pieces are better than one in
situations like this and imagine if the
ANC pawns are gone now you can free your
back rank the Rooks can double on the
second Rank and it's actually I don't
want to say clinical but pretty
straightforward for the Rooks to
dominate the queen in these types of end
games so again a huge missed opportunity
for grishek but at least he didn't lose
right that's big for the teams let's go
back and see what's happening in the
other boards maximum I mean he is just
winning his game right now in the top
right I think we can trust him for the
moment at least uh what's going on in
the other two Danny it looks like guha
for mgd1 if he wins that game the match
will be over in MGD one's favor yeah
that draw like rishik unfortunately that
missed opportunity with the two Rooks
may be what haunts the Blitz it's in the
end of the day because I I like that
position for guha let's go check out
that game obviously Boyer still has
chances it's double edged enough to say
it's not over the black king is open
you're already looking at moves like
Queen G6 check but Doug says not anymore
you are and stop it with Queen E4 but
now this queen is in line with the Rook
this rook's under attack over here if
Rook F3 maybe that works if you pin the
Knight but this bishop is also kind of
loose this is kind of anyone's game with
this queen sliding into the position the
E6 Pawn is also a Target yeah Boyer is a
really really the biggest problem he has
is I'm not on the board but on the clock
he is also threading moves like Knight
G2 now a discovery on the Queen the
Knight doubles up attacking The Rook on
F4
uh there's
okay a lot for Google to think about
this is probably the one we should stick
with by the way looks like cornette
should get the win as white against
savitha and as we said if MBL converts
the blitz's chances are still alive it's
all going to come down to whether Boyer
can make something magical happen here
against guha yes Maxine completely
winning and Diamante deolite also in the
driver's seat but look at Boyer you
can't even see his face it's all hair at
this point and the position is a bit
hairy because he is down a pawn but
Black's King is wide open this queen
went to the dark squares that's a light
Square Bishop The Rook is under attack
and guha is has a minute 20 seconds he's
just under a minute ahead on the clock
but his position is not easy White's
King is safer that's better in bullet
scrambles
yeah I mean and the closer they get to
being equal on the timer the more I like
Boyer's chances to help the blitz come
back here because I would argue it's
harder to play Black in a Time scramble
in this game we know how tricky Knights
can be Robert we talk about a lot Knight
tactics are missed the king is open for
black Here Comes Queen D6
this is awkward it's getting awkward by
the way wait
maximum one Oh I thought that was the uh
I thought that was the Savita game where
I saw the result I thought that black
came back and went okay no Maxine
Bossier the grave has won against
Narayanan uh and so uh the blitz still
have chances at this point but why is
Shook You Gotta Go in three seconds two
no no
no no no no no oh my gosh what's going
on you just lost on time no I don't see
no he he made the move with I guess he
had the move in time somehow oh my gosh
okay
that that is a moment where we were
fooled chess.com we can't afford that oh
my gosh we're about to move off
okay 2.8 he gets the he gets the move
off the increment added back to his
clock uh some uh some timer issues there
now there's a threat of Queen takes E6
check there's also awkward threats of
moving the knight from E3 at any moment
with a discovery on the queen you gotta
watch out this is a blunderable position
as we oh love that H3 Knight G4 oh my
God the way you highlight 94. here he
goes
oh my goodness maybe there's something
better apparently but Knight G4 you're
gonna have to give up an exchange
what was better by the way anyway okay
Knight G4 looks great
this is looking really good for the
blitz all of a sudden they have a chance
and by the way Gua down to five seconds
left he's gonna move yeah and cornet
Coronet by the way gonna win her game
okay so Queen D4 Here Comes Knight F6
check and you have to take it oh wait
Knight takes E8 Rook G3
are we seeing a drop takes G3 did he
allow oh my God professional he sucks
and he's got a draw and they're gonna
win
oh my gosh oh my God he bought her a
Perpetual check oh but with the draw
Danny it means we're gonna have a tied
matchup because the blitz they already
won one game and this is a four straw
here there's no escaping it just back
and forth that's right okay I'm sorry
for some reason I thought the draw took
it but no it's only eight and all
Coronet has to do is get the dub and the
blitz are moving to tie breaks yes and
all she needs to do is get the dump
she's up how many pawns right here four
extra pawns for Demonte make that five
extra pawns I can't count that high and
about to be six resonation happened
Danny eight eight we have tie breaks
have tie breaks I love when moments like
this happen so that the fans aren't like
oh you guys are always just saying
there's a chance because it's your job
we said there was still a chance the
blitz had to go 3-1 in the last round to
pull it off and they did it
without without grishek getting a win
over irugaisy they managed to complete
the comeback and we are moving to
overtime chess the most exciting event
since sudden death dodgeball well we're
not watching the cobras but we are
seeing exciting stuff patches of
Houlihan would be enthused by this
matchup it is eight to eight we are
going to tie breaks Danny look at the
bottom two boards one and a half half in
favor of the blitz same as the top two
but De Monte dilute cornet she comes
through huge when the team needed her
most
she absolutely did she was Owen three
but she won when it mattered Robert
she's uh
she's helping her team move to overtime
chess and I wanted to highlight just
something hilarious as I was looking at
each one of those scores my brain was
was replaying what happened on the board
and if karishuk wins that game
the blitz are actually winning the match
with a three and a half comeback and
they were this close to doing the
absolutely improbable not coming back to
tie it but actually coming back to win
it so okay it didn't happen we're headed
to tie Breakers let's talk about what
the tiebreaker rules are Robert uh for
those who haven't seen themselves a
protest the type breaker match yet this
season uh this is the format round four
pairings happen once again but we swap
colors while moving to a faster time
control it's first to two and a half
points obviously two and a half points
is a best of four score that will win
you the day uh if we are still tied
we're gonna rinse and repeat this thing
to an even faster time control with the
Players Once Again swapping colors
Robert did I nail that anything you want
to add about this tiebreaker format
before we get carried away free chess
that's the only thing I would add that
we get overtime we are thrilled about
that and when this match concludes the
chest does not stop we will have Hikaru
Nakamura and the Gotham Knight playing
in the second half of the double header
so the chess will continue you today
even though this match still has tie
breaks to come
I believe we're going to take a quick
break before we head to tie breaks I
think that's the plan
um I'm uh it's my you know hey it's my
first protest League show this year so
um you know don't hold it against Dan
over here but all right we're gonna
we're gonna take a very quick break when
we come back it is tiebreaker chess as
Robert said just a reporter Hikaru
Nakamura uh making his debut for the
Gotham Knight so much underway still
ahead in this day don't go anywhere the
protest League returns in just a few
minutes
I remember people saying snow you got a
sandbag keep your rating low go play in
the World open and win six thousand
dollars you know just just don't don't
keep your rating up and I'd be like what
are you talking about I'm trying to
become a GM that's ridiculous so that
mentality was something I had to
escape this was not the black bear
School mentality but the park ecosystem
it for me was Prospect Park in Brooklyn
definitely Foster this idea because you
a little bit of awesome mentality that
you keep your rating low and you try to
win some money
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
mm-hmm
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
ladies and gentlemen it happened you
thought we were just hyping it up you
blamed us of being over dramatic you've
done it before and you've been wrong
before chat Blitz complete a 3-1
comeback in the last round to send us to
OT Robert
yeah it was an epic comeback and in fact
the blitz looked like they were about to
steal this match Victory away from team
mgd1 but it's an 8-8 tie we get tie
breaks and if you look at the rosters
our generic icy in a Blitz game do you
trust him he's a superstar well he's
facing off a world Blitz champion and
Alexander grishop a three-time I was
gonna say like as as crazy as it is to
pick against irigaisi I actually feel
like he was more a favorite in the last
game not just because he had the white
pieces but because the momentum was
favoring him the rapid time control was
just he was in a zone right zone two
when you're just you're feeling the flow
of life now the gloves are off right
grishek gets another chance he gets the
white pieces the blitz time control we
know how great he is at three plus two
that's the time control where he won
three of those World list titles by the
way that Robert just said and Maxine
vashi the grav also gets white so I
asked Chad I don't know if we actually
did a poll or not if not maybe we can
who do you think is gonna who do you
think is gonna come back here I mean at
this point momentum greatly favoring the
Blitz
it certainly is and you know we've
talked about how the bottom boards
they're equally important as those
Superstars super Grand Masters at the
top I feel like the blitz yeah they have
the upper hand right now you think about
what just happened these is a rematch of
round four what happened in round four
the blitz one three to one so those
opponents are probably looking like oh
uh if you're an mgd1 player I need to
right the ship somehow even though it
was an excellent first three the last
one that sticks in your mind yep recency
bias is a real thing momentum is a real
thing if you're just getting here where
have you been we see akaranakamura just
went online he'll be playing chess here
in the Pro chess League probably
starting in about a half an hour but
right now we have Blitz we have tie
breaks and uh we're gonna have awesome
chess all right we talked a little bit
about the fact grishek and MBL now they
get the white pieces against boards one
and two uh from MGD one respectively but
Gua gets the white pieces right
for uh for mgd1 that's critical Savita
gets the white pieces right so it's it's
gonna be a uh an interesting shift here
to see to see what what fortune that
changes I just I have a feeling that
given the momentum favoring the Blitz
that I I would be worried right now if
I'm MGD one fans
okay well we have liftoff we have the
game underway our generic guys see what
the black piece is taking on Alexander
grishuk and well this looks a very calm
start to this game no Pawn tension just
yet Danny I was gonna say the big
question is why play C4 already says no
I'll go first I'll play C5 yeah it's uh
a an awkward I guess it was another kind
of Tory uh system but um the early 94
for black
gets us a really tricky Affair now black
has the two Central pawns potentially
the E and D pawns it's like a Queen's
Gambit reversed almost uh but white
immediately playing C4 and uh tactics
will be on the board early and often in
this one
the bishop on H4 is such a thorn in
Black side you can't push the E Pawn and
develop your dark Square Bishop because
the bishop pins that pawn to the queen
and we just sing a lot of night moves
for black the night with F6 E4 back to
take upon C5 this Knight went up to C6
and over to E5 and the eval bar likes
white like quite a large margin because
White's ahead in development there was a
check on D3 here have the bishop here I
just want to show something very quickly
you can blunder oh check yes
I love it when you shall think I was
like I was I was getting excited I saw
it and I knew you were gonna show it
um it had to it's not out of the
question look at this move Brook C1
gains a Tempo because the Knight on C5
is loose maybe bishop takes F7 check is
in the air right discovered attacks so
you gotta watch out for that and you
can't force your way out of this because
as you just pointed out obvious captures
actually improve White's position and
bring that Knight on D2 into the game so
I
this is tough and again it's it's uh
irigaisy having to hold on is B4 coming
next
uh B4 I think that's definitely
available for white and what other moves
come to mind uh
I mean I like he played it I was trying
to call it another
yeah why not kick the Knight where is it
going actually
it's it's unclear where that Knight has
has safety E6 I would maybe even just
take twice and double the pawns A6 I'm
guessing I'll play like Queen to B3 or
something and and kind of continue to
just develop aggressively begging black
to take my Bishop on C4 so that my
knight on D2 can recapture and I've got
that nice thread on D6
shh my goodness if that happens and
white wins a queen that would be
devastating for uh black here and I I
kind of forgot that Alexander grishek
had the white pieces in this game I'm
looking at the dynamic chess I'm like oh
Arjun he's got white here he's playing
excellently but oh it's all Grisha sorry
look at this knife is it trapped in
there like if you take it the second
night replace it like it's almost
trapped
yeah but it's actually kind of a funny
move obviously white must have something
the engine uh really loving white and
based on the eval bar but
I didn't easily see a move for white the
point is Robert to show like if the Rook
moves off of C1 then the the C4 Bishop
is hanging right if you take D3 the
Knight is forking The Rook on C1 and the
pawn on B4 right now so it's whatever it
is for white grishek has to find it
because it's not super obvious it just
takes C8 and queen B3 maybe and that
Knight is going too far
I think that looks great just straight
okay get after this Knight then I has to
go back Black's down like five Tempe and
while this is happening we do have
liftoff in another game the patches are
staggered given the blitz time Patrol
but Maxine for Schiller grop and Esso
norianen they're off
another uh Lopez it looks like for MBL
as white unless it was an Italian uh
awkward move order but I think I'm right
that it was a Lopez white establishes
the Knight on D5
um a roughly equal position Maxime did
lose with the white pieces when he
played the Spanish against irigaisi but
I I don't think uh I don't think
Narayanan has the has the same level of
prep the Euro guys he does all right
we've got the Grisha game back here
we're working on getting the uh the the
other game up between mvl and Ariana but
all right grishek on the clock takes D3
but do you see that he went Knight C4
giving up his Rook because the knightsey
won those nights available winning the
queen and so instead he takes this here
because if white takes is Knight B2 with
a fork so both sides are very Vigilant
of the tactics here and that's why white
just takes and now we see a position
where white is likely winning a pawn
because black can't even Castle as E7 is
threatened twice
yeah and we like rishik's physician a
lot uh attacking B7 attacking E7
this is this is looking tough by the way
Eric icy about to go under a minute on
the clock to go with it so all right
we'll quickly come back and try to catch
the ending of this can we can we check
over on the MBL Narayanan game even
though we will want to keep our eye on
this one because it did start first and
will likely reach its conclusion versus
well here's our bird's eye view we see
that the guha Boyer battle is also no
underway
but let's uh
let's quickly check on Maxine Bossier
The Groves battle versus narayana uh and
uh
and see what's going on in that board
okay here we have it we see that this
Knight on D4 Pawn on D5 why has good
control here yeah there's also a thread
of Bishop takes H6 the last one we'll
play with Queen F3 trying to go for this
kind of tactical sequence uh but now
black has doubled an isolated white
spawns Danny I like the open C file I
like the bishop hair there's a tactic
ambition takes H6 that's why the Knight
came back to Siege yeah he has like
black going in the wrong direction it's
interesting to see the centralized
doubled pawns being such an issue for
black they actually hold the the knights
at Bay right uh the the the whips are
are keeping the Lions back very
irritating to maneuver your Knights when
all your central squares are denied by
those uh ugly d-pods here comes the
bishop maybe to C6 at some point the A6
Pawn is weak for Black by the way
um and uh and again I love your I love
your uh tactical eye that Bishop takes
H6 is always on the agenda over there
you have to watch out for King side
blenders
yeah the queen needs to stay put
different black just is passive here and
look at Maxine Bashar legrov's clock he
is ahead on time he is the former World
Blitz Champion oh gosh taking over
another file that Bishop will sync his
teeth into C6 A6 is weak I really don't
like this position for black and again
the world Blitz Champions the Roblox
Champions are getting it done I know we
just checked on this but we staggered
the games for a reason so let's go back
to the bird's eye view because karishuk
his game with our Junior geisey started
first and Robert The Rook just entered
the seventh rank bro this is not looking
good for iRig icy and uh Kevin bordee
kind of the manager captain of this of
this blitz team looking like a genius
right now he picked a couple of guys
Robert who who would be able to get the
job done in Blitz tiebreakers with these
two world Bliss champions and how many
pawns is white out it's supposed to be
three pawns to the good after Queen
takes D4 so Arjun era geisie
unfortunately for team MGD won it he
could just resign here there is no hope
in his position he can't resign this is
a team event you don't want to let your
teammates down and see them uh facing a
deficit but any sort of queen move
should be enough to keep the win the
bishop on G3 makes sure the king is
always safe to run H2 wow what a game by
Chris shook yeah this is clinical this
is where grishek is at his best here
comes the b-pawn uh A4 and A5 my okay
this is the right idea if you're if
you're looking for any sort of practical
chance hurry and make something spicy
happen on the king side but accurate
play is going to get the job done here
um he's also up on the clock that being
grishek which you know kind of rare for
those words to come out of my mouth Rook
did trades everything by the way because
if you play Queen A1 check the queen can
come back to F1 and trade off Queens but
zero percent scared he realized his
Queen can always slide back to defend a
first ranked check and all right the
pawn to stop for now Rook d8 does trade
off pieces if you want them off the
board and likely picked up the G4 plus
oh Queen B3 what a move double attacking
the queen trade in F7 Kuwait he's
yelling
foreign
I don't know he he just got nervous I
don't know he was yelling maybe he was
yelling at his kids go to sleep Daddy's
working
and he is working it right now but don't
get a three-time repetition I was gonna
say one more time is not good Bishop
comes back to G3 what a move it
threatens B7 because the bishop was
hanging on C7 and here comes the a pawn
yeah The Little Engine That Could he
can't stop them both A5 you take there
goes the pawn to B7 yep you can only
deal with one at a time arjune doing his
best again you got to give him credit oh
and after uh the bishop moves the queen
will reprotect The Rook on D1 okay so
this is just a throwaway move
and shouldn't be enough
falls to the three-time world Blitz
Champion that's why you bring guys like
this onto your team now he's gonna go
take care of the kids I'm telling you he
was yelling at his kids I I know you
think I'm making that up but one dad to
another that's exactly who he was
yelling at
um and he's might not be yelling at
Maxine lagrov who got a draw in that
game and he's certainly not yelling at
his board three uh Mahal Boyer because
look it down yeah look at Boyer Chef
Boyardee let's go right into that game
because he is cooking up an attack right
now he just stole a Pawn on G2 black is
actually down a piece at the moment
count the miners black only has three
white has four but Bishop F4 is coming
in I don't know where this King expects
to go uh Bishop Ford doesn't that just
it's just nasty Bishop before is
those uh those SpaghettiOs are spelling
out Victory right now for the blitz man
Chef Boyardee gets some and uh by the
way I used to love spelling out words
with my with my um
oh wait okay where is it give me give me
some kind of discover check give me
something nasty Bishops
Queen C3 probably the only try here
by the way
oh my gosh there's a calm move F6
shutting down the diagonal we've talked
about this earlier in the day and Boyer
he has it going on right now this King
if you take on G2 the bishop takes and
once the king takes the second minor
piece down goes E2 down goes C1 and all
of White's pieces are hanging by the way
the immediate threat is Knight H4 check
with the discovery because when the King
goes to E1 the bishop is pinned Knight
takes F3 wins on the spot and if the
King goes to F2 of course as you
highlighted Queen E3 check is
devastating OMGs or snaps the blitz if
you're just tuning in Where Have You
Been they were down seven to five
heading into the last round they pulled
off a 3-1 score to send us into overtime
and they are about to get the job done
if Boyer wins it's over the blitz have
won in overtime chess
Queen B4 play that's escaping some
checks there it is pointed out 984. it's
over queen queen E3 we need three check
and Knight takes F3 and the blitz are
going to win in comeback Style
this is why the protest league is played
right here
what a crazy victory
and I can only imagine what Kevin bordie
is doing we saw young Hammer's reaction
yesterday board is probably next level
if I spoke French and I wasn't busy
doing commentary I'm going to check he's
got his arm around Fabian go to
twitch.tv slash blitzstream right now
they are having a party in France
I love the French faithful by the way I
hate the opening love the love the chat
hey Alexander grushrock use it to
Perfection okay
our generic I see and I played for the
French team and that's it if the blitz
have one you see a little fist pump from
Boyer he's the hero he's the hero they
needed even if he's not the one they
deserve Danny and Donya called it as
Chad says he said watch out for Boyer he
didn't start out well he comes back
they're spamming Boyer faces in the
twitch.tv blitzstream chat right now and
uh they are pumped this young man is
gonna help them get to a victory and uh
shout out and congratulations to the
blitz on this comeback day
it's kind of sad that these players I
mean they have to keep going in this one
they don't know what happened perhaps
it's hard to look at other games where
you're still in the midst of your own
look at this King on H1 King on h8 this
Knight coming into F4 the G2 Pawn But
ultimately this result is meaningless
and that's the sad news for Savita Shri
I mean she is most playing a nice game
here but it doesn't matter her result
it's not going to change the match score
not a meaningless result in the sense
that Demonte do lead cornet you know she
will be playing again for the blitz she
didn't start out well today but she won
her last game against Savita and if she
wins The Blitz
he's not going to win the Blitz game
anymore wait what's going on
okay it's a confidence Builder that's
what I was trying to say but it looks
like it's not going to be a confidence
Builder if if it goes this way oh oh go
back there's a cool moment here I can't
go back fast enough can we take C1 and
sacrifice your queen to win the other
Queen oh my gosh
I love when you struggle with the mouse
it's just it just it warms my heart when
you're freaking out yeah but there was a
temporary Queen sack to win an exchange
there and now she's just losing all her
pawns and this is Savita shree's game so
the blitz are gonna take the match
Savita Street she's going to take this
final game here I just trade off all the
pieces but I think she just found out
her team's result I think uh
her her emotional reaction did not match
the chess on the board which means to me
I think she probably just found out that
her team has already lost she's gonna
get the Dub here in fact it's Checkmate
on the board but she already shook her
head
frustrated with how this one ended you
gotta feel the pain for mgd1 they were
dominating this match for most of the
day and again if you're just tuning in I
already said it
they were up seven to five but the blitz
come back and now have gotten the job
done in tie breaks Robert
yes and we just saw Savita Shri win
board four for the team mgd1 and just a
little bit too little because the top
three boards for the blitz they
dominated mahel Boyer the hero Donya
naroditski he is the prophet for a
reason he called it out he said that
would be the underrated player uh in
this matchup and he takes out my
underrated player in mitrabba
yeah it's so exciting I mean this was
this was incredible and there were so
many moments in the last set of Rapid
games where you just it was moments away
you thought from MGD when wrapping it up
but no
the blitz complete the comeback and
Alexander grishek the world Bliss
Champion he gets the job done in Blitz
with the white pieces over Arjun
irigaisi
um again I I have so many great memories
recently of uruguisi especially in his
rapid chess he's a rising star but I
have some memories of the blitz chest
not going his way the SEC battle versus
fabula card one and this game here
versus grishek I'm saying it out loud to
say that I think that I think that
irigai sees Blitz maybe that's where you
want to get this guy because you can't
seem to beat him in Rapid get him in
Blitz Maybe
yeah because speeches Championship that
matchup Was Won by five undercarwana he
did win the junior speeches Championship
ahead of him yes but Alexander grishop
former world champion three-time
worldwide champion and when it came down
to the wire he was dominant from start
to finish of that tiebreak game The
Blitz they deserved it in the tie break
the momentum was on their side as you
were forecasting so a good win for Kevin
boardy and his team
ten and a half nine and a half it took
overtime chess to get there will we have
overtime chess in the next match is the
question let's preview it right up
because here we go the Berlin Bears
stepping in to take on the Gotham
Knights if you miss the memo this is a
team started and founded by the uh the
manager Captain Levy Rosman Gotham chess
the biggest chess YouTuber and on his
team as fate would have it it was meant
to be the biggest chess streamer on
Twitch Chicago Nakamura he'll be trying
to lead the Gotham Knights to their
first Victory but the Berlin Bears uh
will have more than a thing or two to
say about that so Robert uh before we
head to a break your quick preview on
what the people should be buckled up for
click right always safety first as we
head to this next match
well there will be turbulence so you
should buckle up because the Berlin
Bears they may not have the highest
rated players on the planet but they are
people who can punch up and they will
need to because they Karu Nakamura is
board one Gotham Knights Levy and a car
would team up once more we'll see if the
Bears will bring the bite and not just
the scary posturing they will need to
bring their best to take down the Gotham
Knights I can't wait to see what we have
next we've already had overtime chess
today don't go anywhere everybody it's
our second matchup when we return in
just a few
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
League continues here as we move to our
second matchup of the day if you've been
with us for the whole show thank you if
you're just joining don't worry so much
great chess ahead alongside me Grand
Master Robert Hess I'm not going to
recap the amazing things we've already
seen I'm going to move forward and talk
about what's what's coming up but before
we do Robert let me remind everybody we
reset the table we all take a breath
before the the amazing second course
meal begins and let's talk about what
the format is for the pro Chesley you
know it you love it it's an all play all
deal with a Time control of ten plus two
which puts us right into the action it
is fast it is furious it is fun it's the
first team to reach eight and a half
points that's what gets you the dub if
we are tied we will go to a replay of
round four tiebreaker of course with the
colors being switched Robert sorry for
dominating the top of the show here as
we preview Berlin Bears versus Gotham
Knights I'm going to now throw it to you
let you talk about the match-ups that we
are about to see in this second match
well years were dominating and I see a
player on the lineup Hikaru Nakamura he
dominated title Tuesday yesterday he won
both of those he dominates pretty much
every tournament he plays in made to the
finals of the air things Masters and
champions chest story yeah on Magnus
Carlson Magnus won that one Hikaru
Nakamura you see him you have to say his
name but what I've talked about Danny
the Berlin Bears they are a tough Squad
they have brothers the brothers funny in
their lineup and they're full of these
2600s who can't punch up Rasmus has been
on chess.com for so many years he's
played in the German Olympia team they
have some great players in that lineup
Rasmus or Frederick who got the better
deal of the name Lottery between the
parents we're gonna we're gonna unpack
that later in the show it is a family
affair there I'm just kidding uh Rasmus
Fedrick okay great name uh but you
mentioned nicaro you didn't mention the
other guy who's a world Bliss Champion
Liam lay we just saw two World Blitz
Champions help the blitz make a comeback
Victory against mgd1 of course in
grishek and MBL watch out for lamlay to
also be a star for this Gotham Knights
team maybe not just today but for their
entire season so I'm super pumped to see
what's about to go down here now let's
talk about the pairings uh those are the
lineups those are the players for each
team as you see them but who plays who
first the way this thing works is we
kind of go in reverse order we start
with board ones taking on the board
fours for each respective team Robert of
those matchups Circle the one for me
maybe it's a board two or a board three
battle that maybe has the most potential
for an upset Dimitri kolars Andy
Woodward Andy Woodward is board three
for the Gotham Knights but that's a 12
year old Superstar he's an international
Master his rating is nearing Grandmaster
territory he gave Hikaru Nakamura all he
could handle in the Fisher random world
champion qualifiers that was a close one
Hikaru ended up becoming the world
champion in the Fisher random variant
but he didn't even he barely made it in
honestly because that was a tough
matchup so Andy Woodward that's the name
to watch he's just 12 years old I love
how confident and ready you were for
that Andy Woodward the junior rising
star in the U.S but he is playing
Dimitri kolars let's never let's not
forget Dimitri was a hero for the bottom
bottom snowballs when they actually went
all the way to the live finals in San
Francisco in 2019 so he is an
experienced Pro Chesley Grandmaster so
all right it's time to go to the games
the uh the action is about to kick off
we've got Natalia buxa versus Rasmus
Fawn spawn a tell me how to pronounce
the last name so I just don't let's just
I'm just gonna acknowledge and just
you're just gonna tell me in front of
everyone how do I pronounce their last
name
just don't
just you know you're so Sven you
probably think this song is about you
you're so Spain wow I was not expecting
that reference right here but I'm proud
of you I have to say I'm very proud of
you okay anyway
um Rasmus is as you said one of the one
of the maybe better Blitz players on the
site that you haven't you haven't heard
of household names like Hikaru Nakamura
of course are at the top of that list
but uh svane I'm gonna go with your
pronunciation a great player taking on
the board four for the Gotham Knights
can Natalia buxa pull off an upset we're
gonna find out
in Natalia books are she's a Mainstay of
Ukrainian women's team they won the gold
medal in the Olympiad in Chennai and
here with the white piece is a very
solid start we have an Italian game uh
we have a quiet variation set upon going
up to C3 she brings her night out and I
think that's a good decision against a
higher rated player just played a solid
opening force him to take the risks yeah
by the way we gave love where where love
was due to the blitz who had jerseys MBL
was sporting it proudly ultimately that
team spirit maybe help them in a
comeback Victory look at the Berlin
Bears that's a nice looking hoodie I
could look good in a hoodie like that
I'm gonna I'm gonna give a shout out to
the Berlin Bears I would wear it if she
sent it to me looks comfy it's cold
outside where I live yeah I kind of want
one truly like they have a great logo
yeah they also have great team chemistry
they have brothers on their squad so you
know that these players are working
together and right now you know Erasmus
it's the opening stage he played A6 as
Bishop often drops like the A7 but it
usually does that when there's a Pawn on
C3 so I'm wondering what the Dynamics of
this position are what's unique about it
and Natalia she brings her Bishop out if
H6 Danny she's going to play Bishop H4
and allow G5 she answers no she takes it
was yeah this is interesting stuff this
is it was looking you know some of these
four nights are funny because obviously
at this level these players are very
well prepared there's advanced stuff
going on in their head but it's also a
position it's very beginner friendly
right everyone's developed their pieces
they're fighting for control over the
center there's not really a lot about
this position uh that uh that's hard to
follow and I love this move C3 white is
flexibly preparing both B4 potentially a
B4 A4 Advance as well as maybe a strike
in D4 uh depending on what Rasmus does
here
yeah white just is first of the action
we have a very strong Knight on D5 uh
the pawn on C3 it takes away the four
jumps from this Knight on C6 this is all
good news but black is extremely solid
and has the bishop pair at some point
this bishop May slide back to A7 and for
the long term the bishop is going to
cause white problems as it slices across
the board so with our second game
getting underway as well I think that
this is just a very level start I think
both sides you know have not shown what
their intentions are
a greetown population us it's also time
for us to head over to the bird's eye
view as our third game gets underway
remember if you're just watching for the
first time the games are staggered a
little bit by design that allows us to
give every game some love at the start
and potentially if we're lucky catch the
finishing moments of every game of
course it is chess and we're not always
in control of that but looking at board
two uh Dimitri kolars versus Andy
Woodward that's a fun one with a couple
of Pawns dancing in the center and then
you have the others fun the other is
funny the other the other Von sorry I'm
just I gotta get away from this name
thing it's gonna it's gonna kill us
today
um you know Frederick taking on lamb lay
down there in the left corner where
where to Robert take us to Andy Woodward
for Dimitri College just because the uh
Fredericks funny
position is a bit more close and this
one is opening up we just saw black a
moment ago take on D4 and then play E5
so Dimitri kolars he is extending his
Pawns in the center pretending we know
what happens sometimes you push your
pawns too far you leave squares behind a
cold doors here he's giving up the
bishop because he's claiming that his
spatial Advantage with these two pawns
is more than enough to offset this great
Bishop on G2
yeah agreed and uh and I'm excited to
see what that Bishop can do in the long
diagonal I'm also excited to see a
bookshelf I can get behind right now
there's an organized bookshelf
um also looks like I mean he is 12 so I
think some of those books I'm familiar
with uh I have an 11 year old so you
know the library is full of Chess books
Robert and maybe some uh some good some
good family fiction
well it's good to be a reader I've
always enjoyed myself a good book not so
much chess books but I was exposed on
the Champions chest door coverage David
Howell called me out on any because I
told you in confidence that I didn't
read many chess books and by the way we
need to go back to our bird's eye view
it looks like a certain has not read
many chess books but he is a superstar
we usually trust him so Hikaru Nakamura
he's taking on Josephine heinemann and
look at this opening Danny the F Pawn is
missing literally I literally was gonna
ask like what happened to the F1 like it
you know Hikaru does like himself a
Dutch right those for uh D4 F5 from time
to time and and maybe Hikaru was was
into throwing off his opponent Josephine
behind him on today with pieces but um
but objectively if you look at that
board in the lower right corner
everybody it's a decent position for
white you've you've got the open e-file
for The Rook coming the light squares
are potentially weak even if it it into
Carl Nakamura playing Black so uh
whether whether it was planned or not in
terms of prep I don't dislike
Josephine's position at this point
move two that is just uh you're asking
for trouble but Hikaru says hey I'm the
best in online chess right now and I'm
just going to try to kind of shore up
these weak light squares and Danny I
mean this is a very risky decision we
see that white objectively is better I
think it's fairly obvious maybe C4 try
to push D5 at some point you can just
play Knight C3 for the same purpose and
slide this Knight into D4 ah but I don't
know about this I just feel like it sets
the tenor for this game where she is
going to be playing solidly because
she's afraid of akara's Might
I tend to agree and I don't ever like
that not just because everyone knows I'm
an aggressive player looking to mix it
up but it's just usually not the right
mindset right you want to play
principled but aggressive chess against
your higher rated opponent and challenge
them and and having been in those shoes
uh rarely Robert I am a higher rated
player a rarely but having so having
been in those shoes I will say no one
likes that right no one likes when you
sit down and a young Master is coming
after you and you're like whoa big fella
right you don't want to play against
that so I I tend to agree that I think
an aggressive approach is what you need
everyone of course knows that the format
we have we have managers we have
captains we have teams uh and every once
in a while you have a player who also
will want to stream their own point of
view it is legal uh as long as there is
a stream delay and they abide by all
other fair play rules so you can watch
Hikaru stream if you want but it will be
on delay because there is a a
restriction to ensure that uh we're
avoiding any Tome fully any second
gunman on the grassy knoll if you will
uh to assist which is why our games are
on a private server and why they're hard
to find so I had to say that to some
fans of the day they're hard to find on
chess.com by Design you should stick
here with me and Robert and watch the
show so there you go for sure and there
is a show indeed because an open f file
if the black king decides the castle
kingside or very likely the queen side
Kingston obsides the board who's King is
safer
not a big fan of the King on G1 E4 is
coming that will open up the bishop open
up attacking chances all across the
board I really like your car position
despite the fact that he put F5 on move
two if you give me a great gift I will
get you a Euro we could go for a nice
Euro after this with some falafel
oh man when you said a Euro I thought
you were giving me money but you haven't
paid me for shows and like like it's
been like seven years we don't talk
about that okay all right well I agree
with you Robert seems to have right not
Robert Hikaru seems to have righted the
ship I tend to agree that a C4 D5
Dynamic by Josephine earlier was the way
to maybe cramp uh the light squares
cramp It Horror style that didn't happen
um and now I'm liking hikaru's chances
more and more so
um
okay
Hikaru looking up also got his got his
chest his chest uh dress on today nice
shirt he's wearing there
um he's just cruising Danny like
everything is working out for him he
plays E4 kicks the night away once the
night moves the queen comes to E5 lines
up for checkmate you're gonna have to
play G3 but then all of your king side
squares are compromised and black can
always slide a rook to defend this pawn
it feels like black is at the five free
turns yeah I agree like what happened to
developing the queen side and now you're
wondering if there's a concrete tactic
Hikaru puts the Knight on E5 the D3
squares calling his name there's you
know what I want here I want to play H5
Robert and then just put a knight on G4
that's what I want to do I just want to
like literally brute force my way
through the king side
why not it's the fishing pole method but
this Knight is going to D3 you wish ah
the Palm doesn't move backwards but you
need the pawn to cover the square the
Knight jumps in F2 is a target this is
going to be uh on the docket with Bishop
takes H2 but Knight D3 is automatic and
then this Knight you come to D5 we might
see a knight go to F4 at some moment you
can't even get away with a queen trade
I'm just gonna show this that if you try
to go like Queen G4 over here you're
gonna lose the B2 pawn and you might
just lose everything because in a
situation like this I'll gladly trade
off all the pieces and take that pawn
over here
um Black's just completely winning
yeah and the position unravels super
super quickly so hikaru's kind of uh
slightly dubious opening Gambit paying
off by the way here comes my H5 you know
I want it put the Knight on G4 Hikaru or
go home oh wait you're already home come
on man
um but uh but no if you're just tuning
in hit cover play D6 and then F5 on move
two that is not uh something you should
try at home kids
um but uh it has led to a pretty good
position and now what now the eval is
announcing victories
oh I mean yeah you could probably have
just snapped off this Knight and created
a bad Pawn structure but you could tell
a car just wants to crush down the king
side there's not even a knight B5 move
because the queen covers the square so
yeah any four jumps that white may have
in mind across Knight C4 don't look too
threatening especially with some kind of
take on H2 G4 and all that this is
really really bad for Josephine here at
Danny and you know she she played a
little bit too timidly out of the
opening yep and it's tough right
everyone everyone who's played Hikaru
has been there his reputation precedes
him but okay let's move back to our
bird's eye view and check in on the one
board that we haven't looked at at all
and that is the game between the other
svane uh and I don't mean that in any
way against Frederick Erasmus is I think
just the slightly more well-known player
that's the truth Frederick's funny
playing board three for the Berlin Bears
is taking on layham lay the world Blitz
Champion for the Gotham Knights it's
funny because we say that again this is
not disparaging Hikaru in any way
everyone knows what a monster he is but
he's actually never won a worldless
championship title one of the few
accomplishments that has evaded him
whereas Liam lay has and it just makes
them even more of a one-two dynamic
punch to lead the Gotham Knights this
year I am not I am not excited to play
this team if I'm anybody else
no you're not and this position is
actually quite exciting because the last
couple moves let's go back in time the
move G4 was played by Frederick Bishop
takes C3 probably an unexpected shot
from the German player's perspective
because after Pawn takes Knight takes
you have two pawns for your sacrifice
bishop and you're forking the queen and
the Rook so once this queen slides
somewhere the rook and D won't be
captured that means it's going to be a
rook and two pawns for two minor pieces
if we do a quick account do some math
there two amount of pieces six points
rook and two pawns is seven plus
weaknesses abound in White's position uh
the D3 and A4 Pawns
I love that you said Bishop takes C3 was
kind of a surprise and it is true right
sometimes psychologically you don't
expect the bishop to capture on that
square but here we see that Liam lay has
uh has seen the future and it and it's
one where he's up a pawn with some
interest black is uh
black actually wait now he's up the
exchange
um no it's two miners for the exchange
um and I am blacking out because but
sorry I have some I have some
information coming my way we may or may
not have a special guest joining me
those who who will see what's in store
for them in a minute will no longer
blame me for uh for my uh my slip there
so
yeah no I see where your mistake came
from it is a rook and two pawns for two
minor pieces but I get why you're
excited Danny I was excited because I
was getting messages from the producer
and not every day you have Levy Rosman
join you that's Gotham chess for those
who don't speak YouTube good hey Levy
how you doing man
hey hey sorry it's uh it's tough because
there's uh so many cameras and there's
uh there's a lot of scenes right now so
I didn't know when I was gonna get up on
screen you guys are doing a great job uh
loving it so far
thank you sir are you coming are you
commenting on your own Channel right now
are we also live on your Channel
yeah they don't see you but they can
hear you yes okay
that's the best possible outcome for
them that's the best possible
well I was asking permission uh first
before I would say hi Gotham chess fans
and hope you guys are excited for the
season of the Gotham Knights Levy I'm
gonna ask you questions like I don't
know you very well because it's more fun
to pretend and tell me what what it was
that made you want to be a manager of a
protest League team and also give me
give the fans whatever behind the scenes
you can reveal about what it took to
recruit Hikaru to play for you
yeah the recruitment uh for Hikaru was
crazy like you know remember uh Lebron
James and uh and and the whole Miami
thing the first time around like I
wouldn't I wouldn't go that far but
listen man it took a lot of
conversations I mean it kind of started
with hey you want to join the team and
he said yeah
oh okay wow
yeah no that I don't know I I thought it
was going to be very tough but uh then
he uh that he was like yeah I'm in
because he played for New York before
and
um the toughest part after that though
was figuring out what kind of a lineup
we wanted because you know there's like
these different rules and ratings and um
we we didn't know if we wanted to go for
like triple stack death lineup and then
uh yeah then we saw that the Chas Bros
Got Magnus and it basically became an
arms race so we actually we like we went
to the the the the the mountains of
Kazakhstan to recruit like a board four
like uh a borderline flying into the
country and like going like to sit down
and recruit so we have a really strong
young board four we have like uh very
quickly Rising Talent from Bulgaria uh
Nuru salimova for board four so I mean
it's been a lot of fun like it's and
these matchups have been super close
well except one of us which ended in
round three but yeah it's been a lot of
fun
well Levy did you have any scouts
because of course you know most of the
top players but when you're looking for
an up-and-comer or a board four you know
you're talking about across the world so
did you have people help you compose the
lineup or was it just all your choice no
no no listen I uh no I I I would I would
love to sit here and say it was all me
um but uh a really really uh big amount
if not like all of the conversations for
recruitment directly with the players
themselves uh where Robert I'm sure you
know Alex ostrovsky International Master
best chess coach uh in the Western
Hemisphere I think that's where New York
is in the United States if not then I'm
sorry Northern Hemisphere so listen I'm
a chess player I don't do geography
um yeah but no he uh because he has a
lot of students who like play uh
competitive events so he knows a lot of
talented Juniors all over the world and
uh
he uh yeah I mean he he he's like very
good at strategizing he's very good at
like double checking all the details for
the rating lists and the calculations so
I was going back and forth with him a
lot uh but he's like the brains behind
our roster so and available for chess
lessons alexchess.com so there you go
Danny sorry can we just look at his cars
game because something's going very
wrong I I was I was just gonna say the
same thing that before we asked Libby to
talk about the chest let's switch to the
chess board that is uh
is is going very very strangely Hikaru
blundered against Josephine heinemann
but we don't know where
okay it looks dominating dominating F6
just just Rover queen of six
you wanted mate but he walked right into
Bishop
I mean
I'm gonna assume he did that on purpose
but he must have missed some sort of
follow-up
right like yeah he must think he's just
continuing the E4 Pawn
the queen of the E4 Pawn is the key
right when the queen comes to E4 if you
show Robert that guards the H4 Square
preventing Queen H4 for black so the
exchange sack isn't just a uh isn't just
a way to win and obviously we know
Hikaru is is gonna get the job done for
you this year Levy but obviously this is
a position that has kind of gotten away
from the man but let's see what kind of
chances does he have actually C4 is
coming what is going on here this is not
looking great at all and maybe this is
what he missed the Knight just comes
back to F1 and stops the mate yeah yeah
all right you might you guys might be
ahead of me I I have the events Page
open so I I don't know
yeah so if you look at the yeah yeah the
the uh okay well we apologize for that
and again that is by Design everybody
for for fair play reasons but
um Hikaru in a in a bit of trouble here
and in in live fashion kind of shaking
his head a little bit so this would be
talk about a crazy turnaround and a
shocker as we we left this one what we
thought was for good
um
sorry guys I I totally forgot that uh
it's been a while since I joined the
broadcast I forgot you guys have a board
here I don't have to look at the one on
my screen uh yeah Knight E3 Knight F1
seems to have enough but I I think I
think part of it is also he just he you
know he might have started the match
just a bit relaxed right like he played
a very very offbeat opening and he but
he's still got a completely winning
position and he just thought okay I'm
just gonna deliver Checkmate and that
will be the end and yeah yeah this is uh
well this is a worse nightmare situation
but there's uh there's eight points
still to be gained as a team and I think
we're pretty good on the other boards
but I haven't looked so now I'm kind of
terrified well
it's it's true lamb lay is getting the
job done against Frederick svane at this
at this time
um and Natalia buxa also looking
she's down on the clock but the position
is interesting against Rasmus Swanee so
but still you know we hate to have you
be here and to have things go so weirdly
wrong Levy but uh yeah weird start for
the Gotham Knights and uh we'll see
where it goes in the rest of the day
no listen escaro has said before uh he
uh he's a streamer first so he's got to
do things in the most dramatic fashion
you know so now we got to get now all
the story lines and narratives are going
to be out there of uh yeah but I I'll
stay positive I'll be happy with the 2-2
round one uh we are a rating favorite I
think on three of these boards they're a
very very good team but obviously we'll
hope for the best that's all it's all
like well let me before I let you go if
I'm playing I'm like no
last question because I saw fans asking
in chat we've seen some teams sporting
some pretty sexy swag the blitz had
jerseys you've got the Berlin bears with
the hoodies the fans want to know
how long until the levy Rosman Gotham
chess merch and will Gotham Knight's
merch be a part of that I can't I can't
just use the same wingardium Levy Rosman
mug forever bro
yeah that was before I even had facial
hair that's like the old Gotham you know
what I mean uh I think there there is a
result so Liam did get the job done uh
yeah so we actually have a wait list we
have gothammerch.com I've been working
with uh the fourth wall we're gonna
probably get a nice hoodie design it's
just you know we I really want it to be
super nice uh there's an m in the
evaluation in hikaru's game on the board
which is absolutely unreal that Knight
on F1 is absolutely good speaking of
it's it's it's the it's a knight that's
the goat but it's not the it's not
playing for our team uh so yeah we will
have some merch and I hope to do a big
Gotham merch drop like in the few in uh
23 for myself but I wanted to be super
nice I don't want you know there to be
threading and for it to be poor quality
so like a typical Creator uh merge drop
so yep
well good stuff man the fans will
eagerly await that let's get some Gotham
Knights merch in it too and good luck to
the team the rest of the way maybe maybe
this is the drama that the people wanted
hey Carl as you said he's a streamer
first content first and we are gonna
have drama now with this with this board
one upset so good luck man and we'll uh
we'll talk to you later
yep thanks guys cheers
wow Danny I mean I can't believe it I'm
shocked it was it's so funny because
like that that script was supposed to go
very differently we were supposed to
have international Master Libby Rosman
talk about recruiting Hikaru celebrate
hikaru's first Victory here and instead
the gloves came absolutely off the
wheels came off wow and look at her she
is jubilant here she was trying not to
celebrate but you could tell that this
may be the happiest moment of her chest
life she's a very strong player but she
just took down hikara Nakamura there it
is they're the smile that's the smile
wow well self-inflicted wounds for
Hikaru losing his focus a little bit
thereof K the day is Young and we'll see
what happens but uh Leia lay did get the
job done on board two you can just see
it there in the lower left corner it was
it was a pretty dominant victory over
Frederick Swan Abel okay let's go to the
game between Dimitri kolars and Andy
Woodward we've got time scrambles on the
board unfortunately Andy Woodward is
also oh no oh no Danny there's a queen
on H1
oh no never played like Danny never
played like Dan never go full Dan
um
okay Andy Woodward gets a little bit of
a lesson I I did say that uh Dimitri
kolars for those who don't know is a
very experienced protesting veteran very
good at this time which I'll look for
him to be a name that you get to know
well by the end of the season if you
don't already now we got to go to the
only other board still in action no
they're all done yeah what they're all
done wait it wrapped up as well there we
go all four games are done
wow that was like a quick Sprint there
at the finish and it looks like rosemus
funny he's up a night a clean night
against Natalia buxa so he gets the win
and that means the Berlin Bears yeah
County correctly they won three out of
four
what a uh what a surprising start for
this one if you're the Gotham nice
you've been put on your heels put on
notice by the Berlin Bears the brothers
funny helping to lead the way and uh and
just like that
it's a 3-1 scorer for the team from
Germany
oh my goodness I mean it all came down
Ward four for Berlin taking down board
one of the goblin you thought hikara
would not lose all season he lost the
first game of the entire PCL that he has
played for the Gotham Knights now he is
going to be roaring back but look at his
next three opponents Danny those are
three strong underrated Grandmasters you
need to be very careful if you Gotham
knights in particular Nakamura playing
for the results and often backfire 100
especially when you let uh when you let
the Demons of the past we always say you
can't play against your ghosts of the
past but it's hard to do when you're a
human being and you lose a game uh to
start things off one that you were
definitely not supposed to
um but okay next he will play the board
three remember how it works in order so
he will he'll be taking on Frederick's
funny next and uh we'll see what happens
with Hikaru there uh of course many
other matchups that will continue to
break down uh we we will be taking our
first break of the day here in just a
moment and of course before we head to
round two just
I don't know I feel a little rattled
right now I feel like uh I feel like the
Multiverse door opened and we
accidentally slid through the wrong one
we're gonna see where we where we go
from here I hope everyone is as excited
as we are uh we're gonna continue our
coverage of the pro chess League our
second match of the day the Berlin Bears
have a 3-1 lead over the Gotham Knights
and we will be right back
oh
[Music]
welcome in to our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
and on if you have to explain that your
world champion and it's taking longer
than two words there's something wrong
with the adventure there's something
wrong but I believe in when we're
talking the 60s and 70s even the 80s and
90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where
I was trying to tone it down
uh not get very excited and also I had
not had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man
for it for the match to be over so that
he could clinch his title he wanted a
draw at any price I mean you can make a
joke that he had spent a week out of the
swimming pool already so he must have
been exhausted and waiting to finish so
for all of us there was this feeling of
um uh we got to grab this chance with
both hands because it's not going to
come by way
foreign
[Music]
and we are back here with the pro chess
League our second matchup of the day
continues with one of the youngest
players in the PCL we're getting a
close-up look there at Andy Woodward
and the bookshelf behind him there's a
map of the United States I think I see
uh Lord of the Rings series and some
Gary Kasparov migrate predecessor books
Robert
yeah you know my vision not as good as
yours but I think you are correct and as
we see he is the board three for the
Gotham Knights he is 12 years old
already and I am he's one of those
little monsters yeah Hikaru was 22 years
old when this young man was born the
average price of gas was 2.79 I'm not
really sure how that's relevant but it's
a great stat
and we've got the he is he is uh as
we've said he is the youngest okay I
knew he was one of the youngest he's the
youngest player in the Pro chess League
he earned the I am title just a few
months ago
um and uh he looks poised he had a tough
start he just lost to Dimitri kolars uh
but look for this guy to be uh to be a
name you get to know maybe not just the
season for the Gotham Knights but
probably for the rest of uh the rest of
his career for many years to come so
Andy Woodward there he is
making his PCL debut let's like let's
look at the scores for the Gotham
knights in this matchup uh and uh it's
not what they wanted to see not what
they had had drawn up on the old
whiteboard at home Robert to start the
day no because you see a one next to
Josephine heinemann's name that she took
down Hikaru Nakamura who has a zero next
to his that is as unexpected a result as
it gets a 450 Point rating upset and of
course the gossip match are going to be
upset we had Levy Rosman on the
broadcast I think he's as shocked as
anyone
yeah everyone was shocked it was uh it
was a great interview to catch up with
Levy Rosman also shout out to his
partner Alex ostrovsky as Levy would
want us to do the the genius as he would
say the brains behind recruiting so many
underrated players the young Stars uh
like Andy Woodward uh but okay right now
it doesn't matter how they built the
team they they're hopeful their team can
get it done Liam lay was the Lone bright
spot for the Gotham knights in that
first round we'll look for it we'll look
for Hikaru and others to try to rebound
if you're a Gotham Knights fan but shout
out to the Bears by the way who you know
again it's natural we talk a lot about
the nice you talk a lot about Hikaru
they're the star power on that team is
huge but this Berlin Bears team is solid
AF as the kids say right this team is
one of those you need to Mark early on
as one that might surprise you and be
one of the better ones at the end of the
year yeah and they're gonna need to be
solid AF solid as Frederick's funny
because he takes the black pieces
against Hikaru Nakamura we saw Frederick
he had a tough first matchup against
lamlay so Frederick he's going to need
to right the ship with the black pieces
way easier said than done when it's an
angry Hikaru coming at you yeah no one
no one likes Hikaru when he's angry and
uh Frederick Frederick's funny will will
hope that it's his day hey that rhymed
um all the way and uh we'll see we'll
see what happens here shout out to about
14 000 of you on Twitch we got 3 500 on
YouTube 10 000 of you watching Hikaru
another four or five watching Levy a lot
of people tuning in to chess and the
protest League here so no matter where
you are thanks for making the show a
part of your day and let's see uh what
Rasmus does here with the first move
against Andy Woodward we're off oh okay
and Andy Woodward he lost his first game
with the white pieces rosmus won his
with the black and we see just 93 D5 at
comp starting where's rasmus's move he's
is a very quick player but maybe he's
trying to feel out the position against
the youngster and I just have to say 12
years old and 24 47 and climbing Andy
Woodward is one of those prodigies that
you are going to have to watch out
yeah it's a that is a scary scary bright
future no kidding and uh we've seen some
of the the youngest talents in the world
play in these in these types of leagues
and these events you know people
remember Ali Reza farugia before the
launching of his fashion career before
he won the junior speeches championships
uh you remember people like Arjun
irigaisi and Nihao Soren and this is a
name that in a face you will get to know
very well in the coming years so all
right it's a Queen's Gambit decline
structure the d-pawn's leading the way a
semi-slub for black with the pawn on C6
this Knight B to D2 not the most common
development move it means we're probably
gonna see a G3 maybe transpose into some
sort of weird Catalan kind of structure
maybe a B3 double fee and cattle type of
structure for white yeah
it's what you do against the kids right
you just try to get out you have a book
as soon as possible it's possible that
Andy Woodward has never seen this
position before and he goes for a
grundfeld style setup and this bishop
can at some point slide to A3 to make
use of the fact the bishop is on G7 but
it's just you know rapid play from
rosmas he's up on time it's a good start
frame a very natural looking position
and there's tension and neither side
wants to release it
yeah this move A5 played quickly this is
a typical kind of structural idea you're
looking for A4 at different moments
sometimes it's designed to hold back A3
and B4 so a good move to kind of throw
in the youngster may never may not have
played this structure very often but so
far kind of holding his own
um
speaking of holding his own as we said
Frederick's fan a will need to do that
against the Kara Nakamura that game will
be starting in just moments and and
we're gonna we're gonna head back to our
bird's eye view to make sure that we're
ready the moment that game gets underway
because uh everyone wants to see how
hikara rebounds and given what just
happened to start things off if you just
miss it a huge upset with Hikaru losing
the first game to Josephine heinemann
and that other board Dimitri colors
versus Natalia buxa kind of a fun one as
well but here we go Hikaru has liftoff
and we have a king's Indian attack with
Knight F3 played for Nakamura
yeah maybe a slower approach to this one
it seemed like he was all in on the
aggressive play in that first game
against Josephine heinemann now he's
saying let's let's slow play this E5
rookie one Queen E2 it's all king's
Indian attack where you reroute your
pieces but for Frederick he is really
determining right now where does his
King go because sometimes you play B6
Bishop B7 and Castle queenside he
decides let me go kingside this can be
quite dangerous I was gonna say this is
the sharpest way to play when you Castle
kingside you gotta play B5 and you're
all in on B4 C4 D4 anything you can do
to get space and counter play for black
because White's plans if if Robert if
you want to highlight him faster than I
can say it but it's H4 Knight H2 Knight
G4 H5 the pieces are coming uh in a
hurry everything but the kitchen sink
and you might even throw that into for
good measure if you're white in these
positions yeah just a very simple plan
but Black's plan uh actually is quite
reasonable as well H6 stops the Pawn's
progress you actually do not want to
allow white to carve out the dark
squares and if you go Knight H2 Knight
G4 you have to be ready at any moment
for sacrifice on this year uh so white
often lines the pieces up against the H6
pawn and black will have to be ready to
deal with that and you often strike in
the center while white is playing on the
king side flank black plays towards the
center this position has been played uh
before at the highest level you can play
B4 C4 type ideas you go Queen C7 right
after this Pawn but you know what
White's plan is it's actually just very
straightforward and that's why a car is
playing very quickly
and black sometimes with Queen C7 Also
may move the Rook off of f8 so that you
can use the f8 square for either the
bishop or the Knight depending a timely
retreating defensive move may be needed
either piece can be used depending on
how white approaches it but this is
funny it's like you know you think of
the king's Indian defense as having this
attack for black on the king side this
is the King's Indian attack but a
similar uh game in that black is all in
on the queen side here white is all in
on the king side with colors reversed
the other way and this will be a fun one
and if you're funny like you called it
Robert that you you kind of would rather
have a game like this against Hikaru
where he's all in not necessarily
tilting but you know he wants a dub
after losing that first game at least
you're going to get some chances this is
going to be a spicy one and it's going
to have uh counter play for both sides
yeah not a single piece has been traded
all eight pawns all four minor pieces
the queens and the Rooks are on the
board and for Black Knight D4 is a
common plan you would like to see I'm
just going to show this very quickly you
would like to see files open up because
you get to put pressure down C2 now the
D4 Pawn may be a Target but oftentimes
black starts pushing more pawns up the
queen side so it's one of those
positions where you have to be certain
that Knight D4 is good we saw the evil
bar reacting white should be the side
for Choice uh but Knight D4 it's one of
those things that you most moves you
play to give air to your pieces
yeah 100 and I agree with your
highlighting that the transition often
favors black from uh you get the C file
perspective you get counter play
perspective so so here we call our play
G4 obviously immediately you start
thinking that G5 is coming next it also
keeps the options a little bit flexible
Knight D4 can sometimes be met by C3
from White and the idea is that then if
the knights are traded on F3 and if
black ever plays C4 you meet it with D4
and you lock it up I don't know if we
can bring up the analysis board to just
kind of show that what you do with those
Pawn levers is very instructive for
white you create a C3 D3 Dynamic look
I'm gesticulating with my hands I don't
know what I'm doing but I'm showing
where the pawns are with my hands Robert
it's very strange right there and so if
black tries to advance one way you keep
it closed and you still have G5 open
this is kind of what hikar was hoping
for uh at some point
and that's why we saw Frederick brings
Queen back to d8 he is defending the G5
score and bring his Queen closer towards
his own King and this opening is really
one that is it's deceptive I think it's
kind of devious not a single piece has
been traded but the plans we see for
white are clear let's go for an attack
and for black Z is that Sapphire is
going to hurt me or am I okay carp was
King H1 he clearly wants Rook G1 next
and the slightest pieces over to the G
file I think for Frederick it's time to
bring his Knight as a viable Defender
over to H7 cover the G5 push I love how
poised he is Frederick is focused this
is an opportunity you rarely get to kind
of pile on on a Hikaru Nakamura who's
not coming off of a good game it doesn't
happen to him that often and I like his
Focus I also like his time management
Robert I know Hikaru is up a minute and
15 seconds but but Swanee is not
overthinking this right he's he's
playing quickly he's playing confident
sort of deliberate chess in his time
management and that's going to be
critical to not get too doubt too far
down on the clock
and he's not scared right Frederick's
funny is a grand master he has played
against many of the world's best he's
often playing on chess.com so he is not
just afraid of the reputation of Hikaru
Nakamura he is look at that he says go
ahead sacrifice your Bishop on a chick
it is not going to work out if we can
bring up an analysis board it's a
critical line to show and a car doesn't
go let's do it but if you would
sacrificed this bishop on H6 it does not
pan out your queen takes a second Pawn
for the piece and here look at this the
position it's one where it looks
threatening for the black king but this
queen is actually trapped so after
Knight takes E5 distracting his Knight
away I love this bishop G5 gets this
Queen off the board that's a big problem
in losing position for white did you
just go full Donya for a moment you went
full done yeah
Bishop G5
Queen runs out of squares that's
actually that's actually a common theme
to be aware of there in these lines so
again more more great great stuff to
take note if you happen to play these
positions for either side and Swanee is
focused he is confident Hikaru is uh
shaking his head a little bit not quite
sure where to convert from here and that
might be our cue to back up from here
because while we do want to catch this
game as it gets spicy let's go back to
our bird's eye view and uh pay off pay
off some of the other games here there
are several other boards to look at we
see Lamb lay uh in a deadlocked roughly
equal position against Josephine
heinemann uh the woman who just took
down Hikaru nakamuru we also haven't
really looked at Dimitri kolar's
position versus Natalya buxa another
interesting one so Robert
you're in charge for a reason take it
take us to where you want to go from
here I spy tactic I show tactics so
let's go to the game between lamlay and
Josephine heinemann and the reason why
is because Josephine first took down
Hikaru and now with the black pieces as
a really nice position against her super
Grand Master opponent and the reason why
is that it would look it would appear
that this Knight should move out the way
yeah the queen on e4 is in trouble but
if you make a move let's say like Knight
D2 something like that the queen can
actually sacrifice itself on G2 because
when the king takes look at this bishop
and King in a row the Knight steps out
the way with check to the king and
checked the queen at the same time you
win back your material with interest you
see that black has a much better
position
I love it you almost went move Knight
get out the way you said night get out
the way you didn't say get out of the
way you said get out the way I caught
that
um now you can move Knight get out the
way if you put the Knight on H4 that
would guard the G2 Bishop not not saying
you would but I'm pointing out that one
crazy reason I'm saying that Robert is
because if the black queen can't go back
to G6 there's funny ideas where you can
play Bishop H6 in some positions and
actually Flex the fact that your queen
is also on an attacking Square uh of
course black has Bishop F6 on that in
that case okay and now now lamb lay says
I need to get my queen out the way
um and uh
maybe free up discoveries another way
right now the bishop is defended so you
can move the Knight to more aggressive
squares yeah I don't know exactly what
it threatens but we can see that and
like he's just trying to pose problems I
think it's time for the queen to move
out the way and go somewhere on the
queen side because if you go here you're
not only threatening the pawns you're
saving this discovery attack and there's
no checkmating attack the bishop 27
covers G5 you can always push upon if
you're threatened so I like the way
Josephine is playing this game she did
not get off to a good start in game one
she won the game but she was in big
trouble this is a great game though uh
in the early going against Emily and I
even though you know the the quick
amateur eye says oh Queen on H3 threats
of Knight G5 and you just assume there's
an attack but the truth is the queen on
H3 is super committed and very out the
way again I don't know what Ludacris did
to take over this show but we're gonna
get out the way and let Ludacris take
over here comes Queen A4 and that Queen
actually can spy on week okay it's funny
she goes for the
but I'm gonna give the same criticism
you gave last game Robert I think it's a
little bit of a timid move right Queen
A4 flexes Flex advantage and I'm
surprised by that move from Josephine
yeah it was completely unnecessary I
mean she now has ruined her own Pawn
structure double isolated pawns white is
first of the activity
taking advantage of a pin if you take
this Knight I'm not taking back I'm
taking your bishop and if white doesn't
win material which looks likely at the
very least you have the bishop pair and
a better blood sugar so Josephine she
may be respecting her opponent's ratings
a little bit too much she did win game
one uh the game wasn't a clean one I
mean it was Shaky Ground for her but she
was able to stand strong and win here
she will need to do more of the same
because she's much worse than it yep
okay well the night does get out the way
the bishop puts pressure on the diagonal
we're going to leave Josephine to figure
this one out back to our bird's eye view
and make sure we pay off uh the other
games we haven't checked in with yet is
Dimitri kolars and Natalya buxa
um I'm looking at a pretty awesome
Outpost Square there on D5 for Dimitri
kolars uh a roughly equal position but I
kind of like white so let's let's how to
Let's head over there
okay collars is is giving us the old the
good old-fashioned forehead Cam
that looks like a five head to me Danny
come on yeah I just want us
oh his eyes popped up he knows we're
talking about it uh
the Natalya is this is a special kind of
style structure I don't know the I don't
know the opening exactly but just to
highlight what I mean by that white has
the D5 Square here everybody and it is a
good Square it's an alpha square but
black has D6 E5 and if you get F5 you
have a structure that faces the king
side and so what you're getting kind of
in compensation for that sacrifice of
The Outpost square is maybe the
potential for some space but but I
really like white in this position I
know the eval Bar says equal Robert I'm
just biased to the fact that I have such
a positional Advantage exactly on D5
that Bishop on G7 is bad tell me I'm
wrong Grand Master what what is what is
going on here no you're talking and
highlighting the important positional
nuances and I think that it's time for
black to go after this knight and king
h8 all right that's a fine move white
doesn't really want to take on E6
because when the pawn captures back your
knight doesn't hop forward does this
remind you of a certain game it should
Arjun Eric icy and Maxine Russia La
Grave it was a bad Bishop staring into
pawns but when this Pawn came to E6 it
dominated night on E3 so I feel like uh
kolars he's just going to build up
pressure on the C file maybe hint at a
D4 push at some moment but I I like his
position it just feels easier to play he
controls the pawn break yeah I agree so
you wanted Bishop H6 instead of King h8
maybe from like okay we don't have to
analyze it I'm just I'm going in full
instructive mode and I shouldn't keep it
entertaining Queen C2 threatening the
the battery that everyone fears three
major pieces there on the C file
um and it is looking hard for books of
yeah I really don't like that Bishop I
would play Bishop H6 at some moment
maybe next uh because especially if the
Rook goes to C1 that pins the Knight but
you just see maximum pressure in the
position uh D4 would be available if the
bishop goes to H6 and the king is
feeling a bit unsafe there so yeah I'm
liking it for colars
okay
well uh time is uh is close to equal in
this one so a small Advantage for colors
but not not uh not anything to write
home about just yet
let's back up to the bird's eye view and
maybe choose our next adventure based on
that Dynamic of what the clocks are
giving us so we look at Andy Woodward he
is the lowest on the timer of any of the
four boards
um but but the game is very Dynamic and
he's held his own here against Rasmus
Swanee you want to check out that one
okay so Rasmus funny taking on Andy
Woodward I see an outside pass Pawn
that's in was on the top left of our
screen and well I love the pawn on A5 I
love the Knight on C4 protecting that
pawn this bishop on F6 not exactly able
to fend off these Knights and light
squares I think strategically white is
just dominating but somehow black has
activity maybe using the open B file and
the queen is causing the knights to stay
put
yeah exactly it's weird because all the
concrete factors are like how is white
not more better here right the pawn on
A5 is really strong but but then you
start looking for a move that improves
White's position what is you can't play
Rook B1 black trades Rooks and and wins
the Knight on C4
you can't move the Knight on C4 without
the D3 Knight being tender
okay you move that out on F4 to D5 there
we go that answers the question that's
an improvement
um
and how does how does Andy deal with
that that's a tough one and you see
everyone the point is that those nights
on the light squares okay 95 might be
the the way out but white has options to
immediately trade and win the C5 fund
possibly no
true I was just trying to get the B2
Square for my Rook so I'm trying to
remove this Knight it's such a great
piece Knights are the best block haters
because they stop the pawn and it's
tracked and see over the pond and they
even protects the its own past Pawn on
A5 so this Knight is a great piece I
want to trade it off but you are right
the C5 Pawn is loose we can show that
quickly that's the 95 swap swap Rook
takes C5 it looks like white is a pawn
ahead but I was thinking that this Rook
could slam down on B2 and this queen is
a bit awkward to deal with this rook and
there's back rank checks available I was
gonna say there's even fun lines like
Queen A3 you get Rook B1 check and queen
F1 and you know whoop Bob's your uncle
to steal a line out of Don just book so
anyway that that's actually not
completely out of the question not gonna
happen but blunders do happen in time
pressure and it's a good idea to see uh
tactics that Swan a needs to be needs to
be worried about
and Andy Woodward brings the Knight to
E5 that's a good choice for him uh the
Gotham Knights need this point maybe a
half Point uh will be sufficient but
they need to start scoring because
they're down three to one and yeah all
four boards are in full swing here but
it seems like uh the Berlin bears are
giving them all they can handle
yep the the one bright spot we said it
last round it's maybe happening again
let's go back to Lim Lay's game because
uh with white against Josephine
heinemann uh he's uh he's proving that
The Rook ending can be won we see that
he's got the extra B Pawn and
unfortunately for Josephine I think
heading to that end game that we were
critical of ultimately was was the wrong
decision so let's quickly bring up limb
lace game versus Josephine heinemann
because I think it's going to be the
first one to end and we can just show
that uh this is this is a kind of a
straightforward Rook ending to win
because the Brooks doubled on the
seventh ring keeps the king and Rook
stuck on the file you can slowly work
the B Pawn and uh looks pretty good or
white yeah now here you can play Rook C6
and then move this Rook so you can free
the B Pawn that's at some point white
can even throw in the F5 I was just
gonna say yeah you shatter the pawn
structure to give yourself another
Target uh it's maybe it takes a little
bit more time than it would initially
appear uh but Lemley a form World Blitz
Champion 2700 plus player I think he has
this one I believe he feels very
confident in his chances Rook C6 I think
just keeps black it's kind of Frozen and
speaking of Frozen H Pawn to go nowhere
Oh I thought you were going to say
speaking of Frozen we need to let it go
and move on from this game head back
over to the bird's eye view thanks Elsa
uh don't sue me Disney all right we
checked in we paid off the debt here I'm
not sure we'll see that one finished
because there are some more exciting
positions uh to choose from and uh
I kind of want to head back to akara
nakamura's game it's it's not one that
that has a a strong
hold for any oh but good timing hikara
plays F4 we're getting spicy and we've
got time pressure for Fredericks Monet
let's head over to a car's battle as
he's trying wait a second
wait what
he went from that last move turned it
around yeah
he was going for this and I guess the
bishop could have slid to F4 to shut
down the file instead of Queen trade is
offered Danny wait but I think this is
just good if I take and bring your rook
in and then bring your Rook around and
even get this one what do you say
rakarovka Rica rovka that's castles uh
that's a uh the linai or karate
uh but uh you know that Rook isladia but
Reco rovka is actually castles um anyway
I think the idea is you check on f8 you
take E6 you get a Tempo with Bishop H3
and then Bishop F5 check follows oh
right let's show that we'll bring up an
analysis board Rook Cafe that's actually
I mean now support not needed oh it's
happening for it so there you go
yeah there's only one check the king
slides away it can just run away and
there's not going to be enough for
black there two seconds you might even
get a move off he does he check barely
does
you'll be going down the exchange and
maybe more because after she's six The
Rook comes to F7 with check and Hikaru
Nakamura looks to be on his way to
rebounding his fans are happy about that
um but the Gotham Knight still have a
lot of work to do given how they started
and Rook F7 check yeah oh gosh that's a
is this winning because Rook check here
spice thing goes that way and then G7
you go up a bishop
so spice you know the car doesn't need
to be uh
told any more than that he's gonna win
the bishop should be going to win but
especially because the D5 Pawn Falls and
then the light score Bishop just owns
the board and so Swann a doesn't even
want any more of it he resides he's mad
because he he knows he had a good chance
and it was this moment Bishop F4
shutting down the rook and opening the
H6 Square for his own Rook that would
have been what he needed so the game is
over uh Hikaru Nakamura won but there
was a mischance for Frederick Hayes in
time travel so let's get on out of here
uh the car gets hit the Gotham Knights
needed it and other games are still in
session
bird's eye view uh we've got a rook
ending for the others funny Andy
Woodward holding his own the youngster
the young fella
look at that he plays C3 he's pushing
this Rook ending to its wrong position
let's head over there
Andy Woodward is holding on
wow and Andy didn't hold on to his toys
and Toy Story no no spoilers sorry if
you didn't see torso that's your fault
but he is trying to hold on what wait
what happens
hey this is a you problem this is on you
look at this boom new Queen and now we
have an even Queen and pawn but Danny
the one thing I'm noting is this part on
H4 it's good if your queen can get the
checks in but maybe it sticks out a
little bit so yeah if white can weasel
his way out of Perpetual checks you may
have a chance yeah so wait though what
happens so does Andy like give away his
toys in the end like um
I never saw the fourth or fifth or sixth
one I think there's like seven of them
now
well we're not gonna see a seven time
repetition only three in this one we
might is about to be agreed wait me we
can't get seven times three times the
game is done it's how this works this is
fine you know the rules of Chess moving
on okay
um all right a draw but seriously huge
shout out to Andy Woodward he gets his
first point even if it is half of one on
the day so so he's feeling good hey Kara
Nakamura already won as we saw Lim lay
is uh getting the job done right as I
say that we see a result in the lower
right corner so only game for us to look
at is kolars versus buxa and here we go
but that means that the Gotham Knights
they have two and a half out of three in
this round if they draw this game that
means the match will be tied but uh oh
in comes the White Queen A6 is loose D6
is loose but the Knight on D5 needs
Defenders and that's why the queen
couldn't snag that pawn
yeah books are holding on here but she
only has seven seconds you gotta move
it's gonna come down to whose nerves are
better with limited time on the clock I
love it
yeah or maybe a win I mean if you're not
I was gonna say this is
this is one of those ones that can
backfire especially with no time you see
collars lean up this is super
nerve-wracking bring your queen to G4
that's what I would have done City
Allah's the immediate draw
ER
rookie two it's me oh black wins oh my
gosh
a
oh my gosh what a turnaround
she steals one here wow and the Gotham
Knights have rebounded with a 3-1
victory in round two everybody buckle up
we have liftoff
oh my goodness the night is darkest just
before the dawn and it just dawned on
him that he had Queen D7 check and when
the king runs away the queen can come
back to G4 to stop that check on G3 he
thought that he had minimum a draw with
the Rook sliding back but this would
have secured at you know the half point
and white cannot lose his position
we could feel the tension when she
played Queen G5 it was like wait a
second this is how games backfire even
though it was still equal of course this
idea Queen D7 Queen G4 but
but wow so much and by the way King H1
was still okay because rookie two Rook
G1 so King H1 was the draw King G1 was
actually the final blunder
wow that is a sad turn of events for the
Berlin Bears because now they go from a
3-1 advantage and they are trailing
because a three and a half half
obliteration in the second round of
games
we see it right there three and a half
half uh that's uh every single Gotham
Knight got on the board the young Andy
Woodward with the draw victories for all
of the other Knights and just like that
things have turned around time for the
Berlin Bears to huddle up and figure out
what they got to do where does that
leave us in the overall match scores
let's check that out right now it means
that the Gotham Knights go from trailing
by a couple of games to Leading by one
as we head to round three Robert
is the hero right now for the Gotham
Knight uh but Natalia books a huge win
there she was in trouble in that game
but Frederick swanna he is the only
player not on the scoreboard he
struggled against the top two Heavy
Hitters for the Gotham Knight he needs
to get back at it and he will have
easier opponents in the next round
yeah it was hard to say anyone is is
easy but I agree uh you know at this
point you're looking forward to the next
couple rounds I'm super impressed right
now by the knights ability to rebound
Robert just because that's that's a hard
way to start when your guy Hikaru
Nakamura he's the guy you brought in to
lead you right when he loses it rattles
everybody so shout out to them for
rebounding we'll see if the Berlin Bears
can do the same in round three but all
right we'll see a lot of college chefs
this season if you didn't know the
Collegiate chess League spring season
has begun it is back and it's shaping up
to be incredibly exciting with the best
players and college chefs and future
Global Stars competing I like to call it
kind of the baby League of the protest
League you know I don't know maybe
they'd say no but it's thirty thousand
dollars in prizes uh round four matches
take place this Saturday February 18th
you can check out the action at
twitch.tv Collegiate chess League it has
all the coverage use the command CCL in
chat for more Robert uh I'm excited the
baby Team league baby Team league the
pro chess League you know baby shark doo
doo doo doo doo College
we should go to a break
because I'm not gonna stop
hey
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called
Duchess chess but with a duck quack
quack how to play duck chest the duck is
a brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
foreign
moves of opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no London's
can permanently stop the London capture
the points King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemates let's still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
this works oh that's a horrible plan oh
my God I just I just wondered I have to
move something else first then dark and
Knight will take my king this is the
best way to lose the dark chess
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chest
duck chess champion give me those points
baby
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
and competitive chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
we win we win oh my God welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives we got it let's go see him
and that's it he does the job oh Sam
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion oh my God
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
the Gotham Knights getting a comeback
done given how they started helped and
led right now by that man
look at that trophy case look at that
fair play camera by the way shout out to
the fair play Team working super hard
behind the scenes two cameras on
everyone along with all kinds of other
things I just hey fair play Team
um hey hey limlay Robert your thoughts
limlay is a monster he's doing great
work for the Gotham Knights they have a
talented roster from top to bottom Lim
lay the head coach of Webster University
and you look at this lineup first of all
it is extremely International look at
all those different flags there Danny
yeah
I love it no I mean Hikaru Nakamura Lim
blade Vladimir fetto save the big fish
as we like to call him Andy Woodward as
we've talked about today along with
Natalya books uh they're filling out
boards three and four if we're focused
on the people throwing down right now
but yeah this is an exciting lineup it's
as you said a very diverse team
from all over the world and uh you got
to be excited if you're a Gotham Knights
fan Levy super team as well as Alex
ostrowski working hard to get this done
they worked hard Robert in that last
game and it helped them turn things
around that last set of games excuse me
to ultimately Take the Lead four and a
half three and a half now we're getting
closer to the top boards playing each
other hikar Nakamura will take on
Dimitri kalar's next that obviously is a
big one Lim blade will take on Rasmus
spawn a but uh any any other thoughts
you have about which games have your
attention as we head into round three
well just like earlier today I mean of
course all eyes on the car Nakamura and
Lim lay the top boards for the Gotham
Knights but I'd like to look at the
bottom two boards and Frederick svane
he's at off to a tough start lost his
first two games against limbo and hikar
Nakamura but he has the white pieces
against bookset now buxa did just beat
uh Dimitri kolars there that was a tough
one for the bears but Frederick needs to
get on the scoreboard he has the white
pieces he's the higher rated player
now's his opportunity to make his
presence fell and I'm excited for the
Josephine heinemann versus Andy Woodward
matchup right I mean heinemann took down
Hikaru Nakamura she's got to be feeling
confident and remember she had a great
position just now against Lynn lay until
she chose to make that Queen trade so if
anyone their teammates giving her
confidence in coaching maybe look to be
more aggressive maybe she'll be feeling
more confident as she now plays uh
someone someone closer to her rating
here against Andy Woodward so all right
um so much to talk about here as round
three and four will get underway 12 000
of you on Twitch with us almost 4 000 of
you on YouTube keep the chat going we'll
be featuring your comments don't be
afraid to make fun of Robert chat it's
okay I'm here if he yells it's okay I'm
you know if you want to get some feature
chat going that makes fun of Robert
um permission granted you can make fun
of me Danny as long as I get a Berlin's
bear hoodie I mean look
that that's up for the Berlin Bears
shout out to uh the manager I think it's
Beau Wimmer working hard for the Berlin
Bears maybe send us some some hoodies
man all right we've got we have a
Catalan Lim lay versus Rasmus Swanee we
gonna be here all day it's Rhyme Time
Hess all the way
okay well we have a Catalan oh you're
out he gives us the piece the fingers
and now it's Bishop on C6 staring down
this bishop on G2 E4 square is under
blast control but white will try to
bring a rook to E1 this develop this
Knight to C3 and get E4 in so that's
what the battle revolves around this E4
square and if Bishop takes Knight takes
here will black at some point be able to
get this move C5 and it's got E4 and C5
like any good Sicilian I love it I love
it well highlighted the bishop on C6 is
always pointing these cattle lands
because it's awkward that it's in front
of the C Pawn but as you said serving as
persistic purpose to kind of neutralize
the G2 Catalan Bishop so that if 95
comes you can make a trade kind of a key
piece but if white can somehow get E4 in
before making trades then the bishop on
C6 fuel software because E4 followed by
D5 and you're starting to get starting
to get pushed around a little bit so
we'll see uh we'll see what the prep is
for these two guys they've both played
very fast to this point
right and so while this one is kind of
deeper Farther Along we have Hikaru
Nakamura he's playing uh against Dimitri
kolars kolars lost that game against
buxa but Denny and we see another King's
Indian attack from Hikaru Nakamura yeah
he's uh he's liking it though a totally
different approach there from Dimitri
kolars for those who just saw uh the
game before this round hit coronakamura
beat Fredericks funny in a traditional
kind of King's Indian attack all-out
Affair this is a different one colors
fiancattle's his Bishop as well that's
going to change the dynamic of the game
white will not be in an all-out King
side attack here anymore ladies and
gentlemen it's going to be more
positional you're going to see white
strike for E4 or C4 depending a
different type of game this one will be
thanks Yoda
okay well we see that Dimitri College
taking the Magnus Carlson approach in
the finality of the air things Masters
that last game this is what Magnus
played and they ended up swapping queens
and Magnus Bishop to G4 and it was a
great position for Magnus he will end up
winning the tournament so E4 Dan do you
think we're gonna see a queen trade or
is Dimitri going to keep the queens of
the board with the move like 97.
uh I would advise him to keep the Queens
on the board I think that it's a
slippery slope to think that you're
neutralizing Hikaru from getting the
Queens off the board I think that
anningham's a little bit easier for
white to play but okay 97 will be met by
Knight C3 maybe for Hikaru maybe he
doesn't want that transition 97 Knight
C3 d492
I would be you know
I would encourage Dimitri colors to
follow his heart
wow I mean do you want him to listen to
his heart
I'll try to touch your heart
I can't do it I can't do it because of
movie Magic I'm prevented
um all right well collars is okay he
goes for the end game so indeed his
heart leads him down the road uh but the
reason I like this so white will play C3
I think
um to guard the D4 square and then you
have you have the D file early and it's
a teeny Advantage but usually white just
has one of those one step kind of Tempe
games which I think Hikaru enjoys this
kind of chess
right I mean C3 just to take away the D4
Square for the Knight upon three squares
away from a knight dominates it we've
seen this so many times in other games
but look at black it's the complete
development here this bishop can slide
back even to the D7 square and that
would allow blood to Castle Queen side
next or you play Bishop E6 just say what
you do bring your knight to G5 that's
not scary it might just continue uh
moving around I think that black can't
complain about this opening okay okay
well good stuff then all right there you
go he plays Bishop E6 ikaro needs to
develop the queen side I love that Comet
from Chad Dimitri carlars looks like
he's uh he's he's facing a test he
hasn't prepared for
um I don't know I think he looks pretty
confident and focused not happy with how
that last one ended against buxa but as
we said he's one of the one of the
better players I think in the processity
consistently over the last several years
uh name that you maybe don't know about
but watch out
for sure and we see that Knight D2 this
is a very calm start to the game all
four are underway this air in the
protesting the thing I love the most
about and I think many other fans do as
well is every single board is equally as
important as the other so a car Nakamura
will get a ton of attention throughout
the season uh but for his team Andy
Woodward's game Natalia books his game
they are just as important as it and
which one do we want to go to right
they're both they're both just getting
started uh both have the potential for
some real fireworks we might as well
head over to Frederick swanee's game
versus Natalya book sets a little bit
further along
an awkward awkward kind of position with
the pawn on C4 holding back Black's
Queen side b and a pawn so a sicilian a
sicilian structure where white has this
opponent C4 potentially could lead to a
very big Advantage if that pawn gets to
C5 in some positions and it fully cramps
down black style the risk is you give up
the D5 square if you do that to the
Black Knight and F6 but but anyway I I
like this space Advantage for white if
it's played accurately
yeah no I'm with you there because uh in
this position we look at the amount of
material which is even but the pollens
are not on the same file so white has a
three on two on the queen side here
three against these two and black has a
four on three over on the king side in
the center so in the end games if we
could see a future where pieces get
traded then the end games often favor
white because your pawns are more on the
side of the board they're distracting
Black's pieces but look at this healthy
Pawn structure E6 F7 you mentioned if
white ever play C5 the Knight comes into
D5 you couldn't really ask for more in
terms of the compact nature of yeah
I agree and adding to that note the
pieces are Compact and so is the
structure there's no weaknesses for
black right so one of the advantages of
that the disadvantage if your opponent's
Advantage is based on activity in space
if they use it well there is pressure
but a single slip up you're right back
in it and maybe even better because you
have it you have no double pawns you
have no weak squares this position is
very solid like you said you use the
word Compact and uh books are having a
small time advantage to go with it shows
that she's confident with her position
so good stuff good stuff
yeah this is a good start for the Gotham
Knights though for Fredericks funny the
game will heat up later so he can try to
maneuver his pieces to his Advantage as
a continuous for example I was just
talking about how an end game would be
nice for white because you have an extra
Pawn towards the flank Queen B6 comes to
mind as White's next turn let's trade
off those Queens get that B6 Square for
the Knight and then push the pawns
forward
I love that and I love the majority that
could come from that uh but still he's
he can't do it right away right I mean
and maybe books is just trying to think
of how you kind of pass in a high-class
way right you don't really want to do
anything that makes your position worse
um so you make uh Yermo used to call it
a high-class waiting move
um something like I'm just throwing it
out there crazy like Bishop E8 just you
know have fun with me for a minute I
open the D file I keep the bishop on
that diagonal maybe you're gonna play
Queen B6 anyway because I can't take
your knight and the Queen at the same
time maybe that's the idea but what else
does black do I guess how would you pass
the turn or or make a move that helps
improve buxa's position
I'm sort of wondering like if I can
bring my knight into the center but I
see your point that you want the Knight
to be able to go to D5 in the event of
C5 so I'm not sure if 94 actually
accomplishes anything uh because where
is the night really going to trade oh
that Knight's on the rim it's not the
best piece in the world and I'm already
staring down at Queen B6 so Rook C8 does
come to mind okay I know it walks into a
fork so I have to eliminate that even
though I want to play it I'm kind of out
of ideas Danny I'm going to be honest
with you I just prefer White's position
well and that's maybe why Bishop E8
might be a move but when we're out of
ideas usually it's good to look for
someone else to help us so as soon as uh
as soon as he's ready we'll be we'll be
calling up another guest to join us it's
going to be a lot of fun once again okay
Bishop C6 was played
there you go willing to part ways with
the bishop pair opening the D file
bringing a little bit of freedom
and kind of luff to your to your pieces
there uh but you're giving white the
bishop here which is a long-term Dynamic
advantage and that Bishop on F1 at some
point is going to find an active
diagonal so so I don't know I'm with you
I'm liking I'm liking Frederick's
position more and more as this game goes
on that's the truth
I'm playing Queen B6 trying to go to the
end game maybe taking on C6 next and
just to point out that a queen B6 you do
not hang a knight on A4 because the
queen is undefended on C7 and if we get
a swap then the pawns are going up the
board this would be clearly a good end
game for white so I'm just looking at
this I think Frederick is Happy uh and
now he's also up on the clock yep all
right well even if Frederick is happy
here the Gotham Knights are much happier
than they were the last time this man
was with us and uh and Levy Rosman
rejoins the show here the uh the captain
and commentator live on Gotham chess
shout out to the Gotham chess fans if
you can if you can hear me hi hi big fan
of the channel um hey Levy
hey guys I uh I hope that this time when
I join uh nothing goes horribly wrong
wow well how how excited were you to see
your team's rebound there in the second
round right you're down two games and
kind of the impossible happened with
Hikaru Nakamura losing uh to board four
but you're right back in it you've got a
lead and and how you feeling right now
captain
yeah I uh I had to step out it was funny
I was my co-commentator was was Manning
the ship and um we were messaging and he
was like oh Hikaru won you know Liam won
like Liam has been playing he's been
he's been smooth like butter today
Hikaru with the nice bounce back win
hard fought man like I feel like
everybody who see who sees an
opportunity to play against Hikaru just
plays up a level like they just they're
like I don't want to get blown off the
board I got to do my best we saw it in
the Magnus fourth round game like that
game has a couple of other moves played
by a Wonder it's a totally different
storyline right but Magnus doing Magnus
things so uh but then yeah our board
forward taking down their board two I I
don't know because they have their very
balanced team I don't know who's who but
amazing yeah I mean I couldn't be
happier yeah
well I'm sorry go ahead Robert I was
gonna say do you want to give an opinion
on this one before we head there's
another game we haven't looked at uh in
a little bit I want to bounce too and
maybe we can go look at hikaru's game
while you're here uh have have you
reversed the fortunes but your thoughts
on how books is played right she just
got the dub against kolars that was huge
and even though she might be in a tough
one here
yeah well I all all her all her games
today are kind of like a consistent diet
of like 2600s uh of course it's all
women's matchup on board four I mean
like my friend we were talking about
this earlier like when you play a team
like ours you just get done playing a
Hikaru although she won but again you
know normal circumstance you play at
2700 and now you have to play another
2700 like win lose you know normally in
open tournaments you lose you get like a
more friendly pairing but she's been
great her prep has been really good her
time management has been good and to win
a Time scramble against the guy who's
like 3 000 bullet last round what more
can you ask for from the board for like
her job is done you know what I mean but
obviously there's two more games
yep
yeah and I was gonna ask because you
know this position looking good for
Fredericks funny but if we zoom out to
all four uh boards here we see Hikaru
once again kind of in a shaky position
and Levy you know hikara does his thing
we all know that he is among the best
along with Magnus Carlson and all quick
time controls and online chess but as a
captain as a manager do you ever speak
to the team about what you need from
them or do you just completely let them
do as they must and let them be
individuals
well it's the it's the first week and
um I mean obviously in the second week
we we might play with a few different
like conceptual lineups right now we
have a very balanced board three four we
might in the future go to like a monster
board three you know 2580 like right
under the rating cap and uh and then our
board four will just kind of like make
the average work so it's only week one
or two uh but uh yeah I mean it
conversations need to occur and pep
talks need to occur I don't think Hikaru
needs to hear anything uh from me I
think he uh he can look within himself
when he needs to turn it on let's not
forget that there was a playoff that New
York played against France and Hikaru
beat four Frenchmen in a row uh like
that was the last stand you know what I
mean so it's weird because chess is a
very individualistic activity and like
aside from Olympiad
there's no real place really where a
captain gives a pep talk or you kind of
like you know you have like a team thing
so uh I think it's kind of like let
Hikaru do his thing like when you have a
star player on the team like let him do
his thing and build around him if you
have Liam going three out of four you
have like boards three and four shining
we just need eight and a half you know
what I mean I mean it's not like Hikaru
is playing on blindfold mode or
something like that but uh it's weird
because chess like I said it's a very
individual thing you live with you live
and die by your own decisions and
results but in this case everything you
do like affects the team so uh listen uh
if uh let's talk about this let's talk
about this position a little bit we've
got
we've got pawns on e4 and A4 that are
targets uh and that's probably the uh
the biggest problem with hikaru's
position but like you said letting
Hikaru do her car with things he he's
gotten the Knight to D5 he's holding on
um Robert your thoughts on how realistic
Black's winning chances would be because
other than that night on B8 the pieces
are kind of ideally placed if you could
pick up that 9 on B8 and put it on D4
you'd be happy otherwise what else is
black playing for here well I think what
Levy said that Kolar is like a 3 000
level bullet player and Blitz player and
he has an advantage he also has a slight
lead on the clock it's easier for black
to play this is Brook on A3 it's a
bystander simply defending this Pawn A4
this is the best piece the Knight and C5
is great and I sort of why I was asking
because ikaru is playing these openings
where he's asking for trouble like it's
the type of opening where you're like
I'm playing for a win but I might also
get a bad position and he does have a
bad position he just is kind of hoping
that black can't crash through
but it's weird because I think you know
uh anytime Hikaru streams and I stream
like uh we have to deal with chat
relaying back and forth
everything that said he played the move
e-fame he was inviting a queen trade and
he I think he out loud said because it
was really into my check because
everything Hikaru does like breathe eat
sleep whatever is relayed
um they were saying like he said team's
doing well like we're in a good position
so I'm not going to take any unnecessary
risk
um so you know I like but now colors has
a very nice position right so
uh Alex and I were talking about Hikaru
just played this against Magnus Hikaru
just played this line against Magnus and
Magnus equalized but we're like okay
colors is not Magnus but he's actually
doing me even better than Magnus did
like he hasn't even yeah her Advantage
so yeah well and now we're headed to our
name game where the knights are looking
more dominant against the bishop the
bishop is closed in By the Light squares
uh sorry the light squared pawns pulling
on e4 opponent A4
so you're right and and you know we've
been kind of singing calor's praises too
by the way just educating you know chat
and viewers who may not be aware of just
how good this guy is uh in this time
control and he was one of the stars that
helped lead the bond uh German team in
in previous protesting years all the way
to the finals in San Francisco and so
um he's not to be trifled with now all
of that being said Here Comes Hikaru
slowly kind of wiggling his way out the
C4 square has opened up for the night so
you know Levy Hikaru taking it a little
safe maybe now he's gonna turn it on
here in the final moments because uh
doesn't want to let colors grind him out
yeah turn it on but defensively right
white is not the one calling the shots
in this position I mean this is a
position where okay and there you go
that was a massive decision from kolars
to trade the Bishops and the the bar the
evaluation went down one third the
problem when you play kikari you get a
better position and I'm not going to
speak for how colors thinks but it's
like oh my God I'm doing really well I
can always make a draw like at least I'm
not going to lose I was talking about
this when you play Magnus and you play
Hikaru your mindset is like at least I
don't lose
it's not like I'm gonna win and uh
unless presence fall into your hand like
in that first game I mean she just had
no choice but to win she just got a
winning position completely out of
nowhere she converted it perfectly
um so he might be still like his
Advantage is not super easy to convert
here but uh yeah I mean how are the
other games going that's that's my
question it's a very important
a lot of even matchups now
go ahead yeah this game might be about
to end in a repetition by the way with
the Rook coming back and forth so let's
go to the bird's eye view Levy we'll let
you choose while you're here you're the
guest what game would you like to check
on from your team
uh we could go to the goat the goat Andy
Woodward uh okay world number one under
12 year old
I didn't know that
yeah dude we gotta we got a stack team
we got a world Blitz Champion Leanne we
got Fisher random world champion we're a
good team we're a good team World number
one playing the black pieces here go
ahead Robert not say not a good team a
great team uh but in this end game I
think it's looking pretty good for
Josephine she's ahead in the clock she
has the outermost pawns right blacks
extra Pawn is in the center the white
has this three pawns here and they tell
you to take kids down to the end game or
that's the usual advice and Andy is such
a great player right he is fantastic in
all that's the fastest of the game but I
do think that white has an easier end
game to play just because the better
night placement The Rook on the open
file and the king is a little bit more
advanced than the enemy
but I like how quickly he just played
Rook C6 Knight D7 I feel like he saw the
defensive setup and committed to it
um let me ask you Levy you you're trying
to keep the rook and Knight here are you
trying to go to The Rook ending if
you're Andy
uh no no no I'm always a proponent like
I feel like every piece that I trade I'm
getting closer to defeat I I I I like
the concept of if I have more pieces on
the board I have more chances for
counter play I played him in a game when
he was only 2200 feet a only 2200 feet I
say I said was he like seven years old
yeah he would no it was um
it was uh it was spiced up I think 2021
so he was like 10. I think he was 10
maybe okay he's 11. okay and
um and yeah he was already very good
I was winning for like three hours and
he just defended so well so well so uh
when you're a good end game Defender as
a child yeah good things are coming in
your chess career
talk about how well Andy's playing this
with this move A5 okay the king
centralized but it looks like he's got
himself a decent blockade whether Magnus
believes in blockades or not well he has
a blockade on one side it was F5 on the
other the king comes back and look at
this Suddenly It's black with the
activity and the great place pieces uh
the pawn on B3 is sort of stuck in place
if you ever played B4 you maybe just
drop a Pawn on the rim no he's actually
out playing Josephine she needs to be
very careful at this point you see him
play 975 to lean back
what yeah no they're they're sorry
there's like a two or three second like
delay between us I was just gonna say uh
Liam just has an amazing position if we
want to pop over there he has a position
that looks perfect for Speed format yeah
that guy that guy's a monster and we
called it at the beginning obviously
Hikaru Nakamura in many ways kind of the
face of your team as far as the players
go but Lim lay World Blitz Champion
dude's a monster let's go to that game
he's in a great position against Rasmus
svane and also up way on the clock way
up on the clock
uh look at this move D5 Robert keep
doing that instant replay thing
D5 look at that move awesome
yeah wow this is the best moves in chess
right like a square is controlled by all
the pieces for blackout you played
anyway because the Knight is loose in F5
yep wow Queen E4 oh Queen E4 is such a
such a good move you know what I mean
like G4 coming Knight E3 Queen H7 made
oh my God here here come I think you can
even okay you can play G4 now but
there's not H4 checks so maybe he'll go
for your move 93 love it you're right
but either way this is fantastic chess
and Lim lay might be 3-0 on the day when
this game's done
uh am I seeing that right Hikaru has an
advantage
what oh my goodness I know the the
audience doesn't see that we have the
big screen here behind the scenes
hikaru's got into how does he do this
it's I mean like it's
it's sick like he's better
it's insane it's insane and honestly not
only is he better he's up a minute and a
half on the clock it's head shakeable I
see Robert shaking his head it's a Bob
it's it's head shakable it doesn't make
any sense
um and and now apparently he's just
winning the Knight has to move the G6
Pawn is falling OMGs or snaps
what I always like to say in these
situations is colors would have
destroyed me in that position if I was
his opponent yeah not even because I
would defend worse I would it's just
psychological like I'm gonna squish this
bug I'm 200 points higher rated when you
play Hikaru when you play Magnus it's
like never over ever yeah
wow Bishop D5 unreal and he's just 1-0
by the way speaking of 1-0 limlay has
already gotten the job done it was an
Anastasia's mate at the end for those
who know their famous Checkmate so Rook
on H7 that's fun for the kids uh we'll
look at it when we go to the bird's eye
view but all right Levy this is this has
been crazy your team is your team is
coming back I'm I'm as Blown Away by
Hikaru and uh I think we'll let you go
and enjoy the last round with your
co-commentator Robin and I will bring
this one home here for round three
sounds good guys awesome job thanks for
having me it was a good luck charm this
time
you were we had to bring you back let
you end on a high note see you Levy and
Robert seriously though Hikaru of
turning this one around is about as
insane as we've seen all day
I just don't know how it's possible
right that position had a dominant black
knight on C5 uh White's pieces were
frozen and suddenly he's all his pieces
are out in the open he's up a pawn and
he's gonna win this game I mean just
it's ridiculous like it just doesn't
make sense
I I want Rook takes B6 to work here with
the idea of The Rook A6 Rook AAA mating
net I know it doesn't because the king
C8 I've already made one of those
blunders today but I wanted to point out
that the black king is close to being
mated over there with the rook and
Bishop dance that's all
yeah yeah unfortunately doesn't work
I'll just show what Danny is hoping for
it that he wants something like this
where the King goes the wrong direction
and the bishop and The Rook deliver a
Checkmate connect well and the King
can't get out but unfortunately the king
would run the other way and we see that
the Rook check on C3 it's a single check
you can just bring your King around to
H3 and look at Hikaru he is not trading
Rooks until the right moment he wants to
be captured here because I think he
wants to just trade everything off and
then win the king side yep the outside
pass Pawn uh you see collage Running Out
of Time living off the increment
literally made that move with two
seconds Here Comes G4 I think yeah I
think you just play it right away
followed by King G3 winning the pawn and
pushing the H Pawn to Victory and uh wow
yeah that's mind-blowing go ahead no I
just think that Hikaru is a magician I
mean I don't understand how it happened
you look at the position kolars knew he
was better and then suddenly he's just
lost look look at this Final Touch
Bishop D5 taking away the F7 Square for
the night colors is like I'm gonna go
shake this one off time for some fresh
air not interested in sitting here what
in the world just happened there and
back to our bird's eye view as we said
look at the upper left limlay does
finish the job in style that's Checkmate
on H7 the bishop on D5 as we saw
strangling the Knight on D6 so Hikaru
gets the dub let's head to Frederick's
funny versus Natalia bukska yes because
Andy Woodward and Joseph Heineman Drew
their game this is the only game
remaining of the round and oh isn't
Frederick he's up a piece for now though
this bishop is hanging but he's also up
three Pawns
yeah that's a lot of Pawns his King is
open so buxa still has drawing chances
due to Perpetual whenever your king is
that wide open but but this is a huge
win right now for Berlin because if spun
a can get this done there for the record
gonna have the same score that the blitz
did heading into the last round where
they completed a comeback so huge dub
right there the Berlin Bears stay within
Striking Distance and it's not over yet
you thought we were lying when we said
it wasn't over with the Blitz and mgd1
and we were right so don't go anywhere
despite the two-game lead for the Gotham
Knights I don't think this match is over
yet
no it's not over just yet but it's a
dominant performance in the last couple
rounds for the Gotham Knights they are
currently leading seven to five only one
and a half points until they get match
Victory and with Hikaru Nakamura and Lim
lay look at that three out of three for
limit how are you not gonna score one
and a half
translating the hesitation in Robert's
voice when he agreed that it wasn't over
it was obligatory but part of the reason
I think if I was to kind of dive into
that is because the difference is the
momentum right in this case it's like
the Gotham Knights have the lead and
they already have completed a bit of a
comeback to get there and now it's only
it only feels like the momentum is
getting worse currently for the Berlin
Bears whereas in the other matchup it
didn't it didn't feel so clear that the
momentum was shifted either way and in
fact on paper we kind of knew head into
the last round that the blitz uh still
had one more punch left and so man we've
got 21 000 of you just on our chess
channels here we know that a lot of you
are watching hikaru's channel Levy's
Channel thanks so much for being here
this day has been wild and fun we got we
got uh we got one more round to go
Robert I mean any any anything you want
to say as we head to the break
I'll say that Hikaru Nakamura comes
roaring back for the Gotham Knights but
Lim lay he's been the superstar three
out of three he is leading the way and
for the Gotham Knights it doesn't have
to be Hikaru every single week as long
as they get the job done for the Berlin
bears with their balance roster it's
going to be tough they are trying to
take down some of the best players in
the world but we know kolars we know the
Sonic Brothers they're capable of it
let's not count out uh on board for
Joseph and Heineman she beat Hikaru so
why can't you beat the books I hear it
that's it that's a good phrase for the
rest of that beat Hikaru why can't I
beat this person right we'll see if
Josephine can bottle that up and
everyone else on the Berlin Bears
because they're gonna need it don't go
anywhere it's round four in our last Pro
chess League matchup of the day when we
return
[Music]
foreign
my name is Edward Dawson I'm from
Chicago I'm secret Blackman my name is
Roberto beijer Junior and what I want to
share is I love tacos tacos and chests
so yeah
[Music]
the chess program really even chess in
general like on the deck you uh you kind
of Lose Yourself you don't really think
about your case we learn to think
differently you know you strategize more
I sometimes come out uh 7 30 in the
morning I'll probably play until lock up
you know so it makes my day go by faster
it's competitive it's a lot of trash
talk it's it's crazy you know like the
chess players we got our own little
circle you know and all of us play each
other we talk trash about who be who who
garbage yeah I never played that dude
again he garbage I have a plan but yeah
it's real competitive
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we are back as round four between the
Berlin Bears and the Gotham Knights gets
set to start
International Master Daniel Ranch Grand
Master Robert has here Robert the Gotham
Knights
we're talking about it it's an
internationally diverse team it's a
stack team both in terms of star power
and the actual chess on the board
they're uh they're looking to make moves
this year maybe uh maybe get their name
in the trophy case maybe we need to
approach Leslie cup I wanted to say a
Stanley Cup
but I never really liked the name
Stanley I don't know why I just said
that what do you think it gets comics
and Lee was a legend
okay there you go Stan Lee is a little
different anyway we're good
um the St Louis archbishops are also
pretty good we see they've won three out
of the four years pretty dominant teams
mostly led by Fabiano caruana and Wesley
so we know that they are going to be
very good this year again but uh what do
you think about about the chances for
the Gotham Knights to be one of the
teams we're talking about when all is
said and done
when you have Hikaru Nakamura and Lim
lay of course you have a great chance
but it's about all four boards you just
don't look at the top boards and uh
pay no attention to the bottom you need
a strong Junior and they've got Andy
Woodward he's a yeah he's 12 years old
and they have strong female players as
well it's true you know what isn't
reflected on that previous PCL Champion
slide for the fans who followed those
years no it was very much again stories
like an Andy Woodward I Remember
Nicholas theodoro I remember some of
those names that you you don't think
about they're not fogging on a car one
of Wesley so but they were just as
impactful in helping the St Louis
archbishops and others you see around on
savwani when he was a young gun playing
for Armenia so it's not just the big
names it's it's finding those underrated
hidden gems the ability to work the
rating caps and we know that that's what
every manager is hoping to do to be
there when it's all said and done
let's take a look at the overall
standings to see where we're at it's not
all said and done yet the Berlin Bears
still have a chance Robert I'm going to
ask you to do the same thing we did with
the blitz paint the storyboard comeback
we know it's uphill what has to happen
in this round four for them to have a
chance
well Hikaru Nakamura is playing
provocative chess yes he has won his
last two games but he's giving his
opponent chances rosmisphane he's very
experienced he and colors get the white
pieces but what you need to do is make
at least one point because you can't
give up any more than that on the top
two and hope your bottom two boards can
swing and hit they need to win on those
bottom two boards get one out of two on
the top
and I know they have black but they have
a chance Frederick sonay is is the
favorite you would say against the young
Andy Woodward right nothing against Andy
but he's young right Josephine heinemann
you you called it before the break she's
beating Hikaru so why can't I beat
anybody else right so if you're in the
mindset of both Frederick slonee and
Josephine heinemann this is your
opportunity right you got to own those
bottom two boards and just hope that one
of your top two guys can scave the 3-0
Lim lay and the Hikaru Nakamura uh who's
uh who's rebounder from his first loss
so okay that's the storyboard Ross must
say hey look at that he's like I'm gonna
play I'm gonna play like a Caro here
goes one Knight of three and just by the
way if you are the Berlin bears and you
were told that Josephine heinemann on
board four would have one half out of
three he would take that in a heartbeat
and expect to be leading this match uh
but somehow for the Gotham Knights I
mean they are just dominating on or two
in particular in Lay so here we see a
car he's been playing this with white
now he gets it with black and I like
this from rosmas he should not take big
risks Hikaru wants to win I think that
he is a player who wants to win every
single game he plays he'll make a draw
if he has no other option but he's
looking for a decisive result
yeah
and so you're uh you're gonna mix it up
here and take our plane quickly now with
the C5 symmetry of a couple of C pawns
both of them will probably be lost here
uh for both sides in the next couple
moves now if you're Hikaru are you
trading Queens trying to head to an end
game probably not because it makes
recollecting the uh the C Pawn harder or
are you what is your thoughts on that
my thought is that hikar and Magnus
played in this position and
um this is actually just that so Hikaru
he has studied his openings very deeply
played them against the best players in
the planet but here goes Knight A6
trying to grab this Pawn here on C5 so
if I'm white I'm playing C6 I'm giving
up the pawn on my own terms just to show
you what happens and if we get into a
position uh this well white is clearly
better because there's structural damage
isolated pawns on the queen side whereas
White's Pawn structure is next to one
another
yeah that's a key little shot to
remember in these positions of white
sort of renegade Renegade Desperado
sacks the sea Pawn to destroy black
structure especially when you have that
Bishop on G2 in the long diagonal
targets for the rest of the game so all
right it's funny thinking about it is he
gonna go for C6
he probably he's got to know the Magnus
Hikaru game
he's got to go for C6 here and I mean
hikar was defended this position against
not this exact position but this type of
position against gotta komsky enough
times you know to last a lifetime so I
feel like he doesn't feel too out of
shape if the move and here it is C6
hasn't played great move for
rossmosphane yeah White's gonna have a
little bit of an edge and uh we'll see
how hikara works that one he had more
than a worse position against kolar's
last game but we'll keep our eye on that
as we keep our right now on the bird's
eye view we see that game get board two
excuse me the second game that got
underway was Lim lay versus Dimitri
kolars E5 on the board there that's an
interesting shot
um and then already wow playing very
quickly Frederick slonee and Andy
Woodward are Off to the Races there and
that's sort of Queen's Indian Catalan
type position
right but let's uh you know as three out
of the four boards are underway we have
board two here E5 you pointed out Danny
that's such an odd move to whoa Okay so
and they had pre-moved d66 and white has
established this Pawn structure E4 and
F5 and more space for white but that E4
Pawn Danny I feel like that often
becomes a Target in a position like this
Limelight I feel like coaching looks
good on the guy and what I mean by that
is when he's always been a super Talent
you don't win worldless championships
unless you're a talented guy intuitively
you see things quickly in fast time
controls now that he's a coach Robert
he's staying on The Cutting Edge of
theory he knows what to what knows
what's going on in all these openings
because you as a coach you have to work
with multiple different people with
different opening repertoires right you
got to stay on top of everything and I'm
just looking at a confident Lim lay and
feeling like this looks good on him I
mean I feel like he's playing some of
the best chess we've seen in a while
yeah for sure I mean he just understands
ideas and that's what happens when you
work with the lineup the roster that
Webster University has those lineups are
as good as most Olympiad teams Grand
Master after Grandmaster so if you're
going to coach a Grandmaster you need to
prepare at the highest level and we see
that with B5 he's not really preparing
anything he's just going to throw the
pawn up to B4 and try to get to this E4
pawn and that's going to be the
vulnerable spot in White's position now
you can't prepare it maybe a C5 Bishop
B7 go after the pawn this way I just
don't like the look of this Pawn
structure if you don't get an attack and
there are no queens in the port so what
attack then this is misplaced pawns I
agree he ends up not preparing A5 and B4
but back to the preparation topic we
were talking about the fact that again
it's that he's he's got his hands and
and eyes and and coaching on a lot of
different positions these days I I think
it's reflected on his time he's got he
okay now he's under 10 minutes but he
wasn't a moment ago he had more time
than he started with it just tells you
how confident he is and that he must be
prepared in this position or you or
you're not able to speed through it like
that so let limb cook as they say with
the brilliant symbol agreed let him cook
he might go 4-0 on the day and if he
does that spells bad news for the Berlin
Bears they might be changing their name
to the Billy Bob Thornton sequel bad
Berlin Bears I'll be here all week
uh well that's a shame for everybody who
has to watch you talk then but here we
see H3 played I think the intentions are
relatively clear you can also castle and
there's no Knight G-Force taking that
out of the equation but we could see a
pawn March for Dimitri at some moment I
just don't like the flimsy nature of his
pawns you want to push this one back to
F3 ah it's funny C5 is not liked by the
computer I think it's Bishop G5
instinctively the moment I see cc5 it's
Play Bishop G5 and Knight T5 oh he plays
Knight E5 first no but this is really
really smart because if you take on
takes now the bishop goes to E4 you have
a protected pass paw in the center and
so that is what Dimitri is aiming for
black hat was in no rush to play the
move season five surprising yeah you
could have delayed that by at least a
turn with Bishop B7 first and then C5
and then you cover the D5 square with
your Bishop as well but he rushes it and
now that we're here he takes D5 to any
advantage white this is a pass pawn it
will be defended the king slides up the
Rooks get behind it and now you can't
attack it enough times limlay hasn't
been worse probably in any of his
positions today besides against
Josephine heinemann the board four uh
although he did get to an in-game and
ultimately secure the victory uh all
right we'll come back to check on this
one let's let's head to the bird's eye
view because we do have the other games
started we see Andy Woodward and
Fredericks funny underway a dynamic game
there where Andy Woodward is doing just
fine I also look at this back at that
Hikaru Nakamura game with Rasmus Swanee
because C6 was meant by C3 which leads
to this really kind of just funny
Optical position where you've got a
couple of Pawns hanging on C6 and C3 for
both sides
um Robert your Flavor Flav where you
want to go wow I was not expecting a
Flavor Flav reference on this show but
let's go back to ikaru versus rosmus
that is the born one matchup they
started first which means they have the
lowest time and we see what's going on
in this game it's crazy it's Mayhem yeah
both sides have Pawns in enemy territory
and they're not being captured
yeah so what happened a few moves ago if
we want to bring up the analysis board
we left it right as Rasmus had played
the move C6 going down the the line as
you said with Magnus and icaro but akaro
quickly responded C3 just throws the
pawn right back at him
I like it it's like okay take mine I'll
take yours that's just a trade and then
Knight D4 happens defending this Pawn
opening up the bishop creating a threat
and the Knight comes to D5 it's copy cat
chest it's the exact same position for
both sides but Knight C4 that seems to
have been a step in the wrong direction
you see the eval bar go in Black's favor
after that move
um I'm gonna cheat because I don't know
what it is and wow the move is Knight a
to B5 here just putting pressure on C3
and if Pawn takes of course the bishop
takes back and there's yeah left right
and Center
it's funny because
the the engine giving a little bit of an
advantage to Knight B5 but I agree
totally the tactics could really get
dangerous for black there because the
Knight on D5 is flimsy and if you take
B2 and help by develop in that position
the point is Knight B5 really could have
black on noticed there it's it's hard to
find a move there for black the tactics
are very dangerous yeah you can never
take on C6 the Knight captures back the
95 will be loose after a series of
Trades so we saw Knight C4 and then
Knight B4 for Hikaru which means C2 at
some point can be considered don't count
out Bishop takes Knight on T4 for my
knight C2 with a pin if the queen has to
jump up to the D4 Square
it was a fork but yes I do love forks
and pins you called a you called a fork
and a pin
you called both is that a fin is it a
fapoon
of the food I loved it uh all right well
no you're right you've got pins you've
got Forks you got you got uh
you got all kinds of forking problems I
like to say if your rasm is funny and uh
let's get the fork out of here shall we
head back to bird's eye view let's do it
because uh the C3 C6 pawns will remain
at least for a bit and what else is
happening Danny we liked in the top
right collage's position he doesn't have
a pass Pawn but it looks like uh them
lay is just trying to blockade as best
he can but how about that board four
game it's night versus Bishop
yeah let's do it Natalya buxa versus
Josephine heinemann it's a knight versus
Bishop battle the bishop on A7 has has
purpose because that pawn on D4 is on
the same color so you have your target
but the Knight is is perfect where it
stands the Rooks dominate the e-file so
honestly other than that Bishop
attacking D4 I don't really like any of
Black's pieces I have to agree I laughed
just because I wasn't expecting you to
be that harsh but it's true I'm just
saying it
you're you're saying uh there's a chance
um some say there's a chance that
Black's pieces could get could get real
bad real quick here I mean you bring the
Rook into the seventh rank I don't see a
follow-up immediately but
it's a it's a tough position for
Josephine here and also a two minute
almost a two minute time Advantage for
buxa it's also hard to know what pieces
to trade because even if you get one
pair of Rooks off the Border even both
pairs of Rooks maybe the bishop Gets
outclassed By The Knight the D5 Pawn is
threatened so you can't even move this
Rook from d8 anytime soon and rookie
seven like just go for it throw that
Rook up if you want to uh black just
doesn't have an active plan it's just a
passive position
agreed agreed agreed
you could even do the old the old shift
to the other side of the board okay like
I don't want to play for cheapos but I'm
pointing out that the F7 Pawn is tender
if we get the Rook to the seventh rank
there's Queen E3 Queen F4 and and in
some cases if Black's Queen is on the
wrong Square you suddenly in a position
where you have no way to defend obvious
threats and black position falls apart
on the king side no this is a really bad
position for black you just have no plan
whatsoever the only thing that
potentially black can do is reroute this
bishop to B8 but you still don't have an
attack because the Knight covers the H2
Square Never Gonna threaten Checkmate uh
but at least you'll flush this Rook at
E5 where it keeps The Rook on d8 tied
down to this Pawn I really don't envy
this defensive task I think that Natalia
buxar she's trying to be precise here
she doesn't want to throw away her
Advantage but it's bad dues for the
Bears even if buxa draws right they're
one and a half points away from winning
this match and the Bears need to sort of
get Victory somewhere and and just draw
two games and win two others
well in a Twist of events though if we
go back to the bird's eye view Lim lay
is is not in a great spot he's been
dominant all day so you know Dimitri
kolars is is doing okay I'm not saying
colors wins but he's pressing and
Frederick's funny is is doing okay as
black let's check in on his battle with
Andy Woodward because we haven't really
seen the board three matchup yet in this
final round uh how did that pony get on
D6 we we leave it to the imagination
until we bring up the board and find out
I'll show you the night was on B5 the
pawn pushed up to C5 and then the Knight
came into D6 I was trying to do a
material count by the way because the
pawn structure is weird these double
pawns for black double icy pawns but C5
can be grab but is there some kind of
like Knight coming in with the queen
joining the party yeah I see it is a
four straw I think he's got a draw
check
and check he he realizes it
oh my gosh
he realizes that Andy Woodward peeks
down at the clock peeks down maybe at
the zoom they can see each other just so
those of you who don't know what happens
the behind the scenes version and
putting these shows together again shout
out to the team who works super hard
they're all in a zoom call for fair play
reasons they can see each other they can
see their fair play view of their
opponent so sometimes that Peak is them
just kind of looking at their opponent's
reaction and uh
yeah it's a just a draw I'm gonna show
everybody what's likely to happen Okay
the king will go back and forth but that
is allowing the draw the king cannot
step to the side Queen H6 would deliver
mate that is a three-time repetition
when the King goes back to G but Denny
is he really thinking about King h8
allowing the queen in sliding The Rook
over it doesn't work though it doesn't
I'll show why I mean an analysis board
so I can let's do why this does not work
is that you're taking me through there
you're defending G7 that's the mate and
after Knight F6 you're threatening I see
it can I can I say it can I say it go
for it Queen takes G7 and 428
yeah I mean should I was I supposed to
play 98 first okay
no this looks good just winning all the
material no but I think 98 first was
even better
yeah we don't care that it's better
Danny 98 yes that wins the queen because
Checkmate is there but rook's enough
don't be greedy even when I take the the
mic I mess it up by the way I've been
told by production team in this format
players are everything I said double
double Zoom fair play cam team working
hard but they actually are not in the
same room we put them in separate
breakout rooms so they actually cannot
see their opponents uh in this format so
there you go fun fact
okay good to know but uh not good for
Frederick smone to know the game is
about to be a draw he's really really
upset with himself yeah because he
recognized that he had a chance to win
this game he allows an immediate draw
and finally Knight F6 of course the drug
just to show everybody that capturing
Knight at any point would have allowed
this draw here King has to go to h8
that's a check you can get all the go to
G this is a known mechanism you should
put that in the memory bank and that
allows Andy Woodward to secure a very
important half point for his team
yeah that's huge uh we we storyboarded
heading into this round what had to
happen and it started with Fredericks
funny getting a victory because he is
the favorite on paper but that's why you
bring in the Young Guns Andy Woodward
you expect them to over perform their
rating and to defy those statements like
hey this other guy what's the favorite
on paper so that draw
is huge for the Gotham Knights all they
need now is one point out of three
remaining games you can get that with
two draws or a single victory
we bought four Natalia buxo with the
white pieces she is in the driver's seat
Black's pawns on the kings that are
shattered The Rook is active for white
that's bad news but also in the top
right look at Dimitri colors go we talk
about how strong he is he's been around
the protest league for many seasons now
he is much better and pressing forward
against Lemley
I like it I like it Lim lay doesn't want
his perfect day to get away hey
we're rhyme timing
um hey what a wonderful kind of day says
Arthur you want to go eat some hay maybe
hang out by the bay what do you say
um all right the uh the position is
tough for black rhyme time aside the G
file is opening up and that it's not
even just that you might you know be
worried about a past H Pawn here you
might get mated if you're not careful
and he's got meat on the brand surprise
surprise but he brings the Rook back and
that was a mistake that was a huge error
and what is the reason I guess you could
take this Pawn on H6 as your Bishop
defends but there might even be better
take H6 you're winning the exchange uh I
don't I don't see anything better than
that
the fact that you relieved the pressure
on the uh sorry on the B2 Pawn from the
A2 Square means that now both Rooks are
sort of free to wander you're no longer
tying anything down if you're black this
is trouble for lin Lang yeah it is and
actually I think part of the reason why
is that this Pawn on G5 is super strong
it keeps the pawn on F7 stuck in place
so even if we were to see some trades
white would shift gears to the f file he
goes first the G file and then he might
take on E3 it just doesn't help matters
at all I think black's gonna lose at
least a pawn and maybe more as white
Rooks swing on the G F and H files I
love that tension move that Rook G1 move
just build the tension baby build on the
tension
colors did that by the way took out C5
instantly King E3 to follow Here Comes
Rook F2 Here Comes Rook F1 bring this
Rook nope not there up to F6 and then
your d-pawn don't forget about that
that's a passer
yeah and and if black just tries to
buckle down and play you know stubborn
defense the H5 Pawn is hanging in a lot
of cases so whether whether it's bishop
or three Retreat or a rook swing into H6
eventually so this is problematic and uh
this isn't the story we were expecting
limb Lay's been dominant but uh if
collars gets this dub I want to go back
to the bird's eye view because I want to
know like what are the chances the
comeback is in store it's hard when
you're Frederick's funny dropping the
draw against Andy Woodward what else do
we have here
it looks like Hikaru Nakamura slightly
better against razzmosphane who does not
have much time so akara may even win the
match for the Gotham Knights if he could
take that game and look at the bottom
right by the way uh the evaluation says
no longer a huge Advantage for white the
black root gets active the D4 Pawn is
targeted uh this is an end game and
maybe chances for Josephine heinemann
yeah and after that move Rook E6 we
could be petering out to a draw which is
also favorable for the knights because
at this point they just need to inch
from their way to that eight and a half
Point score everybody eight and a half
points wins you can see it in the upper
left corner of your screen all right
let's go check back in with Hikaru you
mentioned that Rasmus funny is under
time pressure I agree with you that's
that's uh that's got my drama meter up
I've got a drama meter inside of me and
sometimes it you know depends on what's
going on there's there is drama here
there's a Checkmate being threatened if
white can pass the move somehow I don't
even know how to do that uh but let's
say H3 Knight E2 and Rook C1 check I'm
threading meat on each one if your king
goes and after this I take it
bam Checkmate on each one that would end
the game so look the last we played F3
by Rasmus fine that is a brave move to
play because your king feels a bit
vulnerable but you have shut down the
diagonal but it's a good move maybe King
F2 next right you're preparing for the
Queens to come off the board already
activating that King I like I mean okay
I still like hikaru's chances and you
already point out the time Advantage is
a big one for Nakamura but uh but I like
F3 a lot keeps this game going yeah I
think that white needs to centralize
because Queen D2 was a big threat that's
what the King goes up to F2 to protect
both the ones but oh that's a pin that's
nasty that's a pin
that's a pin
hey
it's a bin what move do you have
Queen G5 apparently
but uh now before I was just gonna say
B4 is hanging I think
you protect your Pawn E7 and then you
have a past a pawn that's hard to stop
you could also play a move like E6 if
you just want to be patient it also
reinforces or E5 I was going to say the
same ideas you have Knight D5 coming
okay now Rasmus is trying to desperately
get the Queens off
um which your car just might oblige him
well I mean I think hikara needs to know
what's going on in the other games
because yeah you you don't really want
to play for a win if a draw secures the
match a card is an experienced player in
olympiads and World Team Championships
he goes F5 he is not even playing for a
win at this point he's just making the
best moves and yeah black is very active
The Rook slams in first White's just
hopping oh God yeah this is it's just
it's painful to see here comes Rook C4
the Knight on A1 is uh
the Knight on A1 is not having any fun
huh no how's that
um it wants nicely too though he wants
to get there that's a good move
uh 410 oh he didn't miss it
I got nervous
wait a second Danny if Hikaru doesn't
just secure a draw in the near future he
might be worse he isn't isolated Pawn on
D4 and the white king is very active
yeah the Deep one quickly becomes a
Target King D2 King D3 the White Knight
comes back to C2 if that D4 Pawn Falls
and also don't underestimate White's
long-term winning chances there because
a night and game four versus three on
the king side is winnable for spawn a
like that's not a that's not an end game
that uh there's a guaranteed draw at all
and I see a blunder potential so if he
can bring analysis support up very
quickly I just want to show a tactic
that that might happen if you're not
careful let's say H6 King up and Knight
B5 E4 check is nasty if you take with
the pawn I take back your King has to go
you lose your Rook if you take on
passage the Knight joints and that is a
fork one of those rare moments where
ampa song brings you pain it's almost
always fun there's a moment where you
don't want to on passan
okay Hikaru gets the king over I think
we are still likely to be equal
because the beat the B Pawn Falls
and uh Hikaru has held on does he wants
some kind of like creative pieces
by the way Lim lay is going down against
collars so shout out to the guy who was
keeping his team in it Dimitri kolars
taken down the 3-0 Lim lay
uh the other game though likely also
would draw maybe but Danny look rookie
two oh okay this probably wins too oh
rookie two would have traded Rooks on
the spot yeah
that would have been a little more
forcing but now Hikaru back to driving
driving this one home
if you told Hikaru he was going to
finish the day 3-1 and his team would
win he'd probably take it if he told him
he was going to lose his first game to
board four he'd be like say what
yeah I think it's a shocker for a car
but I mean he's just the king of the
comeback
here he goes he's advancing and now
after Rook a two okay he brings the king
in first but uh The Mating net along
with the pass d-pawn is enough for
Nakamura to get it done and with the
resignation it's officially in the books
the Gotham Knights get the victory here
today over the Berlin bears they do it
but it was super close here because now
they've eight and a half points and
Natalia buxa she's in a rook end game up
a pawn in the bottom right that should
be a draw is theoretically uh in a drawn
end game but we have one game left in
the top right Dimitri colorism you've
been shouting him out all day he's just
trying to convert this end game against
super Grandmaster Lim I was gonna say
but shout out to Lynn Lane because I was
kind of calling it I thought kolars had
it let's take that game let's bring that
game up because Dimitri kolars has kind
of let this one slip a little bit I
it's not so okay eval bar still loves
white but
okay
maybe it's easier than I thought
I think you just go for the queen side
pawns but he goes Rook F2 the evaluation
bar is doing some pull-ups going up and
down with every single move
uh he wants to get his Rook around
yeah
okay
but not done just yet Daniel I mean you
see that it's winning for white but
colars has not found the knockout just
yet
I'm looking for Rook C1 Rook C2 sorry
I'm just you know I'm uh a squirrel
looking for a nut here all right looking
for some tricks some way for black
okay there you go you get you get it
this way again still winning for colors
but time pressure
will make people do crazy things and I'm
just uh there's a stalemate not not yet
but potential now
yeah if you played Rook G7 well first of
all this Pawn just goes uh but I think
you just take and then you win with this
Pawn because the king is so far away
there you go all right
okay all right now
now we got it and again despite this
game and and the game between Natalya
buxa and Josephine heinemann still going
the match is over
Dimitri colors will win this one
in style with the bridge by the way
um and there you go eight and a half
five and a half currently the score the
Gotham Knights have secured the match
Victory and uh shout out to them for
doing so after after starting off on the
wrong foot uh and as we say that Dimitri
collage did take down
live life so all right we should
probably check out and let the last game
finish bird's eye view means that we
should take a look at Natalia books's
game versus Josephine heinemann just to
at least wrap up what's happening there
and make sure that uh that we don't miss
anything crazy
should be a draw theoretically but these
positions are harder to hold sometimes
Than People realize even though it
doesn't matter for the overall score
these two ladies still trying to get it
done yeah because this pin along the
seventh rank could encourage G Pawn push
but that's why the Rook is staying in
contact with the F5 pump the King goes
back let's check you away and it's hard
to make progress right now but I just
want to point out Danny that Lim lay he
tried to get sneaky and cheeky against a
collars he actually lost his he gave up
his Rook he tried to catch him in a
pre-move
didn't work out so a win for colars
there
I love it I love the final the final
premium tricks you know
it's what the people show up for
all right this one as you said should be
an easy draw there's always an outside
chance that uh that you can mess it up
if the Jeep will can somehow trick the F
Pawn if it's pinned on the seventh rank
but really uh really nothing to this
position
nope they're going back and forth The
Rook pins the pawn on F5 still no G5
because your Pawn is hanging on F5 the
only way to get this done is to bring
your Rook back around but then you're
super passive which is not what you want
so Rook F4 might be next we could see
this move and Josephine by the way great
clock management
yeah staying up on the clock ensures you
won't beat yourself in these games right
usually the only way these Things Fall
Apart is when you get under time
pressure while trying to defend and then
you blunder a drawn in game so a little
bit of time means you should be able to
figure it out when your opponent does
something like that G5 Now The Rook
should slide to A1 and open The
Floodgate Of checks
that's right but I mean white is a
couple moves away from just winning this
game so you have to be really really
careful here if you're black the last
thing you want to do is see this Pawn
get to F6 and The Rook Patrol the last
rank going to the update Square so
that's why she's leaning forward this is
okay this is what we talk about right
now here comes time pressure now she's
leaning in and Rook A1 is definitely
dead okay she does find it and that's
usually what you're waiting for here
chat is is the g-pawn to push because
now that that King doesn't have any
squares to hide on like it did before on
G5 so that's why Rook G1 because what
white wants is to play F6 and get the
king out with check if the King goes H7
so Rook G1 just keeps that King stuck on
the yeah five square okay she finds it
so this is an instructive thing to show
if you want to improve your Rook endings
The Rook waited laterally on the a file
keeping keeping Advance advancement
difficult for the pawns but the moment
that pawn advances and it opens up the
king to to the checks if you switch the
Rook behind the pawns and uh you let the
floodgates let the flood gates loose so
assuming she holds this you will have
seen an instructive endgame here for
Josephine heinemann and uh good stuff
anyway I like to learn on these shows
you're doing the learning you're doing
the teaching and I think Josephine
heinemann is going to earn this draw
King goes H7 the pawn on G5 in contact
with the Rook the king can't escape
anywhere it would love to get around to
a square like F5 but it's not crossing
the G file with the rook in its place
yeah agreed and again instructive to see
how you hold these ending games and uh
good stuff there Natalya buxa gave it
everything she had and it's good you
know you're building you're playing a
season here right you want to get better
with every game so it's not just the
fact that your team is won you're trying
to improve and uh
see if you can Swindle your opponents in
these big moments
and uh
apparently we've been swindled because
now we're on camera and we're not
looking at the chess
there we go hey everybody uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
just holding here right okay and if you
don't play the king back to H5 the black
plays King G6 so just you know adding
flavor to what's going on here okay now
she allows King G6 and okay books that
could have played it but didn't
yeah all of a sudden if King G6 happens
black could try to win you know it's
like I was gonna say like
if King H4 now I play King G6 if I'm
Josephine all right they finally
repeated the game enough that the server
says we're tired of this server says
draw the position was repeated three
times and and just like that the final
score is nine to seven in favor of the
Gotham Knights overall
uh you know Lynn lay led the way
ultimately him and Hikaru were even in
their dominant performances to help lead
the Gotham Knights of Victory Robert
your thoughts well Josephine heinemann
scores two out of four that's board four
for the Berlin Bears if you go into a
match and you say your board four will
score you think I'm gonna win definitely
but unfortunately the brothers funny had
a tough day they scored one and a half
out of four each of them it wasn't meant
to be for the Berlin bears and you see
at the top the Gotham Knights led by
Hikaru Nakamura Lem lay and then Andy
Woodward and Natalia books are chipping
in with one half points each that was a
team effort
I love I love what you pointing out
there because it's true I mean if you're
the Berlin Bears the one bright spot to
build upon is hey Josephine heinemann
she crushed board for you you're right
if you told anybody your board four will
get a victory and two draws we're gonna
win right and unfortunately though uh
for the Bears Hikaru and Lim lay were
ultimately pretty dominant and also Andy
Woodward
to the other side did his job as well uh
from a board three perspective and so
did Italia buxa so okay shout out to the
Gotham Knights who get that Victory and
uh I would give a shout out to the fact
that we're going to be joined One More
Time by the manager and captain of the
Gotham Knights the uh the aptly named
Gotham chess will be with us soon so get
your questions ready chat start bringing
them because we're going to ask them to
Levy Rosman don't go anywhere it's the
final moments for today's pro chess
League coverage when we return
kit is fun Jess is great for the brain
but it's also fun to play and chess kid
makes it easy to have fun whether your
child is a total beginner or a prodigy
they can hop on and find a well-matched
opponent from around the world at any
time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids that feels just like playing
the chess is a great way to learn
patience strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to Mastery there
are more than fifty thousand chess
vessels and a whole library of
entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
yep
I'm here
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody on what has been
an epic day of pro chess League matchups
we're joined by the the captain of the
team that won our last matchup of the
day the Gotham Knights uh here is Gotham
chess Levy just high level questions the
nerves are they gone now as a captain
you've seen your team get the job done
here in their first matchup and and how
you feeling
yeah yeah I have to say I was never I
was never super nervous I uh I would
have probably been more nervous if
if it was still like a one and a half or
two point lead after two rounds but our
team just struck back in the most
emphatic of Fashions so and then we
never trailed after that so it was great
uh yeah I never really had a chance to
get nervous so I appreciated that what
kind of score do you feel like would
make you nervous like how close do you
have to be to feel like your team has a
chance
uh I mean okay when you're trailing by
like two points but listen I gotta tell
you like uh in in the matchup
specifically today I think two points
would be a maximum I think in most other
matchups if we play another team like
the blitz uh which we we might play them
next week like they also have two Titans
on board one and two yeah I don't want
to trail by that much it would not be
nice
it did feel that despite the early upset
and that crazy moment of Hikaru losing
to the board four as it got closer to
the board one versus Board One board two
versus Board two the strength of Hikaru
and Lim lay really showed but let's
let's bring up actually scores and we'll
let you break it down for us Levy let's
start with uh we'll go reverse order
starting with Intel Natalia books on
board four your thoughts on how she
fared today and is one and a half uh
point something you you were hoping for
coming in
uh it's more than what we're hoping for
yeah uh to win a clutch scramble against
a guy who's probably the best player on
the other team I mean he might be but
they're bored too but I I don't know
it's very close right it's very very
close they have a very young team uh for
her to win that is ridiculous I mean
it's literally one square this whole
match was almost decided by one square
he moves his King to G1 like she doesn't
win that game it's a draw right like uh
just half points here and there one
point here and there so um amazing job
this is exactly what you want when you
have a two Titan matchup very balanced
on the top boards in different Fashions
you know you hope for two wins two draws
and if you're two IMS can get you three
points like that's that's a match sealer
right there well speaking of the other I
am your thoughts on Andy Woodward the
youngster sorry Robert still you're
still your thunder there but I'm just
gonna ask like Andy Woodward right this
guy this this kid
oh awesome uh like you can't ask for
more I mean for him to go minus one
against uh against their their their
lineup okay he had black right against
their board four it's not easy you can't
just beat 2400s on demand unless you're
like Hikaru or Magnus right uh it's uh
it was a good fight and he drew two of
their best players and you saw his game
against collars like colors just
steamrolled him out the gate like colors
is really really good he's great he has
a great playing style so uh I don't
think Andy Woodward should uh uh should
feel bad at all I mean I think he
performed exactly what we needed him to
do and you know what's crazy guys in
about three hours he is starting a nine
round tournament here in the U.S so this
dude played this match and now he has a
classical chess tournament to play
wow I mean that's unbelievable so I
guess I have to ask was it hard to get
him to agree to play today knowing that
he has to go and play an over-the-board
tournament
no he was like I'll play
like do you do you want to not play
because we have we have like another we
have a very strong I am uh we have
Nicola Bortnick like Bortnick is a very
good you know he's 2900 3 000 online
like we but Andy was like no I want to
play and you can't ask for much more I
mean three draws okay he lost the game
but we won the match so he he stole
points from the 2600s that's exactly
what you want 12 year olds are a lot
like computers they don't get tired
they're not they don't they don't have
that yet right so he's like no I mean
I'll play what are you kidding me I got
I got a norm tournament coming up NPD
bro uh well speaking of no big deal the
last two guys to give your thoughts on
your top two double guns as you said got
it done you mentioned uh one two punches
like Alexander grishek and Maxine Bashe
the grab so I'm gonna ask you to do two
things with this question evaluate how
they finish today is 3-1 acceptable also
how do you think your one-two punch
Stacks up against the other best one-two
punches in the league
um
that's a great question I mean the only
one that's on my mind right now is
Grisha Campbell who I I don't remember
who else is in our our little area like
who else won do you guys have that on
hand uh Magnus Magnus no but they're but
they're not but they're not they don't
play with us they're in the other they
play Tuesday Wednesday so on Thursday
Friday I just don't remember
um I mean mvl and grishook is like
terrifying right like that's that that's
that's a really big one they have a very
scary team because they have a young
talented player on board three just like
we do and uh they have a the third
ranked woman in the world like uh got
Serena Lago she's like 2560 GM as their
board for like as their female player
yeah they're like an insane team I mean
when you play them you just it's the
same thing it's just like stealing half
points I don't know I mean um every team
is so good and these matches come down
to these little scrambles and uh I have
no clue what to expect but um listen
I'll take six out of eight from our top
two because you need eight and a half
right like and then it's up to the three
and four to figure it out but every
player is important on these teams like
every player even if it's four versus
four in the last round if your board
four has to win like every Point matters
so
um but I I would put Hikaru and Liam up
there especially if the Liam that played
like he did today shows up uh we can
give Magnus and Geary a good fight I
mean that's the you know obviously you
want to see Hikaru Magnus in the end of
the day but uh I'll I'll I think we're
right up there I think we have one of
the most balanced and best teams in the
league but time will tell
yeah wow yeah no well sorry and you want
to go just go Danny just do it
well I was gonna say I mean I feel like
I already know the answer to this one
but we had a feature chat question come
in from the uh if you had to pick fight
of the night BJ h13 wants to know which
one would you pick I know which one I
would pick but if you had to give a
fight of the night game of the day to
one of your players like you're you're
coming in you're Levy Rosman you're the
coach you've got the ball who does the
game ball go to today
um oh that's a good question uh it's
probably it's a shame he he ended with a
loss but I feel like if Liam had drawn
or I mean even won the last game I I
feel like Liam like Liam is who you look
to after the first round and maybe the
second round like all right let's see
how he's doing and I mean my man in the
first two games was just vaporizing the
opposition and that kind of allowed
kikaru to that's the thing about these
team events like okay Hikaru might have
that hiccup in the first game and the
second game it's like a massive fight
meanwhile you just look at Liam and he's
just like
I mean it's just one after the like
bring him up like let's go let's go so
maybe Liam but uh everyone shine today
and I mean okay Hikaru comes back it
just wins three games like it's nothing
in this last round game he was sitting
there going oh my God I'm losing and
within five moves he was winning it's
like it's just magic I mean they all win
games in different ways you know what I
mean and uh Liam was incredible today
but uh yeah they're they're really good
they're a really good one-two punch let
me tell you and um
we'll see what uh we'll see what the
season holds because there's like that
big three the lineup of death you can
have a GM on board four too you grab a
GM on board five just four GM lineup if
you play the numbers right so
um I'm hyped for the PCL this season
yeah
go ahead we got a couple more feature
chat questions to run through here while
we've got Levy well I actually just
wanted to ask a quick question for
myself about your how did you get lamb
Li because he is the coach at Webster I
mean he has ties elsewhere what was that
negotiation process like because we
heard about Hikaru I'm curious about I'm
late
yeah it was tough because we wanted to
pair a Hikaru like okay I mean if you
can't get Magnus you're gonna get Hikaru
right I mean that's okay like clearly
number one number two punch in the world
in the speed format and then we just
kind of went down the list of 2700s and
we did it really strategically we wanted
someone who is on our time like isn't in
Russia has to play at three in the
morning uh and uh that's not easy like a
lot of guys don't live
in in the states a lot of guys are in
Europe a lot of guys might have to play
super late uh and we just went down the
list and I actually spoke to a niche and
he told me well I'm gonna play for the
bras and I thought okay you know Anish
probably wants to be a board one uh they
signed Magnus so like nobody really
could have seen that coming uh so that
one Niche might even have to be aboard
too and uh yeah I just kind of went like
you know Liam like you're interested in
playing this yeah absolutely like who's
on the team I said Hikaru he's like I'm
in and um yeah the rest of it was sort
of like okay who can we fit on board
three without sacrificing a board four
and we did we did the more balanced
approach which is what we did today like
I am on board three a lot of teams have
a GM on board three but then we saw some
teams Can field like 2580 GM on board
three and like 2300 women and we're like
oh my God I mean this is just just can
get this death lineup out here so we
started playing we looked at all the
people in the world at like 25 60 25 70
and we found the Uzbek Superstar sham
season Walk it off he was like a world
under 20 gold medalist and three months
ago he was 40 points lower rated and we
used the November 2022 ratings so
um we have of flexibility in our lineup
and I I'm just curious to see how it
goes but I'm worried
last thing I was gonna say is like I'm
worried because haven't you guys seen
like some of these matchups come down to
like
10 seconds literally like a mouse slip
and the whole match is over and it's so
so close
Dwayne Jones knows something about that
and Hannah no I was gonna say I love I
love hearing you talk about it because
obviously people know you as as Gotham
chess I don't know if you I don't know
if you knew that that you have a YouTube
channel people know you about that they
know you as a content creator but
hearing the level of thought detail
obviously you and your man Alex
ostrovsky uh put into this is
interesting you're looking for those
guys like it was 40 points lower rated
for the official supplement and there's
there's just a lot of fun strategy that
goes into that and I think as the season
goes on and you see some of those
stories come to life some of those
underrated less known players ultimately
play Hero right I was gonna say I I
think the game ball today goes to
Natalia buxa for that game but you know
I missed that I'll give you another
question peepee and Pampers I don't know
what that username's referring to that
seems like an odd name to bring up
um whatever PP and Pampers wants to know
all this talk about how your team played
are you not tempted to play yourself
after watching no no absolutely okay
good no no no what do you you want us to
lose every match
no no no no no no
no well we can invent a new format where
if only there was a tournament where
like people who weren't GMS played every
once in a while like I'm not at like you
say I'm not a GM or something and you
play yeah I'm not a GM yeah what is this
like an official uh sneak peek preview
when does that happen maybe a PCL I'm
not a GM who knows I'm watching Four IMS
play 4ams well unless they're Woodward
and buxa then yeah yeah I don't want to
play the kids anymore um there's a
reason I didn't let minlay play in the
first I'm not a GM I was like that guy
should be a GM he's not allowed to play
he's going to kill you this one now it's
not fun and he is one now so go ahead
Robert yeah he got to escape that but
there's another question from chess wind
and asking is there some kind of team
prep for each match-up or do they just
play it on the go and I just want to
follow that up with you mentioned Alex
ostrowsky being a prominent coach does
he offer his help for the players as
they prepare for their opponents
ah they have it they they they
definitely uh they have they have us
help if if they need it but uh listen
um Hikaru is more than a professional
Liam is more than a professional and um
I mean like even Andy Woodward I mean
works with a lot of Grandmasters so
everyone is well prepared I think
everybody's taking it quite seriously I
mean Natalia showed up today with super
good prep so uh the thing is like most
players do not have the luxury to show
up and do whatever they want still get
three points and uh guys like Hikaru and
Magnus can like literally just roll out
of bed and score you know three out of
four uh three and a half four out of
four in magnus's case
um with you know some bumps and bruises
here and there but
um yeah I mean maybe once the season
gets like on and on and now suddenly
we're playing for like number one or
Championship that that'll happen but for
now I think this was kind of a feeler
first round and luckily it went our way
yep I think that question was from chess
win not bjh by the way so um anyway
shout out to chasmine we just want all
of our users to get the love that they
deserve uh Levy I hope you're feeling
the love your team got it done you
deserve it enjoy the victory uh have a
have a fun Thursday evening go go make
some videos or something
um you know about your team's Victory I
think I don't know yeah I think that's
what's gonna happen I'm pretty sure
that's the game plan yeah Hikaru has
been beating me to these Recaps
sometimes you know putting them out
first and uh that's that's all I got in
this world I just got the first guy I I
can't play the games I just got to post
the recap so all right man but seriously
though congratulations this is a lot of
fun I agree with you the PCL is going to
be a blast this year congrats to the
team and I can't wait to see how the
Gotham might shake out
thanks guys thanks for having me
congratulations peace Levy Rosman the
captain slash manager of the Gotham
Knights and I off to make recap videos
Robert uh yeah the recap is interesting
of this one it is a final score that we
could have predicted it was dramatic
though along the way and uh
congratulations to Gotham Knights and
we'll see how the Bears rebound next
week
yeah big win for Gotham Knight so he
said lemon lay at the top that would be
his fight of the night you mentioned
Natalia book says she eat Dimitri colors
and that that's the game that separated
this right like it looked like colors
was going to win had he won that game it
would have been eight to eight so it all
comes down to those waning seconds when
the clock is ticking the time is
dwindling whichever player can keep
composure maintain their nerves and go
on to win that's what separates teams in
this league it's that close
you might think this has been the most
amazing week ever I'll take a break over
the weekend for the protest League to
come back next week nay there is pro
chess League tomorrow and you want to
tune in for that tomorrow's matchup the
St Louis archbishops their reputation
precedes them they have won three of the
four protesting championships and they
make their 2023 debut against the
Shanghai tigers and then you got the
Croatia Bulldogs versus the California
unicorns also going to be a fun one
Robert which match up do you uh most
look forward to tomorrow
well I gotta say I mean we're probably
gonna have a god mature join us on the
broadcast with the Croatia Bulldogs I
hope so so the Bulldogs versus the
unicorns that one will be very exciting
the unicorns led by Sam Shanklin uh the
Bulldogs they don't have the biggest
names but they do have that kind of like
Street chest style some Fighters there
they are not going to go down without
swinging but of course Fabiano caruana
Wesley so everybody that you can name
that's 2700 plus is on St Louis they're
super strong but Shanghai you don't want
to look past them Jew and June's on
their team and they have so many
Grandmasters that can fill up their
lineup this is just a tough matchup
there's nowhere to turn without seeing a
very very strong team yeah the Shanghai
team representing a lot of players from
China as those who follow the league
know it was the show and do pandas and
the China pandas and they
I feel like they were this close to
winning a championship compared to any
other team Robert who hasn't quite done
it yet so they they are not fun to play
and even though it's Fabian on car one
and Wesley so I'm expecting an absolute
barn burner in that one so all right
well
I'm uh
I'm sad to say it's over Robert I've
enjoyed the day with you despite the
rumors
sorry what rumors are you talking about
if you didn't hear about those then
let's just leave that
um anyway I really had a great time and
this has been awesome the protest league
is back I'm as excited as anybody it's
like a kid in the candy store with this
one and I hope that everyone enjoyed it
thank you for tuning in shout out to the
team crushing it behind the scenes
everybody working hard uh the production
team the fair play crew all the mods who
make sure that this gets done peace out
enjoy the two matchups tomorrow I will
be back next week with some protest
League coverage Robert you got the call
tomorrow
and uh enjoy the show tomorrow with
Robert and Donya until then everybody
we will see you next time
[Music]
foreign